[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
that my friends is a chess legacy
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid for the first time in 30 years
spain's capital plays host to the
candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
and he definitely knows that he hasn't
made his 40 oh no
oh my goodness
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
[Music]
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess
yet still chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before
them miss amigos
the next challenger to the world
champion of chess must come through
madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
miss amigos welcome back to the 12th
round of the 2022 fide candidates we are
live in madrid spain at the palacio de
centonia as you see in front of you the
flags they're blowing in the wind the
fans are trickling in to see the live
commentary the action unfold and here we
see the chess.com spanish team as some
people are sitting down getting ready
for their favorite commentary sessions
and we are live in the venue the players
not quite seated at their chairs yet
that's chandler he's the videographer
for chess.com taking
so much of this great content and
dingley wren the smallest chair in the
room but the player who's on a big
winning streak welcome everybody this is
international master almira skripchenko
grandmaster daniel neroditzky i am
grandmaster robert hess and we are super
excited to be here almira yesterday
another really battle fought day well
jan scored such an important victory
yesterday he is getting closer and
closer to the tournament victory but
it's not over yet
certainly isn't overdone yeah it
absolutely isn't we've been commentating
tournaments for a long time we've been
watching tournaments for a very very
long time and we've seen crazier things
happen so the tournament is not in the
bag none of the players think it's in
the bag all of them have had their own
crazy experiences so this is reason
enough to cancel all of your obligations
and watch the last three rounds very
carefully it is the weekend and what's
in the bag is three wins in a row for
dingley wren he beat five in a car when
the with the black pieces and yon
napomchi did the same against alireza
almira
well first of all uh jingleren
realized such a tour de force as french
would say and i think that you used this
expression in english he won three games
in a row and
he
is he certainly wants more
and young he beat alive
who was in a very difficult situation
tournament situation he had nothing to
lose but he played in somewhat like what
i would call a cavalier fashion and he
lost almost without a fight he did
indeed and well danya hikara nakamura he
tried his very best 90 plus move game
against richard report icaro is in a
great spot in the tournament so he's
trying to take some risk without playing
anything crazy richard report essayed
the slveshnikov sicilian for the first
time in his career now we know report is
one of the most unpredictable players in
the tournament that's what makes him so
fun to watch hikaru he chose a pretty
solid continuation
at one point toward the ending it seemed
like icaru had
acquired winning chances but richard
reports and game defense was stellar and
realistically there was never a concrete
winning chance of the game
very justifiably ending in peace and the
other game between timor java versus
yanchus of duda ended in peace but all
eyes were on jan napomnishi as he took
down alireza fruga here is your recap
from round 11.
prior to round 11 ali reza ferrugia
decompressed before his game with the
tournament leader yan napomnishi by
playing hundreds of online hyper bullet
games
many of them against commentator daniel
naredicki who won their match
inevitably questions arose about ali
reza's preparedness for the game he
played the first novelty in a unique
line in the petrov knight to d4
after nepo's natural queen to b6 alireza
struggled to find a way to untangle his
queen side and he struck out first with
the dubious but playable g4 and then
with the extremely aggressive probably
overly aggressive h4
yan calmly sipped his tea
stared ali reza down and began targeting
his pieces towards ali reza's weaknesses
on move 21 nepo rapidly offered a piece
with knight takes f4 check and he
followed up a few moves later with the
beautiful hammer blows 24 bishop takes
g5 and 26 rook takes d4
though alireza defended stoutly after
his knight wandered into b7 nepo's
bishops and rook were able to turn their
attention to a vicious attack on the
king with either checkmate or
catastrophic material losses looming
alireza resigned
with 8 out of 11 which as chatters noted
is a score more typically seen entitled
tuesday than in the candidates nepo has
not yet mathematically clinched first
place but even his competitors are
starting to concede that he has
essentially locked up a victory
wow wow wow yonda pomshy the devil is in
the details and he scores another nice
victory with the black pieces and almira
i mean that game yesterday it was
probably a lot to do with an over-eager
alareza
well alive
certainly overpressed it as chess
players might say and what a different
trajectory for both players uh alireza
is clearly lost he's at the bottom of
the standings
lead in the tournament and what i wanted
to say that it might come as a surprise
to you but uh yom nipomnishi has never
crossed the 2800 barrier and after this
game you know he reached his all-time
high and he is galloping towards the
2800 he wants that rating spot just like
he wants another shot at the world
championship title and dania on the
other side of things already for ruja he
was at 2800 his rating has been dropping
but these players who may be at the
bottom of the standings they will play
their part down the final stretch of the
candidates they absolutely will we
should not underestimate the role that
raiding plays in motivating these
players they are not just going to give
any games away just because first or
second place is out of reach so that
group on the bottom alireza richard
report
jkd if anything with nothing to lose
they might play some of their best chess
in these last three rounds of the
tournament so we shouldn't take our eyes
off of them and we certainly shouldn't
take our eyes off of the group in the
first half of the tournament standings
and we certainly can't because while
janna pomshi he's sprinting ahead of the
field in first place by point and a half
there's a trio and maybe you can even
call it quartet if we want to include
team over jabba they're fighting for
second place which may be very important
and as we caught up with dingley wren
yesterday dina valencia had a great
interview with him about his game with
five minute carwana and what should
happen in the event of a tie for second
place
ding three wins in a row how does it
feel
of course that is very lucky
i was in defensive
defense mode
entire game
but
in time trouble he
the position very badly so today is very
lucky
it all started with a very deep line
analyzed by computers apparently was
knight g7 uh in your preparation
uh yeah i briefly checked this line 97
you can fade knight h knight five look
yet it's equal but he played three so i
was more or less on my own
and after 96 here i have so many choice
here i believe my position won't be
worse but i don't know where i went
wrong the position seems very unpleasant
for me
[Music]
he played very well after 96 i think
yeah apparently there was this moment to
play b4 that fabian didn't use and then
uh
bishop g5 uh in the time travel that was
giving a
perpetual did you see that one
when i take on e8 bishop g5 sacrificed
the bishop and yes rookie one queen you
have fg5 queen seven king j8 queen g5
and he might
exchange the queens at some point on h3
yeah i was worried about bishop g5 since
i i didn't found a
clear win but also no clear draw for him
so he didn't go for this
sacrifice after
24 i think my positions
it should be windy yeah slowly
so was that moment when you sensed the
blood that the wind was coming to you oh
well i think the moment he missed queen
g3
he had to defend after that and also i
have much more time
also more present positions so at that
point
yeah i
smell the blood
you are now in a clear fight for the
second place uh maybe even for the first
who knows we were wondering uh in case
there are several players tied for
seconds
what do you think
would be the perfect tiebreaker
if more than one player then might be a
rapid
round-robin
tournament for
if three or four players
there's a lot to unpack from that
fantastic interview with dingley ren and
almira he says he was lucky yesterday
they often say better lucky than good i
say best lucky and good dingley ren knew
the preparation he got himself in a
little bit of pickle he worked his way
out of it and then as he said he smelled
blood
well talking about lucky you know his
girlfriend is certainly
very like a girl you know every time i
watch things interviews it makes my
heart melt
but
well his opening preparation is
certainly working now
uh what a comeback it was and as he said
you know he is smelling blood so he
wants more he certainly does and the
fight for second place is important and
dina touched upon that with dingley wren
magnus himself in madrid whether or not
he plays for the world championship that
remains to be determined but if he does
not then second place matters and
dingley wren gave his thoughts that
there should be a playoff if there is
indeed a tie for second yeah and we are
privileged to be watching the first
candidates in history in which second
place is as important as it is until the
world champion gives us further notice
he used to be winner go home
gold or bust but now there is a dogfight
going on for second place and someone
like fabiano caruana who has had a
disaster of the second half of the
tournament that doesn't mean that he's
out of contention dingley wren has only
a half point lead over the group of
wolves or to use magnus as where the
group of sharks or wannabe sharks were
tailing him so lots of intrigue
remaining and of course as i said at the
start of the broadcast jan he doesn't
yet have it in the bag he cannot take
his foot off the gas pedal it is winner
go home for several of these players
they're all going to go home at the end
of the term anyway some happier than
others but as we look at the first
pairing here donya richard report
against fabiana carwana a great lifetime
score for the american but both players
have been struggling in the second half
yeah it's been a tremendously
frustrating experience for both
especially for fabiano who called it a
two horse race after the first couple of
rounds he seemed to be in excellent form
and yesterday was just another
frustrating entry
in this line of incredibly maddening
games that he's played whether it's been
losses or draws and today he has to put
that behind him he has to play solid
chess and harness his opening
preparation richard reports preparation
it's been spotty with both colors
and fabby just has to play the position
richard usually gives you chances he
goes for a fight every game so i'm
expecting an interesting drawn-out
battle where fabiano caruana tries to
get out of this tailspin
in the last three games of the
tournament okay you heard it from don
here the fabian he's put those games in
the archive and probably lose them but
dingly wren he's on a three game winning
streak it seems like he's in the best
shape uh maybe his life of definitely in
this tournament and we haven't seen
three wins in a row since 2013. so amir
as he takes on timor java with the white
pieces what do you expect well first of
all to paraphrase danny it's about to
get extremely violent you know i think
that uh
dingle iran uh is coming to to this game
uh well prepared
and this is sort of a remake of their
world cup final where timur jabbar
deprived a ding of uh well probably a
well-deserved title at that time but
both players were fighting ferociously
and we all know how
ding needs to win this game so
like i'm i cannot wait
i think the fans are with you on that
one here they cannot wait either and i'm
going to stick with you two players and
their first candidates yanchistov duda
alireza farouja not the results they
were hoping for
but they play here alireza has a massive
score against junches of duda but duda
with the white pieces beat five on a
carwa a couple rounds ago what do you
think is going to happen when he gets
the white pieces today i wanted to ask
daniel well a young sister two day and
they raise the fears that they're
playing their first candidates turn up
so they're the one to be sharks yes yeah
that's the biggest makes it into the
category the baby sharks okay so i think
that uh it doesn't matter how your
tournament goes you always want to
finish it on a positive note we'll play
some creative chess and of let's not
forget to win some rating points it's
very important for the chess players
especially at the top level because it
can affect their standings and while
they were going to be remain in the top
10 or
going to exit the top 10 so it's very
important right because the rating
carries over with them unlike many other
sports so that's very true these players
remain hungry and yon napomshi the white
pieces against hikaru nakamura the
tournament leader the winner of the
previous candidates he takes on the
biggest chess content creator donya your
thoughts about that one well jan has
i wouldn't say dream pairings in the
last three rounds but dream colors he's
got two whites in a row and i think the
most important the most pertinent aspect
of this game is going to be the first
move we're expecting one e4 from jan but
will hikaru play his typical berlin and
if he does i fully expect yan to force
the queen e4 queen d4 drawn we certainly
would not be able to blame him for that
because the tournament situation uh
makes a drop more than sufficient for
yan if hikaru wants to guarantee a fight
we might see a karo khan or a sicilian
he's basically played everything
throughout his life but yet again we
shouldn't hold it against ikaro if he
goes for a berlin because beating yan in
his current form with the black pieces
that's an incredibly tall order but
we're going to keep a very close eye on
how that game begins and we see yon
napomshi at his chair and after that
eloquent breakdown by both elmira and
donya it's my turn to quickly vote make
my predictions for today's matches and
this is not going to be easy but as i go
through them i'm going to go with five
minute carwana i just think that he has
more at stake i know it hasn't been a
good stretch for him but with richard
reports shaky preparation and sometimes
feeling like he just wants to go home
i'm going with carwana in this one in
our next game between dingley wren and
team over java dingley wren seems
unstoppable he's won three games in a
row two of which were with the black
pieces and he just beat 500 karwana so
i'm going with ding with white
and actually a lot of people going with
ding oh oh my goodness we have yantra
stuffed dude against alaris i think well
the people who wanted for tim were there
were his parents
as well
one of these players unfortunately and
will you know keep on struggling and i
think it's going to be already with the
black pieces so i am going with the
polish number one yanchista duda to get
his second win in row with the white
pieces and last but certainly not least
we have janupomshi and akara nakamura
sorry buddy don't mean disappoint but
i'm going with a draw in that one i just
think that yon will kill the game very
quickly and i see you hikaro fans i see
you voting with his win with the black
pieces double the amount that
people predicting yawn to win but as we
have the players on screen in front of
us remind you you have until move 10 to
go to chess.com events and vote on each
and every game if you're the top guesser
you get 1 000
and even 10th place gets a diamond
membership well
look at yonder pomshy staring at the
board hikaru nakamura doing the same and
the big question as dania
posited
will hikara play e4 e5 will we get
something else and that is the biggest
question of all
yeah it's impossible asicaru inspects
the scoresheet there's nothing written
on it yet but will the first move be a
vowel move or a consonant move will it
be a c pawn will it be an e pun i think
that's the big choice facing hikaru
nakamura as he fights for second place
now hikaru is going to i believe have a
game against dingley run so
as almira pointed out before the
broadcast started ikara's approach might
be to allow a quick draw in this game
and then to take the big risks in his
only remaining white game and then his
gaming instinct will run or
he could try to make his entry into
chess history if he defeats yon
napomnishi that
completely opens up the tournament
especially if dingy lee ren can score
this much needed fourth win in a row
against umura java it's a big question
it is about to be answered in just over
one minute and we don't even have
rajabao in his chair just yet he'll
arrive shortly but dingley wren in his
much tinier chair than everybody else in
the field
he's been focused he's been really
excellent in the last bunch of rounds
and as we see alireza farrugia hoping to
bounce back after a tough defeat there
yanchez up duda he's had a much better
last couple rounds on mira
sorry it's like i was like i was so
comfortable you were mesmerized by the
chair i think i was as well i was uh
concentrated like on the opening theory
well first of all a young sister uh well
he i think that he won a very important
game against fabiana then well he drew
against taymor so i think he's eager to
play this game and he
i think he's a very interesting player
himself so
he
he wasn't able to show his true
potential in his tournament whoa
that is trolling that's a joke that's
got to be that is trolling on yonder
palm she's bored in the top right great
camera by our producers uh the move b3
was played
as the ceremonial first move so that is
amusing stuff hikaru that's his pet line
when he plays on all these chess.com
events that he wins and look at richard
report i know i'm not danny but i'm
going to act like him for a second look
at that jacket
it's that same jacket i think danny
wrench just uh it's about is about to
call in because he is obsessed veritably
obsessed with that red jacket
he is and i'm obsessed with this
four camera scene here where we get all
boars at once some players
blitzing through their opening choices
richard report once again
he delays his first move but you know do
you remember the opening that young
sister of duda played against richard
rapport and like he played the bishop
before in taimanov
that was the opening that richard played
against fabian i need to cut both of you
guys off we have a berlin in the nepo
nakamura game so let's keep a very
careful eye because janupamnishi he
carves move knight f6 is essentially a
veiled draw offer
yes because and we'll bring up this game
to analyze because
unfortunately it's possible the game
might not be going on for very long so
jan he takes his sip of tea here but we
will bring this up on screen for you to
show you that after e4 e5 answering
donya's question knight f3 knight c6
bishop b5 hikar could have played a6 the
open spanish as fabinho karwana did when
he had black against ikaru and knight f6
played so the reason why we're saying
this is a veiled draw offer is you
follow hikaru nakamura
online you would have seen him play
this opening many times and have quick
draws so
okay castles and that quick draw is in
the event of knight takes e4 which hikar
is likely going to do here
he doesn't look thrilled about it but it
was his choice on how to play the
opening we're gonna see it now there is
the move rookie one which is a move you
play if essentially you want to play for
two results but the game goes on rookie
one is a very very solid line that's
what people used to play when the draw
wasn't all that popular but if nepal
wants to make the draw we will see the
move d4 that is also the entry point
into the berlin end game so if nepo
plays d4 that doesn't necessarily mean
he will go for the draw but i'd give it
about a 90 chance that this game is
going to end
nepo taking a sip of his pure tea
but all that caffeine might be
unnecessary if nepa decides to end this
game and i'm just going to show that
this is the start of the berlin
variation vladimir krumnick he used it
to great effect against gary kasparov in
their world championship match the
queens are off black has the pair of
bishops but the compromise pawn
structure but why we think this might be
a draw is not this position this would
be a fight but instead if
after knight to d6 white takes on e5
sacrificing this bishop of e5 that's a
free piece white plays a4 and now this
knight is trapped so black brings the
knight into d4 white takes on d4 and
here after knight takes d4 queen takes
d4 d5
this is not illegal look chess.com lets
me do it e takes d6 even though the pawn
wasn't on the square you get this
position the queen takes queen e4 check
here the kings in check if the bishop on
c8 moves you lose b7 if you block with
the bishop on e7 white plays bishop f4
and knight c3 it develops very quickly
so the move is queen e6 queen d4 and
back and forth we go this might be
a very by the way very quickly nepal's
not actually thinking he knows what he's
going to do he's just sort of stealing
himself against what i think will be the
audience reaction if he goes for the
drop but i will say preliminarily we
cannot blame nepo for taking the draw
here if in fact he takes on e5 in this
position we can't blame him because
the first priority the only priority of
the players has to be to maximize their
chances to win the tournament and if
that means disappointing the fans and
making a quick draw then so be it he has
to operate within the confines the
tournament format and we can't expect
anything other than that but
feel free to disagree no amira for being
honest the
onus the burden is on hikaru nakamura
because as donya's saying jan is happy
to make draws and finish this tournament
because if he draws his final three
games it is quite likely that he will be
alone at the top of the leaderboard so
for hikaru nakamura you know if he was
trying to fight for a second and get a
victory or even come closer to first he
would have to play something different
and maybe risk more well i think that
hikaru
will explain wisely today because if he
would to take any risk then it should be
uh against dingleran in the last round
with black pieces
so like he's still having a game with
white pieces tomorrow and then he's
playing his direct you know concurrent
like adversary at the last round so i
think that's maybe from mathematical
point of view this decision is justified
for both players i completely concur
because for hikaru he knows how
important second place can be he still
plays dingley ren later in the event and
here's the big moment for yon the palm
the sheep because after knight d6 will
he go into the mainline berlin that
vladimir the former world champion used
a great effect i i know we all know that
he is just
pretending to think at this point
because if he plays d takes e5 we will
likely go down that variation but a big
question is is there anything that hikar
nakamura having played this position so
many times can he avoid a
force draw and as brewer's gambit asks
why would he car go for a draw well we
were just talking about that it's
because he wants to fight for second
place and with dingley wren still on his
docket of opponents he doesn't want to
you know throw away his chance in that
going to that last round so eight
we have d takes e5 the car with a little
rye smile there we have it he certainly
expected it
and why not and i would add that after
a4 there is an old-fashioned move d6 but
this move has fallen out of favor
because of e6 that forces black either
to take with the bishop making the king
vulnerable or to ruin the pawn structure
with f65 i won't delve into the details
because this will not happen they are
blitzing out these very very famous
moves these moves have been made even
more famous by all of the times that
hikaru and magnus have made the draw
that wesley and magnus and wesley and
hikaru have made this drawing fabiano
the grand masters and i've made this
draw a couple of times i've made this
draw against wesley in the last round of
the u.s championship a couple of years
ago
and yan and hikaru they're looking at
each other he's sipping his seat but
this game is over and the yondu palmishi
will move to eight and a half
out of 12. i think it's important not to
burn all the bridges now
for hikaru
yes that's the great way to sum it up
that you just don't want to throw
your all your chances away because you
play with the black pieces and hikara
said this any everyone the tournament
who's tried too hard with black has lost
the game so we see e take d6 amp queen
takes d6 and
you're trying to at least wait for the
photographers to leave before the game
ends i don't think it's happening we're
about to see a draw with the queens
going back and forth as we have been
highlighting the white queen goes here
and the reason why this game is a draw
is that black's best bet is to follow
the white queen
and wow i mean this is just
there's the result both players i guess
one john might repeat this tomorrow i
mean he's got a second white and i think
that ikaru
he's probably going to get the brunt of
the negative fan reactions because
people are going to be asking you knew
that this would happen why didn't you
play a cairo con why didn't you play a
sicilian i want to make one thing very
clear apart from the fact that the
berlin is the car was main opening the
last couple of years so it's not that
easy just to pull something you know
pull some trick out of a sleeve it
doesn't work like that but it's at the
top level
the other thing i want to point out is
that if a 2760 wants to make a draw
against you with the white pieces
they're usually going to succeed there
is no opening that does not permit any
solid lines against the karo khan you
can take on d5 and play a line that jan
is not going to lose in a million years
in the kind of form that he's in against
the sicilian there's drawing lines in
virtually every variation of the open
sicilian we have our handshake there
there is no opening
save something incredibly dubious that
would allow hikaru to guarantee the
ability to play for a win and what i
would say is it's not hikara's fault
that richard report and alireza frugia
went all in against yonda palmashi first
report didn't take a draw when he could
have then alareza frugia just threw his
kingside pawns forward and found his
king in danger so it's not hikaru's
fault that jan is so far ahead of the
field and for kara he needs to do what's
best for himself and what's best for
karu is making this draw getting the
white pieces in one of the next games
and then if he's behind dingley run in
the standings he's not going to make a
quick draw against dingley wren he is
going to go all out and that's where
we'll see him use all his energy so for
karu this is a very very good decision
for yon obviously he's thrilled because
he made a draw all the pressure now is
on dingley ren and with a currently a
two-point lead over ding that if dingley
ring can win his game
now all of a sudden he's really getting
close to yon napomnishi so three games
remain even though the leader has his
game done with it doesn't mean we won't
have excitement in fact dingley wren's
position in the upper right and think
playing quickly uh that knight on a6
rajaba throughout this tournament has
done some obscure things some avoiding
mainline theory but playing
energetically and i'm not sure that's
always the recipe for success against
someone like dingley red well it's
interesting uh well to notice that
dink's uh opening choice was to play d4
in the first move because during their
match in the world cup that was a very
intense theoretical battle in the
english opening and i think one an
incredible game uh when he sacrificed
upon like i can show it uh a little bit
later when we have the analysis position
on the board so
uh here we can see uh the classical
nymph service with this e3
which has the reputation of being a very
solid opening
okay
that is also very exciting right back to
the more solid opening here we go yes i
wanted to show you just at the very
beginning when uh one game when he
started with c4 the norfolk oh yes with
an elizabeth
so c4
c5 knight c3 knight f6
e4 e6
e5 knight g8 that was the line played by
a ding well rajab of jinx of knight f3
knight c6
d4 here takes knight d4 and jinx
sacrificed to pound here played on a
sword job of played knight e5
knight b5
and he won like a very nice game after
h6 and knight d6 and
it was rashodeva
mhm but here the flavor of the game is
quite a bit different yeah so nimzo
indian from timur and i think the move
that might raise eyebrows
from fans who are
uh not as used to the nimzo indian and
it raises my pros for me is knight a6 so
this is the rubenstein variation as
lemire pointed out incredibly solid this
is all pretty normal stuff it almost
looks like a carlsbad structure but this
move knight a6 not only does it allow
white to take that knight on ruin
black's pawn structure but that knight
seems to have absolutely no prospects
and i think it's important to understand
two things one the light squared bishop
is white's most important piece if you
give it away you weaken all of the light
squares in the center black can get his
bishop to f5 and the dark squared bishop
for white is the inferior of the two
brothers second thing is that the knight
on a6 isn't actually trying to go to b4
what it's trying to do is support the c7
c5 pawn break and if you were to try to
do the same thing from d7 if instead of
knight a6 timur had played knight bd7 he
would have allowed the very nasty knight
b5 as it stands the knight from a6
protects the c7 pawn and knight b5 would
be harmless owing to bishop e7 so i
think this move makes a lot of logical
sense and to more followed up with even
more logical c5
agreed i mean it's still very strange to
see the 996 and it's predictable what
happened c5
take on a6 because if you don't take on
a6 black sometimes plays his move c4
expands on the queen side and if you
take on c5 thinking that you gave your
opponent an isolated pawn this knight
very happily takes on c5 puts pressure
on the bishop and also these this
file can be a problem the c file the b3
square can be a bit vulnerable so that's
why dingley wren takes an a6 first and
as we get to the live position and
dingley ren takes a think almirah as you
look at this opening black with the
double isolated a pawns the isolated
d-pawn
who would you say uh should be happier
about how the opening is gone maybe both
of them are very happy i think that the
pair of bishops guarantees here
was sufficient compensation uh for black
because well
their pawn structure is certainly um
somewhat weak but um
on the other hand there are a lot of
attack perspectives in this position for
black because as you can see uh you if
you castle then i can always play knight
g4 queen h4
bishop g6 yes and also even try to bring
my rook to play rook v8 that's actually
one of the most important moments
okay you have these double bonds but you
can play rook b8 rock b6 and transfer
the rook or oh to the six wow
which is one of the ideas of this
opening we saw hikar nakamura do
something like that against ali as a
ferugia when he brought his rook all the
way from the queen side over to the king
side so the open b file anytime you have
double pawns you gain an open file for
your rook that is good news for black
and this bishop looks worse than the
counterpart and if you try to play b4 to
fianchetto you eventually allow this
pawn to come up to a5 so just to show
what that looks like this bishop can
come here and let's say i play bishop to
b2 to try to develop black can always
try to get at this pawn oop i dropped
the bishop back on c1 but yeah you can
try to get at this pawn directly so the
double pawns will be double no more as
you trade them off and if you play b5
then the other double pawn can advance
to a6 and continue harassing like b-pawn
and uh try to get that light-squared
bishop an excellent post on a6 but
from my perspective white has made a
very serious positional concession and
giving up the light spirit bishop like
the light squares are now going to
plague white for the rest of the game as
long as black's light squirt bishop is
alive so you might ask well what does
ding get and return from that almira
pointed out the damaged pawn structure i
would also point out the d4 square which
is a very traditional parking space for
white's knight you don't want to go
there immediately because the trade is
not necessarily favorable if a pawn has
to move to that position but dangly ran
expanding on the queen side despite the
possibility of a fav robert you look
like that surprises you it certainly did
and dingley wren has been taking a bit
of a think in this game so he's down 10
minutes but i've learned not to read too
much into dingleran's time usage because
there are games when he's down an hour
against ikaro nakamura plays perfectly
even though he wasn't familiar with the
theory he understood the fundamentals of
the position but this b4 move it just
feels like it will allow black to play
a5 but maybe he felt it was better to at
least expand first because black could
play a5 anyway and if white had castled
instead of playing b4 then maybe now or
in the near future black plays a5 to
take away this possibility well i think
that after
before uh well black first of all has
two moves maybe bishop d6 is more
flexible but ding's idea uh
is probably to deprive
black of this typical breakthrough in
the center and to exchange the bounce to
play d4 at some point
so
if he castles but now the problem is
that if i play bishop d6 are you forced
to play h3 is bishop h2 is the threat
already for example if you castle yeah
these are always
risky decisions because the king is open
and if you're kg1 this is how you lose
games everybody queen h4 comes in your
rook has to move because queen h2 is
checkmate and once the rook moves away
f2 falls and then the king is still
being hunted so you really don't have uh
that option to castle because of this
check your king would have to go up to
g3 and while in this position it looks
like it pans out for white it's very
very dangerous with the king out in the
open so as we look at the live position
we are joined here by hikaru nakamura
the most popular chess streamer the
biggest content creator on twitch for
chess hikaru not a very long day today
yeah i mean there were a couple things
obviously first of all yan's very
fortunate because he's in the situation
where he seems to be playing for draws
and then winning with black like he's
like being solid with black and then
winning with black so
i mean if you're gonna win every game
with black uh and you know the white
piece is like i mean what what can i
really do i i thought about um
changing it up but when i played uh i
played the rcc right before i i left the
states i played against fedor save
actually and i played a sicilian and he
just like killed me i just got
absolutely destroyed in that game so
i didn't think the risk reward was there
really how much does that weigh on you a
recent game as you're saying it's fedo
save if that game hadn't happened do you
think you would be more likely to play
sicilian um maybe but also there's a
problem that i played richard yesterday
and i was looking at a lot of sicilians
before the game um from the white side
and so
even even when i look at it from from
the white side the problem is i think a
lot of people forget that jan he i mean
he only to face e5 in the match against
magnus but he obviously did a lot of
preparation across the board and
it just it didn't seem practical i mean
if if i think about the risk reward even
if i were to win the game i don't think
the chance of me catching on were very
good uh since i have blackens ding in
the last round so i didn't think that
makes sense and then if i lose the game
of course there's no shot at second
place either so it just it didn't didn't
really make sense and i had a feeling
yawn would do this because i mean let's
let's be honest ding is not going to win
the last three games i don't think so
it's just uh yeah that's what it is
yakara i know you're focused on your own
tournament but a quick question about
alireza
uh what do you think might be behind his
overall lacking performance and how
disappointed were you
in the fact that he lost a pretty
one-sided game yesterday oh i thought
you were about to say
how disappointed was that he lost here
and how does someone really couldn't
even beat a commentator in a hyper
bullet um
yeah i mean i thought what he did was
fine if the intention was to make a draw
if the intention is to just make the
quick draw with the white pieces then i
think it's completely reasonable but as
soon as he won c4 um
i had a feeling that it was going to go
downhill and i mean he was fine he was
fine out of the opening but it just
you can't you can't play till 6am and
then play a game of classical chess and
actually that was kind of the thing is
when i think about um when i was in
berlin i think that i was playing
something after the first game against
wesley um but i i think i knew quite
well that i was going to be solid and
try to draw the second game so like i
already have that in mind but if you're
going to play a lot of blitz or bullet
and then play a classical game against
the top player i i just it's ill-advised
um and i understand he was trying to let
off some steam but at the at the end of
the day it's just it's it's too much
it's just too much so
yeah that's that's my that's my general
take on it but you know i think a lot of
people have been critical of yon they
feel like he's gotten a lot of gifts
he's been lucky um but you know when you
play well throughout the way he has uh i
mean you make your own luck and so i
think it's very deserved in terms of how
how young it's uh performed and
something you mentioned here is you know
you're still in the fight for second
place so you played ding lyran in the
last round so if you are within distance
of him or you know
i think what you're maybe implying is
that you're willing to take a risk in
round 14 but not this early yeah i mean
i think the the big difference when you
look at it overall is um well i guess
first let's let's back up first things
first is that if you look at the way i'm
going to use fabiano's examples he's the
best example fabiano has been playing
every game taking huge risks so it's
very clear that fabiano does not believe
for a second that second place is in
play it's very clearly thinks magnus is
full of bologna
let's put it that way
um and i generally have the same
attitude as well but
it's i still want to have a chance where
maybe there's that backdoor option where
i can get to second place so yeah i mean
if i'm if i have a chance we'll we'll
see what happens um you know the
situation obviously determines a lot but
realistically i don't think it's there
but it's still something where if
there's a chance you want to have that
that possibility and what would you
think about that like you want that
possibility but a world championship
match not featuring magnus carlson is
that at all odd to you um
yeah i mean it's very weird that the
best player in the world suddenly
doesn't doesn't play um especially when
he's very clearly the best like if you
go back in time i'll look at fisher i
assume fisher probably would have would
have beaten karpov but it's kind of
close already um after 72 if they're
playing like 74 75 um whereas magnus i
don't think you can look at it and say
someone else on paper is going to beat
him it just doesn't look realistic right
now so it's kind of strange um
to hear that but i mean maybe magnus is
just he's tired and wants to do other
things so
he wouldn't be the only one i mean i've
certainly transferred a little bit too
but
yeah but i mean poker is one of those
things where it's it's fun when you have
a deep run in a tournament um like you
did in the the
whatever it was in oslo but i mean if
you go into like the main event in the
world series and you bust on day one or
day two it's not really very exciting so
um and that is gonna happen if you play
tournament poker so
yeah i mean maybe maybe he'll find other
things but at the end of the day i think
he said in the heat of the moment i
think he's done a little bit of trolling
as well but
i i mean if he doesn't play i i would
just i'd be shocked just don't buy it i
mean we asked john this yesterday and we
were you know wondering the players like
what kind of input would you give about
a world championship match because it
seems like for magnus that's a big part
of it i'm sure the lack of prize fun
relative to how chess is growing is you
know also an issue but what would be
your
preferred format for a world
championship you know i think the thing
is when you look at the candidates on
the world championship they're very
different than other tournaments so for
example i'll just use the grand prix or
the grand swiss i i spent a couple of
weeks preparing for the grand prix in
berlin just a couple of weeks that's it
nothing special i think everyone else
did the same so you kind of go in
um sort of you're you're sort of
free-willing you're i'm not free-willing
what's the word you're sort of um
you're sort of just going in and you
come with ideas on the fly everything is
on the fly nothing is really set and
when you plan the canada's turn where
players are like six months or more to
prepare everyone's repertoire is very
very solid and they have a lot of really
really good ideas so it's very different
it's just like you know if i go play the
us championship people will prepare for
maybe a month before the event if that
and you go play so everyone's coming up
with things on the flywheels in the
candidates and the world championship
you have months and months to prepare so
because of that uh there's far less room
i think to kind of be creative and take
chances and i think for magnus that's
probably why
he's so frustrated because it's not fun
having to prepare for the uh petrov for
months
he had to deal with it with fabiano and
and obviously yon as well so um i think
that's maybe the thing is perhaps if
they had it um where it wasn't such a
long break where let's just say this
tournament ends today and you go play
the match in um in let's say september
for example i think i think that's
probably the the biggest thing that
could be could be done right off um to
also make it more exciting cause if
players have six months to prepare
you're not going to have many decisive
games no matter what because people just
that's the nature of chess if you're
well prepared you play a good game um
it's going to be a draw so i think
that's that's probably the biggest thing
that i would suggest changing which
doesn't require like adding rapid or
blitz or other things into the mix
one more question for me on a slightly
different topic this is a 14 round event
super grueling you're no stranger to 14
hour streams
and incredibly ruling online events do
you feel like all of the focus that is
required to conduct a long stream and
keep up a high level of chess online
helps you keep your level of play sharp
as this tournament nears its conclusion
yeah i mean i actually thought in the
grand prix as well it was definitely the
case i think i alluded to this but when
i was playing at some of the younger
players i think yasupenko in particular
from from russia it seemed like he was
getting tired before i was getting tired
i was kind of confused because he's half
my age um but yeah i mean it's a little
bit of a different skill set but just
being sharp for so many hours on end i
think i think it does help and and also
when i play against really strong
players online non-stop that that
definitely um is it makes it makes a
difference so i think for sure it's
helped me but i think probably the
biggest thing um that helped me that's
helped me with this tournament
specifically is that i had the
experience in 2016 playing the
candidates where things really didn't go
my way at the start i was able to kind
of win a couple games in the middle had
a decent result and um like to use an
example i think like for ali reza if he
had the right people around him who were
sort of like keeping him calm telling
him that you know you'll get your
chances later in the event
i think it could have been very
different
yeah no but i mean i think it could have
been very different but i think the
problem is he doesn't have that
experience he doesn't have people around
him telling him to just like you know
you just stay solid they're going to be
opportunities and like even even if i
look at my games i didn't win yesterday
but i got this opportunity out of
nowhere against richard um and there's
those opportunities you're going to get
them in a really long tournament and and
so i think that actually is the biggest
thing is the fact that i had that
experience in 2016. it's really helped
me just sort of focus on one one game at
a time and not really think about the
the bigger picture and what how much
classical chess can we expect to see you
in and has the candidates you know
inspire you to play more
um
i mean we'll we'll see i don't have any
classical tournaments planned um
in the next six months at least so i i
don't i don't really know i'll probably
play uh the rapid and blitz in st louis
at the end of august i think there's
like 960 there too um maybe i'll play
something in india close to the end of
the year on the world rapid and blitz
but but not the olympiad
not no but the olympiad i mean there are
a couple things first of all it's right
after this tournament normally the
olympiad's in september or october it's
in the fall as opposed to suddenly being
in the summer uh it's very far to travel
the event certainly it's gonna be a
little bit weaker than usual as well
without um without i think china or
russia france also doesn't have their
top players so i think it's just a
situation where you pick and choose i
think one of the things with all the
tournaments online and over the board
now is there so many events that people
are not going to be able to play
everything they're going they're clashes
no matter what and because of that you
just have to pick and choose you see
maxime ali reza skipping they're playing
i think the grand chester event instead
if i'm not mistaken so we're in a world
where there are just going to be more
tournaments and you're not going to see
all the top players playing in every
single event because it's just the
nature of what happened with the boom so
um yeah and then just as far as
classical i mean maybe of a tournament
like gibraltar returns in 2023 i might
want to play there i've always
had great memories there i think i've
won that turn like four or five times
and it's just been it's one of my
favorite opens and i've always enjoyed
enjoyed that so maybe an event like that
maybe taught us still um but it remains
to be seen of course well of course
we'll see you online a ton but before we
let you go any parting thoughts about
the games here and dingley wren he wants
to continue his winning streak he's got
the white pieces in the upper right side
here against uh team over java do you
like the opening that he's gotten or are
you thinking the teamwork's gonna go i
mean i actually hate the openings it
looks it looks like something where if
they're if they have 30 minutes and
they're nearing control maybe it's
something where you can get play but
with with team revving hour 50 on the
clock i mean i have a feeling this one's
going to fizzle pretty fast that's just
my guess um
like yeah i mean this this it just looks
i don't know i just i have a feeling
that if the players had less time this
could be dynamic but i'm guessing timor
is going to find a way to um simplify
this pretty soon although apparently
computer likes black here which i guess
makes makes some sense perhaps with the
uh with the pawn on b5 maybe black is e4
c c file i mean
i i actually the more i looked
especially the more i think i'd rat i'd
rather be black than white here because
bishop bishop
maybe bishop b7 or c8 and rookie 8 and i
mean black has very obvious ideas and
white i mean for white you need like so
many moves like after bishop b7 let's
say you play knight d4
just i mean
but after rook c8
it's like you need so many moves you
need like you need like queen d2 rook c1
castle's worth d1 and then knight e2
just i think to possibly claim anything
and i think that's
that feels like way too much to expect
here
and at some point black might even just
have a6 somewhere to just simplify
everything on the b file yeah i don't
like this at all i kind of wonder if um
kind of wonder if ding's going to get
into some trouble in this this game
actually because it looks
yeah this is not what you this is not
what you what what you want that's
definitely not what you want so not that
surprising um
but also that's why it's good to be the
leader because when everyone has to
chase leader down you're seeing people
take risks you have to take risks to try
and catch a leader and i mean it seems
like in this tournament whenever people
have been creative whether it's against
yon or whether it's in in other games uh
everyone's gotten punished i got
punished against teamwork fabiano's
gotten punished a few times um everyone
who tried against janna obviously so it
seems like the moral of the story is
when you try really hard just it's not
working and ali russell also had that
happen too fair enough and actually
really last question i promised you
dangling right we had him for an
interview and he said
in response to what do you think should
happen if there's a tie for second place
he said it should be played out over the
board
yeah i mean if if it matters of course
like like i said if it matters then yes
i think there should always be a tie
breaker actually fide changed the rules
i think uh for this candidate's turn or
if there was a tie for first place
unlike in the past past editions there
would be a tiebreaker so yeah if it
matters there should be a tiebreaker um
but i again it's one of those things
where i'll believe i'll believe it when
i see it but basically if this
tournament ends the tie for second do
you think the players should say we
should play it just in case yeah
actually that's uh interesting um
probably probably that is one way to to
do it um
i i mean whether fiji goes along with
that i mean who knows but yeah i think
the players got together and said let's
just play let's just play some kind of
tie breaker um
i think that that would be a reasonable
way to resolve it uh and yeah see what
happens okay the only thing we have to
resolve is are you wearing pineapple
socks yes i am yeah
i wore them in uh in in berlin as well
my mods gave them to me so um yeah i
figured i would do that well props to
the mods thank you so much shakar for
joining us for sharing your thoughts and
the game wasn't long today so enjoy your
double rest day thank you
thank you
you heard from hikaru nakamura
super grand master having a good result
here in madrid
as he said he didn't want to burn his
bridges he will leave his chances open
because dingley rent the player on
screen is the man he faces in the 14th
and final round at the palacio de
santonia so no need to go all in against
jan that's how you get in trouble and he
gets white against yanchez of duda after
the rest day elmira and it's always good
to hear hikaru's thoughts but he does
certainly have chances to catch up to
dingley wren because he plays in the
final round and the white pieces against
judah that's a pretty good pairing all
things considered
well that's exactly what i thought i
think at the beginning
[Music]
of the round and
i actually love how rational hikari is
you know so he
he's very calm and he explains his point
of view
like point by point so um i think that
those two rounds are going to be
very interesting
from and we will see
and now i'm very curious if the players
will
group together to ask fide for a playoff
because
we know that in the regulations for
first place tie
you'd have to play it out but
nobody expects second place to be
involved with the world chess
championship and i don't know if i just
gave icar the idea but he seemed to be
receptive to it that if the players say
you know we don't believe in this you
know these tie breaks it feels like
that's not how you should ever settle a
chess event and dingley ren you know if
those two are the people who are tied
and dingley run himself said we should
play maybe those two can agree to play
there's a lot of stake there and the
person who ultimately finish in second
may change their mind like no no it's
good this way no no match sheet you know
for
the tie here let's just go with it but i
think the players always want to settle
out on the board i think the fact that
there even is an active discussion is a
great thing because when you have an
unprecedented situation you need the
input of everyone involved you don't
just want some higher up making a
pronouncement you know this is how we're
going to do it you want a rational open
discussion where the facts are laid out
and i completely agree with you i think
it's only fair that in a situation like
this you decide who qualifies over the
chessboard everything in chess should be
decided the maximum number of things
should be decided over the chessboard
rather than on a piece of paper and with
a calculator so it's great that we're
discussing this i know magnus is in
madrid so i'm also hoping for a
pronouncement from the world champion
himself before the end of this
tournament maybe the day after this
tournament concludes for us to be able
to figure out whether a tiebreak would
actually be a relevant thing to conduct
i hope that magnus
saves these players from playing a bunch
of useless tiebreak games if in fact he
wants to play everyone wants to see them
play rapid time that's true
there's nothing rapid chess between
these players two thumbs up that's true
it's a net positive and i was thinking
that like with the like so many people
behind zing and the
huge community behind hikaru there might
be like very important leverage finally
you know on the side of the players so
they can negotiate against finland
absolutely and
the players are saying they want it and
also changes the dynamic of that last
round we know in the 2016 candidates
tournament fabiano caruana sorry
kayaking were tied for first place
fobbing on the black pieces but because
there was no tie break match five and
had to play for a win from move one
which is really uncomfortable and if
hikaru nakamura wins round 13 and
dingler draws the next two games and
somehow ding has better tie breaks we
might be in that same exact situation
where instead of a draw being okay they
you know tie for second they play a
match that now hikar from move one has
to play for when if in fact they are
tied heading into the round so we'll see
what happens with respect to that i mean
we see five out of card on on screen we
heard hikaru's thoughts on the dingley
ren's game so why don't we go to
fabiano's game against richard report
there are already 12 moves in so if you
haven't voted well you missed your
chance because it's only up to move 10
but here we see a pawn structure where
both sides have double pawns
yeah
isn't it like with the same variation
that fabiano played with white you know
how important this like to study uh well
the opening theory for both colors but i
think that fabiano went for
uh bishop b6 they're not bishop d6 okay
we'll bring up the analysis board and
show that moment for you all
okay just to go through the opening what
a surprise
anti-berlin
and amir mentioned the move bishop to b6
here instead of bishop to d6
i don't remember which move is more
common to be honest
i think that was like
already this line was sort of considered
to be very rare because fabian used it
against hikaru
like knight
d2 and knight b3 then so
what is more flexible well bishop e7 i
know is also a possibility here that
prevents knight g5 bishop b6 i think
might be more natural from the
perspective of controlling the maximum
number of squares putting pressure on f2
i mean you're not exactly going to
develop a mating attack in the next like
four or five moves but that bishop looks
pretty safe and sound
but richard did try to exploit the fact
that knight 25 is possible and he played
it straight away essentially inducing
forcing black to give away the light
squid bishop i don't know what to make
of that though who does that favor it's
hard to say can we talk about how many
night moves have been made like okay
knight f3 that's one night move knight
bd2 that's the second
knight b3 third knight g5 fourth this is
captured
fifth move oh my god
seventh night move of the game and we're
only 13 moves in black should play
knight d4 just for the heck of it even
though that's a bad move yeah i mean
it's clear what richard is doing and
amir i have to ask you stylistically
um it looks like richard's trying to
avoid anything that could get him in
trouble like he's playing the most solid
position that you could ask for in a
chess game well
that's actually for me is a very strange
opening choice because that's what the
story that i was telling right
at the beginning of the round that uh
richard himself played against fabiano
caruana this the man of sicilian was
bishop before this crazy line but
fabiano
went for a solid opening himself here so
he doesn't want to take any risks and
he's been struggling in the second half
of the tournament
i wanted to show you that we might get
this uh
very strange looking uh pawn structure
if uh white takes on b6 so it's very
compact
oh it's not i mean you made the worst
possible you cannot
let's say let's say you castle and if
knight b6 you have this it's not very
often that you get this type of
structure
in the game i like it on cube people on
twitch love that i know chad is probably
going crazy right now well you know we
don't typically love double pawns but
they occupy so many squares i mean look
at this they can go up and the second
one can join the party then you can keep
going over here so you it's like a
convoy you know you keep moving it
forward and they have your back so
queen d7 is played by
fabiano and that means after knight
takes b6 no longer can you take with the
a pawn your rook is loose on eight
that's why you need the queen over here
so he's willing to take away from the
center with c takes b6 and in the event
this happens look at this little like
what is this like a i don't even know
what this is like a lightning bolt or
something
yeah it's some sort of parallelogram
shaped pawn structure also not something
you see every day
i guess there's only one
set of double pawns here even though it
looks like there's more
there's only the b-bonds are doubled i
feel like i'm playing blocus or tetris
or something right exactly with this
kind of piece so uh what do you make of
this elmira that the fact that fabiano
is willing to capture away from the
center we typically don't advise that if
we don't have to but what do you think
his ultimate goal in this position is
well actually it's even more complex
than that i was thinking about so
positionally
which piece is better the bishop on c1
on this knight on c6 i think that
fabiano wants to play c5
here and to
to establish a very uh well emerity
blind with black pieces uh richard will
most certainly play
for a four here he will castle and play
f4 maybe on the next move or
but then
if i i'll take bishop before i will
always have this queen g4 and uh queen
b2 that's why i think fabiano wanted to
keep his queen on on the g file i'll
just show that amiros points f4 would be
a nice useful move to get the bishop
open but there's a tactical flaw that
after bishop takes f4 this knight
captures this rook captures and after
queen d4 check you may just be dropping
a pawn over here on b2 it's not the end
of the story because black's king is in
the center and things of that nature but
you don't want to just drop a pawn like
this
yeah and i would also make one more
point which is that if you give up the
night
it's like that feeling of not having the
right screwdriver
uh i don't really experience that
feeling because i don't really use a
screwdriver i don't do any repairs
myself
but after something like bishop e3 c5
if only you had a knight on c3 that
knight would have a mouth-watering
square on d5 so that's the problem oh or
a light squared bishop on c4 so you have
the worst possible minor piece now the
bishop on e3 isn't terrible because as
elmira pointed out it it can potentially
support f2l4 but black has this
incredible bind on the d4 square with no
downside because white doesn't have the
machinery to exploit the drawback
of black's pawn structure so yeah the
fact that black is to take away from the
center is
a little bit unpleasant but it's really
not a big deal and
i think that richard is going to keep
his knight on c4 at least for the time
being yeah there's no reason to capture
right away and report he doesn't look
thrilled right now he's kind of slouched
in his chair and
dina bellancaya caught up with richard
and he gave us insights into what's
going on in his head
but joining how satisfying is your game
today
i don't know
i really
don't really care at this point so
i again
got totally normal position then
i decided to lose and then after making
the decision that i will lose again
today i
changed my mind and i drew it here so
yeah very strange game i mean i guess
there was many people who would have bet
that after i don't know
it takes p3 bishop takes b3 the game
will finish within five minutes but
not for me not in this tournament
apparently so it's okay
according to the computer it was a
relatively clean game in fact uh hikar
was the one let's say who didn't use the
white collar you were playing really
solid yeah i mean this opening is
generally very solid even for islamic g3
which i think is not um
the most ambitious one and after that
okay there was some minor complications
but with bishop perry should always be
fine and of course his final position
which he played forever
is totally drawn i mean uh to be really
okay if my pawn was on g5 let's say
probably it's lost or possibly it's lost
but
right what we got uh
all he could do is just you know hope
that i will blunder something in one or
two moves which i
haven't done
fortunately this time yeah
what do you think about this tournament
situation when jana is the clear leader
do you think he already guaranteed
himself a first place or he still needs
to be really careful pretty much
especially because he's still playing
with me so
i think he's
he's kind of
guaranteed
to win this angry so why are you saying
that you still have some motivation
regardless of what you have said before
we will see
i don't want to reveal some secrets
okay
right thanks a lot richard
you know richard report has a great
sense of humor very self-deprecating
hard to tell when he's being serious or
when he's just
joshing around but he is a fantastic
player he should be invited i've said
this earlier in the event to every
single chess tournament because of his
creativity and his exciting play we know
that the result didn't go his way
against janna palm she earlier in the
event but he declined to draw he called
himself stupid and he said he should
throw his laptop out the window but it's
just great to see a player you didn't do
that yeah no no no that would not be
good you need to look down and make sure
nobody's there before you toss anything
out your window which you shouldn't do
in the first place but amira i mean we
just heard his interview and he's ready
to go home
well it's
quite surprising for me because uh
richard is such a fighter but he
certainly had high expectations for this
tournament and he looks so disappointed
he's like i wanted to make a joke he
looks like a suicidal fish
but
well he keeps
joking about it as you said so we can
call this interview unraveling
the mysteries of richard's report
and uh well
there are three and three games ahead of
him and donna he said that yon napomshi
you know he has this win in the back he
still plays me but we know that when
richard takes him on he is not going to
play lightly he's going to take that
game very seriously and i'd say two
things i think
you know chess fans
need to be very discerning
of you know the way in which richard
said uh self-deprecatingly that jan is
still playing him and he said at one
point i don't care
i think none of us can actually accuse
him of not caring he's putting in his
best every game somebody like richard
report
it's not that he consciously puts in
effort every game he can't help it he
lives and breathes chests the guy gives
all of his energy every single game and
you can sense the disappointment even at
very minor inaccuracies because that was
all he committed yesterday and the
second thing i'd say
i think some people might look at this
interview and say well you know i
consensus disappoint but did richard
really think that he had serious chances
to win the candidates yes that's why we
want to invite him to every tournament
we don't want to invite someone who's
just there to fill up the tournament
standings we want to see players who
believe themselves
and who obviously have the results to
back that up richard does have the
results to back that up he has the
rating to back it up and i love seeing a
fighter and even a disappointed fighter
is better than a
happy
non-fighter that doesn't really roll off
the tongue you know what i'm saying well
he has been fighting we see a win
against yanchez of duda in round eight
followed by two consecutive losses
against alvarez afruja and dingley ran
some disappointing results there he drew
hikaru nakamura but that wasn't for a
lack of trying from hikara's point of
view and for richard he defended for
over 90 moves so now he gets the white
pieces against fabinho karwana they are
actually very good friends and
from report he hasn't played that much
overall but in the last year it seems
like he's playing everywhere right he
actually was also going to play in the
norway chess event but he dropped out of
that because it ended a few days before
the tournament team over java did take
part in that one
so for a report we are getting to see
him much more over the board we know
that there's this whole thing when he
with him transferring from his native
hungary to romania he has some
sponsorship he has previously spoken
about the lack of sponsorship in chess
and how he feels like he doesn't have
support so uh it seems like you know
he's doing well in his wardrobe
of course it is only natural that he's
attracting sponsors with that
absolutely and uh he's so fun to watch
in every way imaginable from his
wardrobe to the moves that appear
on the board and i remember richard has
been 2700 for
six or seven years now and there was a
point at which he dropped below 2700 let
me tell you playing richard report when
he was like 26 70
was the most nightmare pairing
imaginable so now he is back to his
rightful place over 2760
and he's taking his time in this
position deciding whether to take on v6
whether to cast a queen sight to a
castling to throw in a check on h5
it's symmetrical from the point of view
of material but very positionally
complex given the pawn structure and
given all of the options available for
both sides
i also wanted to to say that given his
psychological state it was very
important to
stop the bleeding yesterday so he made
the draw against hikarus and well he
still has two games with white
and uh well maybe a more difficult game
with black
it remains to be seen what he's capable
of but we haven't touched upon this one
final game in the bottom left between
yanchez of duda and ali raza faruja so
let's bring that one up let's give the
youngsters the two youngest players in
the candidates they're due it's their
first candidates tournament and before
the game i had to make a prediction and
i said that yanchez after it was going
to win
i have to pick somebody but if we look
at the live board here and we look at
yon schistup duda his position at least
the outline of it looks really nice for
white
well do you remember danny if
you played the miranda before
i don't even really know what he plays
against d4 the funny thing is this
started as a nimzo indian
and then alireza transposed into a semi
slob and played the [ __ ] so
to answer your question i don't remember
ali reza in these positions
well actually what i wanted to say uh
it's true for timura jabba and for ali
reza firuja that both of them uh play
the kings indian you know as kids
they're
that that was their first love the
opening they loved so much so how do you
come from the king's indian and then you
play the queen's
queen's gambit and there are more solid
openings
yeah i mean one of my criticisms of ali
reza
this tournament i think hikaru paycode
that was his opening choice i mean he
hadn't played for many months we were
expecting you know opening wizardry
and at times his choices and his play
overall
hasn't been totally aligned to what we
think his stylistic preferences are and
yesterday he definitely overrelied
on the uh engine assessment by his own
admission so we're keeping a close eye
on ali reza's opening choices in the
last three games the [ __ ] has the
upside of being a very tactical weapon
it's existed for decades it's very
reputable it's incredibly well studied
this move b7 b5 is what really defines
the [ __ ] it's named after a city in i
don't know which european country where
this was
first played so black expands very
quickly on the queen side fiancatos the
bishop on b7 and in the baron black has
a lot of possible pawn breaks that
b-pawn it can move forward to b4 the
c-pawn can move to c5 and open up the
light square bishop and finally you
often see black playing the third pawn
break which also featured in this game
and that is e6 e5 which is often played
in response to white pushing the pawn up
to e4 robert the position is complex
tactically structurally positionally
this is one of the most well-studied and
yet one of the most
open-ended
uh openings in existence yes and you
mentioned the b-pawn push first and
that's why yan chisholm plays a3 if you
play c5 you're going to drop this pawn
on b5 and there are times where you can
do this because this bishop slices
across the board to take this knight and
this bishop is aiming towards h2 but not
in this position c5 would be a mistake
too soon because this pawn on b5 can be
captured and it doesn't end here right
we've seen games like bishop b and
fischernathan anand the five-time former
world champion he won a beautiful game
against lavon oronian in such a position
so you have to be careful from white's
perspective don't just take pawns and
assume you're good but younches of duda
has undoubtedly studied these positions
so fuji goes a5 we saw e4 and as you
said donya e5 is the response
after the swap of pawns and then knights
we get this position where white plays
h3 elmira you called out in the dingly
ren game against teamwork java that you
have to look out for bishop takes h2 and
knight g4 check so h3 takes care of that
problem well first of all i still
remember
this game you know uh levon arenan
against trisha anand and maybe we'll
have some time also and we will show you
that the final sequence this game
is absolutely breathtaking but here uh
this opening actually reminds me of a
boxing match because it's very concrete
so you
should always be aware of the threat of
your opponent and with both colors and
like
well you play b5 a3 then
every time white plays e4 you should
almost always reply the e5 the
counter attack in the center then uh
blacks on e5 if you have to play h3
uh
what was the next move bishop a6 i think
here and uh
yes bishop three was played
could he play bishop rook d1 here or
it's uh unnecessary i was not sure yeah
rook d1 is possible i guess
dude is keeping his options open and
waiting to see how
alireza will react because after bishop
e3 you've completed your development
maybe this rook wants to go to d1 and
this pawn goes to f4 at some point so it
does feel like a flexible approach and
when i'm looking at this position i
understand that bishop a6 was played so
that you could play b4 and that's that's
why i wanted to play with d1 because you
should always consider the tactical
consequences because once again
bishop b6 with the idea of playing b4 so
we should calculate
what happens next just showing what b4
would be impossible the queen would be
loose there or hanging because the rook
is on the same file so after doing the
queen would have to move and
i don't know where should it go to here
or
here
that's an interesting question almost
always we ask ourselves where to put our
rocks
but here
queen e7 or queen c7
is also possible i mean i would be
inclined to put it on c7 to prevent f4
um
but
maybe f4 with the rook gone from the
king side is two weakening so maybe it's
not even a danger in the first place but
i'm impressed with the fact that duda
clearly identified alireza's idea and
bishop a6 is not exactly a mysterious
move like my wondering what he's
preparing
he stared it in the face and he ignored
duda just continues developing as if
nothing is happening so the question we
have to ask here is what happens after
b4 because
it's clear that duda is planning to
sacrifice a pawn you have to take on a6
now rook a6 a takes b4 on the rook hangs
so that's not what alirez is intending
he wants b
takes c3 instead
and i think a lot of people
you guys can
co-sign me on this would reject the line
right here out of hand the pawn will
take on b2 black will get a monster
passer that's supported by the bishop
looks terrible but let's keep
calculating bishop back to c4
the upside is that white has gotten
control of all the light squares the
bishop has no equal and here white has
rook a d1 it's very important that this
move comes with tempo because after the
queen moves let's say queen c7
white can now chase the bishop away from
e5 with that f4 queen c7 here is
actually a very very bad move because
the bishop walks inevitably into a fork
so the queen has to go elsewhere but i
think duda has seen this idea of f4 and
he has decided that his initiative and
the fact that he is a light-squared
bishop is fully compensating him against
that very nasty pawn on b2 it's a very
very sharp and interesting decision yeah
i mean what a pawn sacrifice down there
on b2
i think you're right that most people
would dismiss this you visualize a past
pawn one square away from promotion
protected by a bishop while attacking
this rook and you say no way no i can't
do this but you're absolutely right and
almira your point about f2 to f4 keeping
that rook staying on f1 it feels like
white has the activity black has the
material and if you don't kick that
bishop out and get that pawn back you
might just lose the game as white but
duda he's calculating this he's not just
seeing the future he's assessing the
position and he says i like my chances
to be honest now i
i have the feeling that he's still in
his home preparation wow
even though he spent
30 minutes or so
well but as you've said you know miranda
is such a
complex opening there are so many lines
and plans to to remember yeah
no that's totally true and maybe he had
this idea in store for a while and
finally uh
well he got the chance to use it so yeah
as the old proverb goes the faintest ink
is stronger
is more powerful than the strongest
memory so maybe this is in some file
that was recorded five years ago and
dude it just has to
access it it's in the far reaches of his
memory i totally wouldn't rule that out
in the mirror a move like bishop b3
isn't played unless you've either
calculated it very very carefully or
you've studied it beforehand
i don't think alireza though has much of
a choice having said a
you have to say b in this case
positionally you might just be
borderline lost if you don't play b4
because your bishop and a6 looks silly
the c6 pawn becomes a target and
maybe yesterday's debacle might
influence him today he pushed pawns
forward pawns can't move back and then
you get yourself some trouble but i
think as you said you say you have to
say b he's already all in on the b4 move
so we'll leave alire's offers to it
we'll leave dean lee wren and team over
java to slug out that position which
looks interesting and not clearly
defined and of course five-minute
carwana he looks to rebound today with a
win with the black pieces of richard
report but richard he is playing a
sturdy opening so
we're about an hour into the round we
are going to take our first break here
in round 12 of the 2022 feed a candidate
and we want to remind everybody of the
upcoming i am not a gm speed chess
championship featuring eric rosen and
feed a master james canty the third this
is the finale these players are playing
for gold at the razor sharp canty and
the always tricky rosen so you will not
want to miss that match up on thursday
july 7th 10 30 a.m pacific time we'll be
right back here for more coverage for
the 20 22 feet of candidates this is
chess.com broadcast we'll return shortly
[Music]
how many brilliant moves have you played
when do you play your best chess
how many games have you won by castling
in the end game
how many opponents have you played from
new zealand
and most importantly of all how many
botes gambits has alexandra botez played
find the answers to all of these
questions and many many more at
chess.com
insights
our new tool that lets you dive deep
into all of the fun and instructive data
behind your chest try it today
it took some good fortune but dingley
wren arrives at the candidates with some
very legitimate reasons to think he can
secure a bid to challenge for the world
title for the very first time
a visa issue originally kept ding out of
the last opportunity to qualify
but when a spot opened ding was next man
up based upon his hot streak of late
the timing couldn't be better for ding
an entertaining and unpredictable player
ding enters the candidates rated higher
than any player in the field
the chat went nuts they love their man
dingley ren we said this is an engine
move humans don't find it and he found
king f1 i am absolutely stunned once
again this is such a difficult move
the strongest player in china's history
ding is the only player from that
country to earn a 2800 rating
launched by an undefeated streak across
100 straight classical games ding has
sat amongst the world's top five for the
past five years
once out of the tournament completely
deng now aims to bring china into a
world chess championship match for the
first time in his native lands history
we always say we are a family the people
who come here
say that it is like being home
everyone is very comfortable here
foreign
okay
[Music]
chess kid is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
to kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking
chess kid features a comprehensive
training program that guides kids to
level up on their way to mastery this
curriculum is designed to work with
common core standards and global
educational guidelines there are more
than 50 000 chess puzzles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds chess kid helps you organize
your students and monitor their progress
each child receives a weekly report card
that shows how many lessons puzzles and
games were completed you can also
organize kids into clubs and send them
messages
chess kit is the online home of
scholastic chess for thousands of kids
parents schools and coaches signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
chess player okay
and
as we see here the players are on screen
well there are some empty chairs here
because yana pomshi and hikara nakamura
have ended their game after a short draw
in the berlin and only one player at
each board so i think we know whose move
it is fabinho karwana on the clock as is
dingley wren oh wait no i think dingley
wren has made his move with teamwork on
the clock and all there is to fruits are
trying to work through his position and
as we
have seen and mentioned still tired what
he's still talking about
i was not going there donna and someone
is pulling this on you i'm trying to
avoid that storyline and you're just
bringing it right back
into
into the discussion
oh wow okay well here we do have three
games remaining jan napomshi takes the
short draw because it allows him to
maintain his lead in this event
all eyes on dingley wren because he
needs to win and almira just during the
break we were talking about fabiano
caruana you know what he needs to do and
also the type of preparation he does
well first of all uh i think it's very
important to remind everyone how
how important the physical preparation
is for
a top chess player and i remember when
fabiano was preparing for the world
championship match against
magnus carlsen
i read a very interesting article where
he revealed well some secrets of his
preparation and i was absolutely amazed
to see that his physical preparation
consisted of like one hour of swimming
one hour of tennis i think half an hour
of basketball and also some running and
cardio training and this all this in one
day
and we are talking about the chest flare
so
now you can see uh well how important it
is
to
to be able to last in a tournament like
the candidates which
we have 14 rounds and that was one of
the things with bobby fischer there are
many interviews with him there's sports
illustrated
videos and interviews where he discussed
his physical routine because he believed
that playing chess wasn't just about
making moves on a board and doing
nothing else you need to be on tip-top
shape and we have seen that more and
more from chess players down here yeah
and i read that article with with great
pleasure i read the article that uh
scientifically analyzes the fact that a
lot of chess players lose weight during
the tournament because of the
stress and then i heard a uh an npr show
where they were making fun of that and i
just thought that you know a lot of
people do have this very short-sighted
idea that you know you're just sitting
at a board for a couple of hours and
then there are a lot of rest days and
you know you get to watch your favorite
shows in the evening
you just it's hard to convey that when
you're in a tournament like this
especially one that is 14 rounds you're
in a capsule
and every single second is full filled
with stress the moment you wake up
you're thinking about which opening
you're going to play the moment the game
ends you're not thinking about which
player you're going to order you're
thinking about the mistake and the
inaccuracy made on move 32 and why
didn't i play bishop c4 and move 48 and
maybe i would have won and then maybe
nepal wouldn't have been leading these
thoughts are constantly cycling through
your head every second of the day and
combine that with the fact that you
actually have to play a single move can
totally shuffle the standings of the
tournament the pressure is unimaginable
and it's a great privilege to have
quartzite seats to this kind of
entertainment yeah really is an absolute
privilege and i just saw the move h4
played in the top left of our screen you
know that's good news for fabiana
carwana because he needs to win today uh
mary was just talking about how he stays
in shape he hasn't quite been in shape
over the chess board in the last four
rounds ever since the second half the
tournament started he has lost three
games only drawn one i don't think we
would ever conceive of that possibility
but right now with the black pieces as
we pull this game up
he's happy to see him move like h4
because even if it makes sense and it's
a logical choice whenever someone starts
launching pawns forward it could be
scary for your king but it also creates
problems for white so amira fabi we have
him on screen here what do you make of
it well first of all we're sure that
he's playing against richard up
when we see this move on the board
it's a very creative approach in this
position i think that richard doesn't
want to trade his very powerful knight
first first of all he doesn't want to
take on b6 and he wants to play h4 h5 h6
and to well to create another weakness
the pawn on f6
it's a very good idea right because if
we just show that let's say i make some
move like a6
h5 and i'll just make a random rook move
like rook d8 and h6 you're saying that
this f6 pawn can become a target so you
have to push it and then the pawn chain
shrinks and a pawn chain is only as
strong as its base pawn f6 is more
approachable by white's pieces well then
it can be justified to take on b6 to
play an f4 there are similar ideas in
rasulima then you'll triple an f file
and
at some moment you you can even make use
of your age six months and to well to
combine some mating ideas and um
to win
the game so you're a fan of h4 is what
i'm well i like it okay
dania what about you are you a fan of
this for rich reporter if you're a
fabiano caruana fan are you happy to see
it well i have some thoughts on on this
position but i want to make a more
general point about how fashion and how
general knowledge has shifted in the
ante berlin so when it got popular about
10 years ago people were casting short
automatically that was just something
you did that was the teeth brushing in
the morning
i mean
that was like putting your pajamas on in
the evening castle's castles happened
very very early but just like
knowledge in any field
when the knowledge progresses certain
basic assumptions start being questioned
right does the earth actually revolve
around the sun
they asked after it had been assumed as
a given for thousands of years and in
the same vein people have stopped
castling at first black started castling
queenside and now both sides have
started to delay castling altogether and
it's become totally normal and you can
see in this move h4 the cat and mouse
game where both sides are trying to get
the other side to be the first one to
come in and as olmira pointed out if you
castle too early just move h4 h5 it
either induces a weakness on the g6
square black plays h6 or if white
advances the pawn to h6 then the f6 pawn
really softens up so if i'm fabiano
caruana i'm very seriously thinking
about castling queenside not immediately
but maybe after a preliminary a6 and as
i say that that is exactly what fabby
has just played i think he's preparing
queenside castles and trying to punish
richard for weakening his king side
good explanation a6 looks like an odd
move because we're talking about pawn
chains before from a7 to c5 but the pawn
chain it may shrink in the event of
bishop e3 but black can still play c5
and the pawn on b6 is quite difficult to
get to so
both sides delaying their castling
this has been a topic of conversation
throughout the candidates that people
ask my coach always tells me that you
should castle in the first 10 moves of
the game and as you get stronger and
stronger you can break those principles
because you know when to break them and
as you've been pointed out the cat and
mouse game amira when are they going to
move their kings
well first of all i wanted to uh as for
us to show like a very beautiful mate
just in case like if you castle and
knight b6 ab6 uh rook 8 mate oh gosh if
black had made this mistake 1956 you
don't want to lose your pawn on a7 so
you capture with the a pawn and then
unfortunately
you get checkmated in one move that
would be pretty tragic
yeah magnus carlsen right before he came
to madrid he played a bundesliga game
when she blundered an exact mate like
this on with 15.
i'm kidding that didn't happen yeah no i
think that people sometimes believe what
you're saying and they realize that they
shouldn't i have a very funny story
about that okay scale of 110 not funny
okay it is funny this is women yelling
give me a number seven okay wow okay go
to the starting position i hate doing
this i hate high expertise changing the
course of the game put on the night or
the night over yes so when i taught uh
at a very strong chess scam a couple of
years ago i was teaching the top group
2000 plus i was able to convince an
entire group of kids that bishop f4 in
this position was a legitimate move that
was recently played by the opening
maverick alexander maurizevich of course
there's e5 forking the two pieces they
literally believed me until the end of
the class what was the rating 2021 2200
that's the power of authorities i'm
saying something you know even though
half of the things i say are untrue
so now everybody's watching the tens of
thousands of people are thinking about
everything you've said on the broadcast
right do i actually believe a word that
he said you shouldn't
yes but it's very important we would you
have to question authority you know
nothing so we were we were talking about
questioning uh everything and every
dogmatic way of thinking so well here we
are and i did say that i get puzzles
where the answer is just an equal
position because you should always be
using your own brains not just relying
on somebody else so that is true that is
good robert has his brain never do that
coming back to the position and um well
to your question robert when they are
going to castle
uh this is a very interesting dance
we have here
so after a6 uh fabienna wants well at
least he has this possibility to cast so
long um what can richard do about this
well
he we're about to find out h5 it looks
like he's just going all in with that
pawn and a question i had
can this bishop move
the knight on c4 is a very strong piece
but maybe i want to move my bishop to c5
and say you're not going to trade off
ever on b6 and that might give fabiano
some more winning chances because the
more pieces are made on the board the
more options you have so i have been
wondering if fabinho can move his bishop
and maybe even to the d4 square because
most times you put a piece on d4 gets
kicked out immediately but you're
inducing a weakness in c3 and i wouldn't
even mind going all the way back to a7
that's another thing a6 did because this
d3 pawn is a huge target a knight comes
to c5 a rook comes to date whether or
not i castle and then i'm gonna go right
for that pawn so i feel like fabiano who
understands these positions very well he
might just keep his bishop here i we do
want to have the opportunity to put a
knight here but h6 in and of itself
isn't that scary i pushed g6 and i could
always put a rook on f8 and now that my
pieces are out the way i can castle
queen side and maybe even play for f5
actually
it's a very interesting opening strategy
he kept his bishop on b6 he prevent
wyatt with the most obvious from the
most obvious plan uh c3 and d4 or d4
and now uh well i like your idea he well
he can play bishop d4 bishop c5 and to
keep this bishop alive on the board and
maybe bishop c5 is also possible because
it could be transferred to um
to the king side and to protect the in
order to protect the f6 spawn so
it's uh
it's very interesting but on there on
the other hand if you play bishop d4 can
i start with uh knight t3 and knight to
five
certainly can and the thing is once your
knight gets there now h6 g6 will come
with a tempo against this knight so it
feels like this knight on e6 is really
the great piece in black's position
because not only does it defend g7 from
any attacks it can always hop forward
and it stops they move f4 so i do like
these positions from the black side i
have a slight bias because i play them
from the black side and fabiano instead
of moving his bishop just castles
queenside he is not afraid of the
capture but i feel like for richard if
he doesn't capture that bishop fabiano
will move it out the way and then it
won't be easy for him to
play because it's not clear what his
plan is i think maybe now uh
it's very important to take this bishop
because you can play bishop b3 with the
tempest so you develop a piece uh well
most probably richard will castle long
as well
so what do you think knight b6 it takes
b6 bishop b3
uh
[Music]
if
fabi plays c5 okay we'll analyze that
here knight takes b6
pawn takes bishop e3 and c5 i mean
at some point you may consider the movie
yeah queen d2 could be
an interesting canada move here to
potentially as elmira said prepare
castling and simultaneously it's kind of
funny because black has so much control
of this board like this knight is great
this bishop even though it has opponent
sights that pawn is defended by a knight
the queen can always move up the board
to defend the pawn
i like this position for black i really
do i just feel like the bishop doesn't
have as much promise as the knight and
the side that controls the pawn breaks
is usually aside with the advantage and
i could see an f5 coming or even a c4 so
i think that black has a little bit more
control i agree with you conceptually i
do think that if white castles queen
side in a position like this now you
could throw an h6 g6 we could debate
uh the
usefulness of that but white does have
this plan of going g3 and f4 and trying
to expand on the king side and i much
preferred black's position had fabby
saved the bishop i really think fabi
should have put more thought into
playing your move bishop d4 there's also
a very powerful psychological effect
that such a move produces because when
there's an option that you dangle in
front of your opponent for several moves
and then your opponent doesn't take it
and then that ship sails i feel like
richard would have started questioning
himself maybe i should have taken that
bishop when i had a chance maybe i
shouldn't have let fabby keep that
bishop on the board now he gives richard
another opportunity
and
i
very strongly feel that white needs to
hop on this opportunity train before
that bishop moves because if he doesn't
take the bishop here then i think fabby
will probably move it to d4 or a7
agreed so richard
he has his work cut out for him will he
take on b6 that's the big question he is
down a little bit in the clock but still
doing fine as we look at our
fool as a four board view but one maybe
it's already done as richard takes the
knight on b6 uh the bottom right we saw
yonder palm shakar nakamura make a very
quick draw and oh bottom left by the way
we see that duda and farouza are going
down this variation it's going to be a
slugfest between those two and dingley
run he has a lot to prove because it
looks like his position as a car
nakamura predicted is worse with the
white pieces and every single half point
in this tournament is meaningful because
the players they get additional money
for every half point it's 3 500 euros
per half point so thus far in the in the
tournament the players are adding that
up until they
see the final standings and may add
24k euros per third 36 per second and
not bad 48 000 euros for first so what
what are the players earned thus far
that's the big question i know a lot of
people when they watch chess tournaments
i was like how much do the players make
why do they get these secret appearance
fees and we can't figure it out because
of course everyone wants in on everyone
else's business but we do have that
information that jan naponshi has
already made 60 000 euros approximately
wow
i'm mesmerized by those numbers
not bad
he's going to raid that test the
dealership he comes back home
and you know alireza perugia down there
in eighth place still has made 28 000
euros and with every half point he
scores
that's 3 500 so if he wins a game that's
7 000 euros for each win well it's a
very important prize poll and well it
looks like a poker tournament you were
discussed in poker tournaments with
hikaru or so
and i think that's the first time that
the money is distributed in this way
that players uh get additional money for
for half of half the point and
which is also interesting is that
fabiano said that the press conference
that he doesn't even know what was the
first prize
all what mattered to him is as i told
you you know it's the first place and
well to play for something greater uh to
have a shot for the world championship
title and that prize is much bigger than
even these but still it's good to see
the players getting rewarded for their
efforts they put a lot of energy in and
these prizes do not include the first
through third additional prize fund so
with yonder palm she already securing at
least
59
500 euros
if he keeps this he'll gain that extra
48 000 euros to that so he's making a
huge payday here in madrid so uh on that
note we're going to remove the money but
the players are hoping to find money
moves here
my eyes are on that dingley run for
jabba game dingley wren down on the
clock with the white pieces and his
position just looks worse right black is
the bishop pair and timur is taking a
page out of his book using that queen's
rook and doing work with it usually it's
dingley round of the rook on b6 or b3
by move 17.
this is
i mean he called it i think he carl
called it even when the position was
closer to equal objectively and things
are kind of getting worse for white
and we should explain by the way why
knight takes d5
isn't just a free pawn here but
more generally do you agree with my
general assessment that this is souring
for ding yeah i'm just going to show why
it looks like it's just a free pawn in
this position but the problem is this
king is still in the center so you're
giving black all of this time to make
moves like queen of the v8 hitting the
bishop here this rook is going to come
over to c8 and if you just move your
bishop away let's say bishop a1 ruxia
look at black's play here all the pieces
working together and you think yeah it's
not a big deal i'm going to move my
queen where do you think you're going to
move your queen to if you go queen a2
that runs into e6 thank you very much
for your rook it's pinned here if you
move your queen to d2 you've blocked
your rook's access back to d1 so here
comes rookbee one check the position
falls apart immediately so dingley rent
can't go upon grabbing and almiro we
were looking at this knight a6 move back
in the opening timor clearly coming
prepared and it looks strange but it's
paying off
well i think this move uh looks uh very
natural uh after you have played bishop
d3 there are similar ideas in the
karakan
uh very often you use you wait for uh
white to play bishop d3 and then you
want to play uh knight d6 and almost
always black has
sufficient compensation for this very
strange looking pawn structure
but coming to the position on the board
what explains that ding is thinking for
such a long time because there is no
comfortable way for you to castle here
because
one of the maneuvers for black is to
play bishop b8 and uh queen c7
at some point and you cannot play g3
in this position
because the pawn on h3 is hanging and
knight f4 is always met with g5
yeah just going right for the attack and
little things make the biggest
differences at the top level so i'm
gonna go back to that moment with knight
a6 this actually
might have been a really critical moment
digler did take time he put his knight
to e2 maybe he should put his knight in
f3 and the reason you don't typically
want to put your knight there is that at
some moment bishop g4 will be annoying
to deal with because with the knight in
e2 bishop g4 is a non-issue but with
knight and f3 potentially capturing here
would double white's pawns but knight f3
if we continued with the same line c5
bishop takes pawn takes like this
then white has an easier time castling
because the knight is better placed on
f3 the second knight can also go to e2
to blockade the isolated pawn so i
wonder if dingley ren got a second
chance you know he plays this game and
immediately plays another game right
after if he would pinpoint that move on
move nine and say knight f3 was actually
an improvement oops
it's a very interesting idea and i also
wanted to ask you
what was the
black's idea
if i would play b4 not knight f3
because i was thinking how do you
justify
playing knight a6 here
maybe c6 knight c7 and a5 is the general
queen sight strategy here
something like this i still think ding
would have probably preferred this
position over
over what he got
but here i think he was concerned about
black using the pawn as a hook
right because the carl's bought
structure and you know whites plays for
b5 but that opens up the queen side and
can be a problematic in the knight
quickly hopping around to c7 maybe into
e6 later and black will have more
firepower on the king side and i've seen
better dark shard bishops in my life so
bishop c1 and g5 would have been
an excellent move here of course but
maybe we can make it work here bishop a6
here
and knight a4
like
you're just trying to go for this pawn
it looks like that you know this pawn
unfortunately going forward it's a
little slow because the king is in the
center wipes down several moves in
development and maybe you can protect
the pawn or just play move like a5
because
steal this pawn here i think that
whoa i was gonna say a rook b8 but i'm
looking now and says a takes b4 giving
up this rook in the corner is good for
black catastrophic lack of development
here is what
destroys white in these positions yeah
the queen is trapped in the corner so uh
black's next move is like bishop a6 the
queen's trap your king's in the center
no good all around this line helps us to
understand the nuances and the positions
so this uh
this line is very tricky
yeah it is and
ding didn't push the pawn or bring his
knight to f3 he goes to e2 and as we
catch back up b4
bishop b2 and a5 black's play is so
simple right he goes b5 black plays a6
and exactly what we're talking about
with hikaru and dingley ren tried to
develop but the bishop comes out to d7
and that rook comes up the board here
and finally after rook b6 there's so
much pressure in this position and ding
has nothing to show for it right it's a
pair of bishops a very healthy position
for black every single piece except for
the rook on f8 and maybe that will go to
see it or as we're showing more likely
queen b8 and brook c8 but every piece is
doing something for black and white
hasn't castled the bishop on b2 it would
like to get an open diagonal but it
could just become a target the queen is
in line here when a rook comes to c8
really nice position for black yeah
i'm surprised about two things the first
is i'm wondering where exactly ding's
preparation ended because the move
knight a6 while it seems very cutting
edge it's been around for a very long
time are very hard working producers
they told us that this move actually
occurred in a fm bogalubov game
game hillberg in 1790 i believe it was
burned 1932. it was yeah 1932 and
bogalubov uh was a world championship
challenger he did lose to i believe
alexander alakine one of the leading
uh opening specialists
of his time so this move was known and
the second thing that shocked me was
b2b4 because he played this move robert
as you were indicating that this move
essentially hands black queen side play
on a silver platter
yeah and uh
it allows black to play a5 and i thought
that ding had some sort of follow-up
idea but he really didn't and he hasn't
come up with an adequate response to
rajab's massive queen side pressure and
now he's in big trouble amira the last
three games that dingleran has won he
probably didn't feel any pressure right
because he was in a minus score he won a
game even score he wins again okay i'm
still you know in the running but far
away do you think he's starting to feel
more pressured now that he's won a bunch
i was sure that it was more about
pressure than feeling uh maybe over
optimistic you know about uh his
position and maybe
losing his objectivity like at this
concrete moment of the game so now i i'm
pretty sure that he realizes that his
position is um
well
very dangerous
to put it the least and uh i i was i
wanted to ask you the question so is he
thinking about
like a very concrete line so to
exchange a few pieces and to make a draw
here i think you would love that
yeah i think he does as you said he
realizes he's worse so if he could
exchange pieces and make a draw he
probably would do that especially hikaru
just drew so he knows that if he draws
his game he'll still have a half point
lead on the car who he plays with the
white piece in the last round so there's
no reason to go all in but i think he's
worried that he's gonna slip from being
slightly worse by the evaluation bar to
like
really worse because uh the pawn on a3
won't make moves necessarily but if we
just look at the outlines if the queen
comes the b8 and you say i'll just put
my bishop back on a1 then this pawn a3
could drop as well and you definitely
don't want to put your bishop back on c1
staring into your own pawn so ding is
faced with many tough decisions here and
if he has any hope of catching yonda
pomnishi he will need to win this game
and jan he spoke to dina bellancaya so
let's hear his thoughts about his game
and his tournament standings
jan berlin we kind of expected it but
still had some hope you know for
for hikaru going for a fight and
yet he chose berlin do you think it was
the right choice uh
well it's hard to say so it's
i mean okay basically the ball was on
his side so
i mean obviously
one can try
few ideas against the berlin but i guess
okay a lot of players here i mean
okay for example at least the current
team or they play berlin so
i mean surely uh
it could be played differently but in
general once again charming situation
probably screams that uh so far i
shouldn't like burn some bridges
so i was like preparing for all kind of
i don't know
uh murky lines like i don't know maybe
some beer course some i don't know rare
spanish lines but uh
yeah i felt like okay if berlin then
okay then that's it and in general i
would say he shows like very nice level
of prep here with both colors so it's uh
i mean
i got i can't say that i was really into
you know refuting the berlin today right
and uh in general overlooking at all
your games here in uh at the candidates
in madrid what do you think so far has
been the reason of your success
i don't know i'm just trying to keep you
know my head calm and uh not
you know let you know
any emotions uh drive me so
trying to do my job more or less and
maybe that's
that could be
this could be the difference with the
players who like play their first
candidates but
i mean it's
it's hard to judge yeah so once again
it's like we
like as spectators like we can see only
you know very very very few aspects and
a lot uh you know
a lot you know the bigger part of
iceberg is surely hidden here so that's
we don't really know what's happening in
every player's team
now the distress is uh slightly uh going
down any particular plans for tomorrow
rest day apart from lying in the bed
uh lying in the bed yeah so i mean okay
the tournament is uh nothing like over
yes so it's
still i have two games which could be
like extremely tense
and uh
i
mean so far once again so far it's good
but i mean it's
it's true you know to give some promises
thanks a lot jan thank you
this is
jan napomshi he draws hikaru nakamura he
just has two games remaining including
white after the rest day against richard
report and the last round black against
john schuster duda
he showed a lot of respect for his
fellow competitors because he mentioned
how hikara has been in great form has
shown great preparation he said i don't
refute the berlin today
well of course he knows that uh there
are still two games left and what i
liked about this interview that he well
that's why i didn't want to talk about
jan yesterday i know that he's not he
doesn't allow himself to feel you know
he's restraining himself and uh
he he knows there's still a lot of
pressure on him
uh and
it might not seem like this but he's a
very sensitive guy you know so
um
he showed a very impressive play like
till now
and he feels that he needs you know to
stay very focused in order to finish the
tournament
but
one also
interesting thing is that he said that
we don't know what is the bigger picture
is it's just what we see is just the tip
of the iceberg and what is the
preparation uh what players feel during
the tournament
and uh this was a very important comment
yeah and he also said at the end dyna
the tournament's not over yet that you
know it's tense for him so do you think
he really believes that or do you think
at this point he's seeing the finish
line and seeing everybody else behind
him i think both can
both can be true at the same time jan is
obviously aware of the reality he knows
that while the tournament isn't in the
bag just yet
barring a miracle if he continues
playing
you know even 80 percent of the strength
that he's played thus far in the
tournament you should be able to lock up
first place with that being said i need
to keep coming back to the point that i
made at the start of the tournament
anybody in the candidates is capable of
beating anybody else and jan understands
that perfectly he's playing richard
report in the next round there's a very
high probability that report with
nothing left to lose isn't just going to
play the berlin
or even the sebastian cobb again both of
which are openings against which there
are reliable lines that essentially
always
lead to a draw rapport might play the
scandy or a perk or something crazy so
jan knows that he has two very difficult
fights ahead of him and he knows that if
he messes up his next game with white
the tournament is going to be blown wide
open and his last round matchup against
jkd with the black pieces is no easy
matter as well so tomorrow's rest day is
a critical one for him it's one that he
will spend in a disciplined way
alternating between the bed and the
laptop
and i think what might play a part in
this is what happens in young church up
to this game today because john schuster
gets white in that 14th and final round
against yon napomnishi and he could
spoil yan's tournament so
duda beat five men on carwana
right now he's playing as alireza
version a very sharp game and if he can
win this game with the white pieces i
think gets white in the final round
against yon judah is the type of person
who's not just going to hand you on the
tournament he's not just to say we'll
make a berlin draw from the white side
he will play and he has come to play
today
he absolutely has and what a fascinating
turn of events now we got word that at
least up until bishop c4 will update you
they were following two alexei shearer
games from over a decade ago
and uh sure of is one of the
main proponents of [ __ ] type structures
he is an expert in the slav and our
team is very hard at work verifying
whether they are still following any
games but the interesting decision was
queen e7 and they are still indeed
following a game between daniel dubov
and alexey sharp that is incredible and
looking at from 2013 and looking at the
clock remaining in their times
at the time remaining
[Laughter]
looking at the clock remaining other
times
uh it's quite clear that neither of them
are aware of it in an exchange
sacrificed by holly rosa frugia robert i
think he'll second me on this queen e7
that he played two moves ago i'm pretty
sure it was not a blunder i think it is
a conscious decision to get rid of
white's dark squared bishop and make it
impossible to play f2f4 and there we see
jkd grabbing that exchange on f8 and
what a sequence this is and first of all
shout out to alexis shirov always fire
on board when that man plays and it
makes me think if they didn't spend so
much time i would have said is alexi one
of these players seconds is he working
with somebody but clearly they haven't
seen this position before because you
don't spend this kind of time to get
here but that move queen e7 as i point
out it wasn't a blunder bishop c5 is a
wonderful move if you think you have a
free piece think again because when
pieces are in line with one another
think about happen what happens when the
piece in between gets out the way and
here it can do just that with check to
the king on j8 thank you very much for
your queen and thank you for the game so
the queen slides over to c7 and we see
bishop takes f8 into the last move
played and after black recaptures this
bishop i'm not sure if you take with the
king or with the rook but either way
what black has accomplished by giving up
a rook for a minor piece is that you
also have this pawn and it's not any
pawn it's a polynom b2 and that's one
square away from promotion it's
protected by a bishop on the dark
squares and then we'll have this dynamic
with bishops of opposite color i'll just
take with the king just so i can get the
position to be finalized here when you
have a material imbalance and you have
not just a rook for a knight and pawn
but also obstacle bishops it's the side
that can control squares has a safer
king to the side that's happy so amira
which side would you be happy playing
with
after already recaptures an f8
i actually like black's position uh
but i had a question yes i wanted to ask
you given a choice you know one of my
favorites movies once again is like bean
and binjo and malkovich so if you could
spend the night in one player's head and
to look to have a look in some of those
flying folders you know would it be
daniel do wolf or what player would it
be
don you go first because i need to think
about my hands oh my goodness this is a
mouth-watering question i mean alexia
i'd settle for alexis shearov
i would definitely set her for lexi
shrub but i also
if i got a chance to play blitz on
chess.com then i choose to kara nakamura
because i want to experience what is it
like yeah to be
that good at blitz but from the point of
view of creative thinking alexander
morizevich alexey sheriff daniel dubois
all of those names come to mind as
alireza without much hesitation decides
to take an f8 with a rook but let me put
you on the spot
do i only have to hear their thoughts
about chess
anything you want oh my gosh
open-ended question
fly on the wall
wow
um maybe i'll go with levon aronian
he's a man with many interests so i feel
like he wouldn't spend all day just
thinking about chess and because you
know i i do talk about chess and i
that's my profession but i also like a
lot of other things i love learning i
feel like lavon he's well versed in so
many things and he really is a curious
guy and also his chess style right he
comes in the board with some kind of cat
t-shirt and really fancy outfits of all
sorts of colors but the way he plays
kind of matches his like style his
fashion sense so levon's i think a
pretty decent answer and
i don't know i i've never thought about
that before well i was just thinking but
maybe we can ask our chat yeah that's a
great let's have a chat that's a great
thing then we could pull up some of the
interesting responses look at elmira as
you're getting used to the chat get
involved we may feature some of your
responses here who would you like to be
inside the head of what chess player
there are so many great answers now that
i'm really thinking about the question i
mean of course hikaru and maurizevich as
you mentioned so i mean just counts
vishy anand just so you know does he sit
right on a big chair and just think
about the world championships he's won
you know is he just sitting there oh
yeah my game man's kramnik where i beat
him that was just really a brilliant
game
yeah
if the hess was in my mind i would never
make the same mistake in my life i think
that is just not true but that's an
incredibly flattering comment that is
totally true and you know it oh my gosh
and this is interesting by the way as we
pull up more fascinating chat answers g2
g3 quickly played by i was going to say
duboff dubois did play this move duda
and dubaf have played this move and they
are still following the game
any chance
that one of the players that played a
psychological trick
that do you think it's possible that jan
chistov who
allowed this
series of events here
do you think that he's been spending
time and luring alireza into a sense of
comfort or that we're both on neutral
territory whereas jan schistoff is you
know still in prep or is he just such a
strong player that he's going to play
the best move that came in a predecessor
i think that they've seen so many games
that uh
there is a particular image that
they still have you know in their head
they might not be sure you know of
the concrete variation or the pattern
but
anyway this variation is always very
sharp so you have to be sure first of
all about what you are doing and i'm
pretty
they're pretty aware i think
of several games that have been played
in this variation but
we'll ask them after the game yes we
certainly will and we have another chat
the miss amigos guy well danny and while
he is back in the united states and i'm
sure he's watching the broadcast uh i i
don't know if i want to know what's
going on his head half the time because
the way he comes up with all sorts of
uh pop culture references and he
electrocuted himself at 12 he stole that
story a bunch of times so not dan and
just kidding we love you so arena crush
especially for efforts in the world
match against kasparov well that'd be
interesting to hear about but what if
she doesn't think about that every day i
doubt that she thinks about that every
single day so you might be in her head
and she's just you know living her life
not saying that it wouldn't be an
interesting mind to get into but if you
want something specific then a niche
gear yeah that's a great answer
want to know what makes him think what
he tweets who says he thinks before he
tweets
no
aren't all the best tweets just spur of
the moment decisions
i wouldn't know
true i tweet i don't know i haven't only
[ __ ] a few times in my life
fascinating chat engagement thank you to
everybody for putting that into that
question anyone saying
diamond membership and i have that power
but i'm not giving you one homie fun
uncle because danny would just for your
username oh no not from me here nice try
you want to call everybody else out just
so you seem like the cool kid who's
trying to get you know the diamond
membership pretending like you're not
interested i see right through you no no
diamond membership for you damn girl
you've blasted that attempt
at free merch i saw him
why i'm nice to my students
but i don't know homie fun uncle
but back to the game you know g3 was
played white's idea is pretty obvious
he wants to play f4 e5 and to
open
well the
big diagonal also for the light square
bishop
this plate in the game that we were
annoying yeah this is indeed what we've
played there's still in that
game from dew bombshell which was the
draw black played c5 we'll keep showing
white played f4 here and maybe that's
not the best move as we see the eval bar
start going down so of course because
young chistophe and alvarez are seeing
it for the first time they might are
very likely to deviate and then bishop
d4 check was played king to h2
queen went to b7 rookie won and just in
general this position is one where this
pawn isn't going anywhere anytime soon
but the bishop has found a safe haven on
d4 so the only way to get rid of that
bishop is by sacrificing your rook for
it the game continued rook to b8 the
bishop went to a2
pawn to g6
upon the e5 knight to d5 now that knight
is trying to jump into the action and
rook d3
eight i don't even know if i would
consider the move a4 it seems so random
wow over here that's a sure i've moved
if i've ever seen one a4 i guess i would
now that i'm actually looking at what
white's plan was taking away the b3
square and all right the game continued
and finished relatively shortly looks
like queen
d2
wait
and a repetition just moves repeatedly
weird computer-like repetition
that not there
although that actually would have been
fine but what a strange end to that game
i don't think we're getting that but we
are getting a move
wow and i really wrestled with g4 in the
free game and now g5 in this game oh my
gosh and you know who else played g5
against five minute carwana and uh i
made a mistake there
regret it it was fabiano caruana he
plays g5 does ala raza faruja he's
trying to stop pawn daff iv but i don't
think he stopped the move has he only
made it stronger in fact he might have
because if white plays f4 black has one
two three pieces covering the square and
that means it's a pawn sacrifice but
let's not forget the bishop is doing a
very important job it is defending this
pawn on b2 so bishop takes f4 there's
queen takes b2 sure the bishop can go
back to e5 but white is very happy about
this because white has an extra rook for
a knight and now has increased pressure
pawns are gone open files are there and
this looks very very good for yanchestav
duda
yeah i'm
it looks like alvarez was doing a lot of
uh positional exercise like uh studies
well well he was not playing you know it
seems like he wants to fix a structure
it's a very symmetrical move when you
have a knight on e5 for example the pawn
on f on a4 and then you play g5 but with
queens on board
yeah
it's almost like
he's only adding more kindling to the
fire
rather than extinguishing it now to your
question about whether there is any
possibility that the players
have seen this before i think the answer
actually is yes i think what a lot of
people might overlook is that duda might
have actually just remembered that this
is in his files you might have forgotten
it and then when you're analyzing a
large swath of openings you need memory
markers and maybe he hit upon one of
those memory markers and said wait a
second this must be the sure up game
that i found an improvement in but g5 if
that is the case is definitely a move
that he hasn't seen before he's on his
own
and you know what the problem is with
this move
it's that dude just doesn't have all
that many ideas here which i think makes
f2f4
easier to find and a lot easier to play
because if you're not playing f4 what
else are you doing there's no other way
to dislodge the bishop on e5 and that
means there's no other way to get to the
b2 pawn i think we're going to see f4
and i think alireza might be in trouble
yet again it helps that he was already
thinking about f4 right he played g3 to
make sure that f4 could work so he's
much more likely to find it and let's
not forget the game he won against five
minute carwana his
amazing move f4 right near the time
trouble that was a tactical shot that
earned him the victory so f4 makes
perfect sense the game doesn't just end
there are all sorts of ideas with his
queen and then you come to b6 with check
and the bishop trying to come to d4 but
the bishop doesn't have the stronghold
over the square with the pawn as it does
the pawn c5 it feels like black's pieces
a queen to b6 and bishop d4 you're going
away from this king on g8 and with the
move f4 coming and files opening this
king looks like it's the one that's
going to be in trouble because white has
the extra rook for a knight
maybe this is where he could use that he
there is a further flue of the handle
yeah
because i i cannot understand this move
wow i think i might have an idea about
what elioraza might have underestimated
here okay let's handle if we go down
that line one more time f4
gfgf bishop f4 that seems essentially
forced from a human perspective
queen takes b2 bishop back to e5 if you
look at this superficially you might say
well
that bishop on e5 is pretty stable and
black has this clear idea of going king
h8 and rook g8 that knight from f6 also
has a pathway to g3
via h5 or e4 so from those angles it
might seem like black is full
compensation but let's go two more moves
ahead queen g2 check
looks like it only fans the flames rook
g8 is a threat but white is the
cold-blooded queen f3 which does three
things prevents titan takes e4 it
prevents knight h5 and it takes the
sting out of a check on g8 why does it
take this thing out of that check
because the king shifts to the right and
rook g1 is going to follow and once
black's temporary initiative is
extinguished it could just be lost yeah
the queen defends everything over here
on the king's side and as you said rook
g1 white has two rooks and while black
still has a pawn and knight it's not the
same pawn give me one of these let's put
that down there right that's a really
good form of compensation upon f7 no
that's not doing the trick so
almira as we see ian shifts up on screen
here is he just really focused or is he
uncomfortable do you think he didn't
expect g5 and
now is feeling some discomfort
i'm not sure he's such a strong player
so
first of all he doesn't believe his eyes
that this move is even possible
and uh it's also like i think
if we would be in his head right now
it's like the computer switch you know
he understands that's now is the moment
where the evaluation of the position
changed completely and he needs to find
uh a clear-cut line he's looking at four
i'm watching his eyes i mean he's a
hundred percent looking on f4 and
maybe he knows what he is going to do
and that's why he's kind of sitting in
this position uh but
we've seen in previous rounds yanchez
stuff dude even when he's uh fine
according to the engines even when he
knows he probably is doing okay we've
seen him have some body language some
slumping in his chair or some slouching
i should say so
there are moments throughout this event
where yon just hasn't looked comfortable
but i think he is going to play f4 and
it's alireza who is not going to be
happy
well he's smiling yeah now he's smiling
because he knows that he's the topic of
conversation right i'm saying all the
wrong things and he knows robert hess is
talking about him which is a very
special occasion no but no i think he
knows that i'm wrong and so he's gonna
have the last laugh
yeah i mean i think that
and and as bonanza bros i think is
making a great point i think jan holt
just holds his head while he's
calculating lol he always looks stressed
i agree and i think that's why i don't
like to base firm conclusions
off of looking at someone's facial
expressions because you might grimace
just because on move 10 of the variation
you're calculating something didn't work
out it doesn't mean you think your
overall position is bad
you know
he might be thinking about move 20 of
the game he played four games ago you
just can't know for a fact
i think jana is perfectly happy with his
position and i think we're gonna see up
four within a couple of minutes i will
just quickly not counter but uh maybe
raise a specific moment when he played
against yonda pomnesi after the game he
pretty much said like oh it was all
going downhill for me it seemed like he
felt like he never really had a chance
and you're right that you know we never
really know what the players are but i
agree that in that case you couldn't
know yeah but unless we do elmira's
experiment where we get in the player's
head for a day so we never will know the
truth behind their thinking unless they
tell us so i think duda you know he i
think the commenter is right that duda
just happens to like that pose maybe
that's his modeling look but either way
he does look really focused and he i i
would have a hard time imagining him not
playing f4 and these players i think
everybody who's trying to chase down yon
napomshi
dingley run in particular he's looking
at yan chistop he knows that yanchez
plays napoli in the final round so
dingley wren just made a wow what a
movie made that looks
terrible we're gonna have to go over to
that game because i was just mentioning
the world number two player the number
one player from china and he just made
the move pawn f2 oh my god
three
and he doesn't have a oh my gosh his
problems not three good
this looks very suspicious
well he wants to play king f2 knight d4
and to hold this position
wow
will it work though because if black
positions his queen on b8 the thing is
there's a hole on g3 and if you play
king f2 knight d4 is always going to be
met with
bishop g3 check so you could tack on
some pressure with rook f8 to e8
and oh my lens does this position suck
for white
oh my gosh i mean dingley wren we knew
after the opening stage we started
thinking he wasn't comfortable but now
his position is just bad he's got
weaknesses all across the board there's
pressure down the b files pressure on
the e file is pressured on the diagonal
and white by comparison is extremely
passive without any very clear ideas so
dangly wren
i don't know what's going on this game a
team over job love if he wins he's back
to an even score if he wins this game
he's only a half point behind daily wren
and out of nowhere timor will be
fighting for that second place and more
importantly jan napomnishi
guarantees himself
at least the two-point lead right yes
unless
no even if fabiano caruana was correct
let's pull up the standings for a second
just to verify that that would be
absolutely huge that means jan would
guarantee himself a playoff even if he
loses the last two games and either ding
or hikaru win the last two games which
is already exceedingly unlikely well and
he reached like eight and a half points
out of 12 which
was the tournament victory for the
previous candidates and a few of them
before
he still has two rounds
um so
and he gets the white piece against
richard report next so if he wants to do
what he did just did it against a card
definitely again report he would force
that draw win the candidates for around
despair for the second time in a row so
jan gets the white piece against richard
everybody else in the field i think
richard himself will play something
combative because uh richard seems to be
a very sporting individual right he
regretted his decision against yonder
palmish in the first half because that
objectively should have been a draw and
then he just lost the game because he
didn't take the draw but on move one you
can do whatever you want and nobody's
going to blame you for trying and
honestly who cares what anybody else
says but even if rapport can't get first
place can't get second place i feel like
he's the type of player for the sake of
the tournament will give it their all
where many other people would just say
here's a handshake congratulations you
go to play magnus or if max declines the
second place finisher well and he's not
going to throw away the game
which is even more important
i do not see on losing the last two
games so for ding
it's going to be critical right now to
play perfectly he has to be perfect the
rest of the game if he wants to save
this position
i don't know how it's going to happen
but he's going to have to pull a rabbit
out of his head where drove up is 20
minutes up on the clock
he's flat out winning out of the opening
of the black pieces against a dingley
round who's won three games in a row
that's why we watch the candidates you
never know what's going to happen and
much has been said about
timor java he hadn't won a game since
2019 in classical chess before this
event he beat hikaru nakamura who yonder
palmishi was saying is in great shape
with great preparation and if he could
be dingly wren who just won three in a
row now the fight for second is wide
open in this position i mean it really
does not look pleasant for white because
of the peace placement because of the
weakness on e3 but there's a lot of
fight left because if rajav can't find
the right sequence of moves we have some
plans for white now the king is going to
f2 he didn't want to castle and just to
show you that the reason you don't want
a castle when a queen and bishop are
lined up is because there could be
sacrifices so just a turn to go castling
might have just allowed bishop takes h3
and that's what dinglerang was afraid of
after g takes the queen happily takes an
h3 there's a checkmate thread here if
you block the checkmate threat with your
pawn in comes the knight this is just
devastating you lose the game and you
also lose everything in the position and
just no hope uh this is
game over so dingley wren feels like he
has to castle by hand starting with f3
he'll put his king enough to bring the
rook into the game and if rajavov can't
find a knockout then he'll still have
chances
we have so much going on in this round
one game happened to be a draw very
quickly we still have three exciting
games in store for you all and
two hours into the round it's time for
our second short break and there's not
much of a break after the candidates
tournament because when the candidates
tournament concludes the blitz champs
event is coming your way watch your
favorite nfl stars compete for their
share of the 100 000
charity fund there is hall of fame wide
receiver larry fitzgerald hoping to
receive the most of his opportunities
against linebacker michael parsons we
have the top five pick cave on thibodeau
and of course new cleveland browns
receiver amari cooper some of the
biggest names in the league will be
there july 9th and 10th at 1 pm pacific
time
so as we leave the players in the hall
trying to work their way through the
calculations we'll head to break we'll
see you soon for more from round 12 of
the feeder candidates
[Music]
how many brilliant moves have you played
when do you play your best chess
how many games have you won by castling
in the end game
how many opponents have you played from
new zealand
and most importantly of all how many
botez gambits has alexandra botez played
find the answers to all of these
questions and many many more at
chess.com
insights
our new tool that lets you dive deep
into all of the fun and instructive data
behind your chest try it today
apparently this is the horse she rode in
on literally queen isabella herself on a
knight a noble steed you know changed
the world forever it's why
everyone in madrid
knows the game of chess
they know that the candidates is here
they know that that this is
one of the capital cities of our great
game and it's all because of that lady
right there on that noble steed now
that's a 9. thank god for queen isabella
changing the rules right and giving the
queen her powers i know that in the
filming we're really running with this
but in my head it was the queen of
france so that begs the question who is
the chess.com historian and can i fire
them um
well you'd have to fire yourself i think
yeah that's good
that's uh call that's an out take i
believe they call it him yeah i'll take
so mike's gonna say was the queen of
spain next time he knows he knows yeah
we gotta find more about this lady
and find more about what the people know
here
[Music]
you guys excited for the candidates
hey can we talk for a second about this
here we go
to the plaza we go
which way is the plaza
you guys play chess yeah yeah yeah
there you go
are you excited for the candidates yeah
yeah yeah
you don't know what it is
okay what is it we've watched the
queen's game oh you've watched the
queen's gambit me too okay you guys
actually play chess like on your phone
what are you playing chess.com yeah
you're about 1300 on leash yes yeah so
it means you'd be like 900 on chess.com
actually
yeah give me your username i'll give you
a diamond membership
not kidding he's going to be a contender
in like three years
he's up and coming so i'll give you a
premium membership and then you won't
have an excuse then you can use that
i'll go back to it yeah all right man
you're an am that's me man
he's like number one oh yeah the guy
that like beats yeah so this tournament
decides who plays magnus carlson
so the next challenger comes out of this
tournament all right guys enjoy thank
you so
trip guys there you go no drinking no
drinking
still no drinking that's true you guys
are connected now yeah we're buddies on
we're going to send each other some
ticks do you think they already talked
and then we'll we'll we'll talk about it
is that your phone buzzing because they
are there they already yeah they're
already hitting me up for my digits okay
yep maybe wearing a pager wasn't the
smartest idea to fit in with them
[Music]
[Music]
want to hold a massive chess tournament
with dozens of clubs or hundreds of
players or maybe a small chess
tournament with local but competitive
clubs with club arenas you can
club arenas allow for tournaments of any
size with any number of clubs and
players customize the arena with any
time control with standard chests or
mini chest variants and with any
starting position you want club arenas
are the most flexible tournament format
on chess.com try one out today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
that my friends is a chess legacy
passion for chess
continues to thrive in madrid
for the first time in 30 years spain's
capital plays host to the candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
and he definitely knows that he hasn't
made his 40 oh no
oh my goodness
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
[Music]
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess yet still
chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
miss amigos
the next challenger to the world
champion of chess must come through
madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
[Music]
and we see players in material park they
are playing in a simul having a good
time
and
there's many people there so they're
enjoying the chess
always a bright day in madrid and it's
good to see so many fans coming not just
to the venue but getting their games in
it absolutely is i believe that was
grand master david anton guihara but
don't quote me on that great to see the
atmosphere inside the palacio de
centronia but it's also great to see
that the atmosphere outside the palacio
is also filled with chess
and filled with the beauty of madrid
and how lucky are those actually who got
the tickets for the candidates
tournaments because every day it's like
we are sitting here and doing the
commentary but every day outside the
plaza de san antonio there like a group
of 20 30 people uh watching the games
live you know on their phones discussing
like for six seven hours and waiting for
the players after the game they
and so players are signing autographs
but this is an absolutely amazing scene
it certainly is and just to reset here
international master amira skripchenko
grand master daniel nardiski i'm
grandmaster robert hess and it is a
great scene here in madrid but we all
when we're all we're looking at right
now in addition to teamwork of on screen
is jan napomnishi he's sitting in clear
first place he is the happiest man in
the canada's tournament and the players
they're trying to catch up but it's been
all yawn from the very start and jan is
keeping a very close eye on timurujaba's
position
we said the word pretty plenty of times
one thing that isn't pretty is dingley
wren's position
wow it's over on your top right dingley
run with 51 minutes but more importantly
he's got that king on f2 his position is
in shambles no control over the light
squares and timur jabov's position is
bustling with activity it's like a
madrid market every part of the game
hustling and bustling with the two
bishops and that rook on v6 dingley wren
needs to pull a rabbit out of the hat
here i think he's sweating like he's
wiping his head he doesn't look very
comfortable right now at the board and
part of the discomfort is undoubtedly
because he has so many appealing moves
and when you are in a position and you
have seven different options that all
look equally good i mean if we just
started making move candidates bishop f5
very reasonable move attacking the queen
if we don't do that we talk about queen
b8 using the other
bishop to form a battery with the queen
while
putting pressure down the b file um
i mean so many moves look good here this
rook to c6 why not if we want to use a
queen of rook why not pin this knight so
there's so many options and he has just
played a move queen to b8 that is the
best one and for dingley wren still so
much to figure out as he scurries back
to the board
my lands this position is terrible what
is the purpose of a move by queen v8
those i think could be the hardest moves
to make but also the most instructive as
we pointed out previously it builds a
battery queen and bishop and you might
say and a queen a rook battery if the
knight on e2 ever moves there is the
devastating check on g3 there are also
rook sacrifices on e3 don't rule them
out because that queen after a bishop
check on c5 can dive into the attack via
the e5 or g3 squares you can show this
here bishop c5 and if knight d4
oh my god there's a bunch of winning
moves such as queen e5 check and
everything collapses here ding's
position
oh
i can't believe this i'm still wrapping
my head around the fact that ding has
this position with the white pieces in
20 moves
well he played a very long game
yesterday and timur jabba had well
quite an easy and a short draw
so
maybe ding is exhausted right now
he is going to be even more exhausted
and he thankfully gets the rest day
tomorrow but if in this position his
best move is like bishop c1 just to make
sure that you can defend this pawn here
that shows how sad this is and i i think
though that we shouldn't make this sound
like a foregone conclusion because it's
very far from it
black is up no material black doesn't
have any checkmating threats there's not
a pawn that's immediately going to be
won so
it still is very appealing for black but
you have so many different good-looking
moves and as we see this coming here
ding has turned bad games around before
like yesterday and i remember a game
that he played against vishyananda in
the sink filled cup a couple of years
ago i think that game really stands out
for me because at one point it was like
minus five or something but vichy had to
find an accurate sacrifice at one point
he didn't find it he was still much
better but then turned that game around
and actually won it so he has a track
record of resilient defense you can tell
that rajab is nervous he senses that
he's very close to scoring
and i don't think it would be an
exaggeration to call this
you know one of the most impressive
victories of his career to beat a
dingley red who's won three games in a
row rajab also defeated gary kasparov
with the black pieces in 2003 so that
probably takes the cake
but he's gonna have to keep his
composure and keep finding powerhouse
moves like queen b8 if he wants to
supersede what i'm positive is going to
be a very dogged resistance by the
chinese grand master
well brooke iii is a very concrete
threat
so bishop c1 is the only move why can't
we play um something else
name a move
knight d1 maybe
that's sad i mean it does protect the
immediate threat but then this rook says
you've stopped that let's go over to c8
and there's where's this queen going
bishop c3 if i had to predict a move i
would so at the very least now black can
turn
a good position into materially a head
position so i can just snag your a3 pawn
be happy about that and
i don't know dingley wren he might try
to hold on to everything or if he
senses he can get some activity he will
give up material but this looks really
really bad but on the other hand
black just played i mean queen b8 but
before
rookie
psychologically are you ready to play
vk8 then rook c8
that's a good point i didn't think of it
that way but i think if the knight moves
from c3
it
it it's quite obvious that like the c
file opens up so i think that increases
the likelihood that timur plays rook c8
because it hits the queen
and the queen just doesn't have squares
and this position is really difficult
and you know i mentioned it's bishop c1
move it's not like this solves all of
white's problems still rook c8 looks
reasonable
um
but
yeah there's no clear breakthrough and
that's always frustrating when you know
you're better and dingleran also knows
that java is better but you don't find a
way to
crash through like yan chistov duda is
doing in his game because while this one
is very favorable for teamwork of we see
in the bottom left-hand side of our
screens yan chistov duda plays the move
f4 we are clamoring for it he goes with
it it earned him a victory over five
minute carwana and it could very well do
the same in this game against alireza
frugia
yeah and as duda returns to the board he
will play g takes f4 immediately
upon recording ali reza's capture it
surprises me a little bit that he took i
want to say about 20 minutes on app four
on the other hand that is a move that
there's no going back from right you're
pushing upon on the king's side changing
completely the nature of the position so
it was worth double and triple checking
some of the key lines but
we've said this many times this
tournament ali reza is in trouble once
again do you think he missed f4 because
he played g5 to stop f4 and the move
happens anyway and then you start
thinking after the move is played and
yes dude has spent a lot of time but if
we look at alireza he hasn't made a move
yet which really leads me to believe
that he
thought he had stopped f4
well on the other hand this is the most
principled continuation in this position
so when you make such a committal move
as g5
you have to be sure that everything
works after f4
so what could he possibly miss on this
line is this the maneuver queen g2 queen
f3
which controls all the squares there's
also bishop d4 check here which we
haven't pointed out a very creative
tactical idea we'll analyze that because
that is a peace sacrifice at least
temporarily with bishop d4 if the rook
takes on d4 give me that free piece
there's queen b6 and normally this queen
could just
go into the diagonal protect the rook
stop the pin but the queen is needed to
stop this pawn push and every other move
runs into things like rook to d8 so
you can't protect the rook and keep the
b-pawn stopped in place they're not
forced to take exactly
that's that's that's right why you can
play king h2 for example no you know
you're not forced you should not take it
king h2
next move e5 and
it seems like white's pieces are coming
right into the attack
and we should point out that white can
sack the exchange back in certain
positions so for example black plays c5
because the bishop is now hanging
e5
and this reveals why you should keep the
king on h2 and not on h1 e5 opens the
long diagonal so you want to eliminate
the possibility of a queen check and
after the knight moves back
you could very well consider the move
rook f1 to g1 check nope scratch that
earlier as it takes the pawn on f4 oh
goodness i could see this game ending in
the next 10 moves and it's only moved 24
while there is a plenty of time on his
clock but we know for a fact this
position is good for yon chistop he
missed that four i think it just you
make the move g5 to stop it and then
it's a cold shower when your opponent
plays it anyway and yanchezuf
confidently walks back to the board he's
going to take black's best piece that
pawn on b2 and he's up material
alirez is in free fall
right now in complete free fall
because the move c6 c5 to establish the
d4 square to me that was a given that he
would play that f4 is the threat you
can't prevent it
so
you know you have to adapt to it
and
the fact that he missed that f4 i mean
it it is shocking to me it just seems to
keep getting worse and worse
for uh for for
ali reza
and he has no attack against the white
king so white's going to have
all the fun here and
almira the players they always try to be
objective and after queen takes b2 i'm
sure
alireza thinks he has some chances to
hold but would you be surprised if you
could get into his head if he thought he
was already lost
well i would certainly be surprised
because uh
i think that he
he was counting on this idea of playing
knight h5 and knight g3 and then
it seems very logical so king h8 rock g8
and you have the control over the
dark square
okay
cases i wanted to say dark squares
the
the french again
so um how do you say the word in french
it's square yes yeah cassia in spanish
so it's similar
hopefully
[Music]
but yeah can't get all of it right
that's the big problem right once the
queen takes on b2 you're already forcing
some action here because uh
this knight's under attack this bishop
is threatened and we're solving that all
at once by bringing the bishop to e5 but
with the open f file
white's rook is so happy the queen joins
the party and
yeah
and oh my god wow we have to go the game
i mean we're excited with this one but
the game between team over java and
dingley wren i predicted a win for
dingley ren with the white pieces but
after his move queen to c1 he is
overlooked three oh my god we'll bring
this up we'll bring this up with the
analysis board here that the rook takes
e3 is a shot that dingley wren has just
missed and we were talking about it in a
different variation here it still works
we'll show you why rook takes e3 you
have to take otherwise you've given away
a free pawn but after king takes e3 this
king is out in the open so bishop c5
check it's the same exact variation
knight d4 and queen comes to e5 and
white's position falls apart completely
here as if you run your king back thank
you for this one where's your king going
king f1 there's even knight h5 knight g3
we're just talking about that idea in
the other game here's knight h5 here's
knight g3 it's swiss cheese on the king
side
this is shocking stunning
unbelievable choose
your adjective or jabba is going to find
rook takes c3 he looked over at the
camera there i feel like he's thinking
to himself is this really happening is
this too good to be true am i miss
evaluating this
and the answer to all those questions is
no he's got
almost an hour on his clock to calculate
a forced variation
insane
insane and i think everyone cast team
over job aside in this tournament they
said no way he can contend he's going to
finish on last place hasn't been winning
classical games his rating the live
rating was the lowest in the field but
we know what team over job was capable
of he has now become a very solid player
but from a very early age as a teenager
when he became a grandmaster he had the
style where he could sacrifice pieces
left and right played the most
ambitious but risky openings and he beat
gary kasparov with the black pieces he's
beaten many
of the luminary chests with the black
pieces and dingley ren might just be his
next victim robert i was thinking after
rookie three
can we play knight d5
i guess knight takes d5 and rock takes
e2 check yes exactly so if you take back
rook takes e2 check because amira's
point is that if you first take the
bishop on b2 this queen takes the other
one although even that's winning with
bishop g3
oh my god oh even this is winning yeah
but let's just show the more natural
variation rook takes e2 so i was going
to lose this rook i take your knight you
take back i take a second minor piece
and your king's not really going
anywhere it's going to get checkmated so
it goes to the first rank there's always
rook to b1 things like that the king has
to go up well that's terrible and after
rook two d2 here we can bring more
pieces into the tag bishop b5 check
check here check there check everywhere
and white's king is being hunted down
i think a point that isn't made often
enough
is that where java is actually a very
unpleasant opponent for all of the
players in this field because
you know accurate or not people are
expecting
the the participants to defeat or jabba
with white and i think very unreasonably
so because timur is perhaps the most
solid player in this field
and when there is that additional
expectation coupled with the fact that
ding has won three in a row people are
voting for him too and he's aware of
that pressure obviously that creates
additional anxiety on top of the
anxiety that comes from needing to win
based on the tournament standings and
that is a very powerful force
and what else is a very powerful force
is rook takes e3 which is on the board
no hesitation
a huge moment there by team over jabba
he rested his head for a moment but he
is not going to rest on this position he
goes rook takes e3 he steals that pawn
and for dingley ren when he gets back to
the board sees it he is not going to be
happy i just found it in another crazy
line rookie one in this position
rookie one justin bishop c5 okay we'll
spring up an analysis board
king f1 bishop c5 king of one rook takes
f3 and you have a bowden's mate on top
of everything else this would be made
without the rook the queen and the
knight
you can believe that that is a gorgeous
checkmate this is why you study your
checkmate patterns because when happens
in your game you have the opportunity
you don't want to lose it
this is just crazy oh mirror can you
believe this
well first of all this made this very
beautiful and what i i was thinking that
it's also
um
very easy to play uh with black in this
situation like i'm
not looking at the position because
uh
psychologically he is fine with the draw
so he knows that uh ding will
overpush it at some moment
and uh
that's what happened today oh and you
could see dingley around he knows what
just happened he is not the happy ding
we've seen over the last three rounds
rook takes e3
and his winning streak is about to come
to an end
and just what a shot by teamwork java
and
the points that we're making about you
know you can't
try too hard to win you need to keep
your objectivity otherwise you're
just playing into your opponent's hands
we keep talking about dingley run is
like fabiano caruana usually is
the most objective player and i don't
think that he was unobjective i honestly
think he just played well below his
standards today
he just played terribly i mean he really
you really did now this is not to take
anything away from tomorrow who played a
phenomenal game and found queen b8 and
found so many accurate moves but
really starting from bishop takes a6
ding
he completely lost control of the
position in a very very uncharacteristic
way and it may go to show that teamwork
java's preparation throughout this event
while it didn't work oh and look at dink
i mean he knows it's over he sees the
end
he knows that rijaba found a vicious
tactic that will only end in ding's
defeat uh but for dingley reno you win
three games in a row you don't expect to
have this happen to you like this and
rajabov i mean he just has played an
excellent game where ding never quite
felt comfortable
can we play with get one
king
here actually i could see him resigning
king c5 i cannot i cannot play knight d4
everything is hanging in this position
yeah everything and he's going to try
and you know find a solution
where one doesn't exist so
yeah rook takes e3 what a move to have
him played against you and timor rajava
is going to make hikaru nakamura happy
because nakamura drew his game very
quickly
i don't think he could have expected
before the round began that dingley ren
would lose with white
but now that means that karu and ding
will be tied in second and for yon
napomnishi
nobody can score more points than he can
once dingley ren loses this game he is
eight and a half both ding and hikara
will have six and a half two games
remain a single draw
locks up first place for you on yonder
paw machine and ding any car playing in
the last round so
as you said a single draw
locks it up and if either ding
or hikaru um i mean
draw the next round then the tournament
is over so
there's still a mathematical chance that
jan is cut but that will require
a world-ending turn of events
and
we
we forgot about fabiano's game you know
because he is back in the race yes he is
i mean fabiano on the top left over here
it's a knight versus the bishop the pawn
structure features doubled pawns in the
b file for both players and we have seen
a trade on the f file
white's pawn is gone black's e5 pawn is
gone uh but it's anybody's game in that
one it just has been such a mesmerizing
show with both yan chistop duda with the
white pieces and now team over job with
the black pieces the way those games
have gone have stolen our attention but
we of course cannot forget about fabiano
caruana zamiro said now he has a chance
to tie for second if he can defeat
richard rapport with the black pieces
although that game being in your top
left
it feels to me increasingly unlikely
that fabby's going to win i think ever
since he missed the opportunity to
preserve
his dark square bishop the position has
simplified
and uh we don't have to
delve too deeply into the game although
we can and
i feel like richard richard's position
has improved tremendously over the last
five or six moves oh mirrors f4 has been
played there's pressure down the f-file
at any point you can take on g6 to open
up the h file and the knight on e6 well
it's still stationed there and it's fine
it's not creating any threats and
already there's certain threats for
from white's perspective that cause
fabiano some concern
well i have another idea once again
can fabi play
something like first of all he protects
the sixth spawn maybe rook and then a5
a4
so you want to play rook hf8 or
hf-8 probably
yeah i mean white also has to find a
move here
the the most tempting move to me is
bishop f4 to h6 chasing the rook away
once again and softening up the f61
would then work off e8 and you could
argue the bishop on h6 is quite awkward
i think the pressure on the f file will
persist
and that could be an issue so what are
the f5 he went f5
he is trying to get rid of the f6
weakness by pushing it to f5 and if we
see a trade of pawns on f5 after g takes
back where is this queen going this
knight is happily going to hop into d4
or rook's going to come to e8 and let's
not forget that this pawn on h5 if
you're unable to take on g6 that could
be a long-term target an overextended
pawn that black could go after
yeah well the knight will jump on d4 and
then maybe if we can use the idea of
playing a5 and a4 queen a2
ah almira is going for the attack over
here well i'm ready to sacrifice it all
well that's smelling blood as a
commentator i say i always enjoy
sacrificing other people's pieces so i'm
with you
so as a conclu as a result of this i
think richard might do well not to take
on f5 and to drop the queen back to h3 f
takes c4 is
ill-advised not to the bishop e5 would
do the bishop b8 check it's kind of a
cool discovery just like we were saying
before when there are pieces in line
with each other think about what happens
when the piece in between goes out the
way and bishop e5 would win the rook in
the corner but why win a rook for a
bishop when you can win a queen for a
bishop that sounds like a much better
decision so
you're right f takes e4 not possible
maybe black can play knight to d4 or
bring the rook towards the center
because already white has a big threat
if black makes some random move h6 g6
this looks like a trade that i don't
think black really wants even if the
material
uh imbalance is even according to the
evaluation it doesn't look that pleasant
to play from black side
i think a draw is actually very likely
in this game black can take the bishop
on f4 and we shouldn't
overlook that option after in the live
position after queen h3 in in our
analysis after f5 queen h3
knight takes f4 rook takes f4 and
there's this very weird looking with
rook hg8
the point is to indirectly defend the f5
pawn if let's say white takes on g6 and
then takes on f5 black takes back
and uh i guess after rook takes f5 you
just play a move like queen e7 or queen
g7 and
you have full compensation because
white's king as elmira has been pointing
out is very vulnerable black has
excellent heavy pieces and as you're
pointing at robert it's only a matter of
time before that pawn on g3 is
surrounded
and one back so
if i had to predict a result here i
think
we might see a liquidation
pretty quickly
but fabiano wants to avoid that right
he's been playing for wins it seems like
in every single game so he could
liquidate or he could take a bit of a
risk and try and play on it may cost him
another
game but he does need to catch up to
ding and hikaru in second place well do
you think he had the look at that game
he knows what's going on in digloren's
game oh yes he's definitely going to be
walking around checking out the
positions and looking at dingley ren's
game and when you see rook takes e3 in
that one dangler and hasn't moved all
the players can just look calculate and
be like all right dingley ren his
winning streak has come to a close
yeah there's not much to say not much
left to say in his game as he continues
in vain to look for a way to prolong the
game you can see the despondency the
desperation written all over his face
you can't help but feel some sympathy
for dang his hopes dashed in a very
cruel way by two more job of in this
game and rejava of his dash hikaru
nakamura's hopes as well early in the
tournament so hikara was looking to
pounce on timor java vajab said nope
here in this game dingley ren just
couldn't really get out of the opening
stage of this game and what move number
is it i don't think i've ever seen
dingley wren be lost with white in 21
moves that just
that seems unfathomable
i don't know if that's ever happened
since he hit twenty seven hundred well
against yandeep nishi in the first round
first of all he almost never loses with
white yep this is
this result is absolutely exceptional
and it has like some of the
characteristics of that game yeah
it definitely does although i think in
that game
he played better in the opening i think
what's often overlooked about the first
round is that i think ding had a slight
advantage at some point
and he just totally underestimated yan's
plan which was to build up the kingside
attack right here
it's almost like he never had a chance
it's like from the moment he played b4
and
he carver really helped me understand
this in his interview black's position
was just so much easier to play i mean
he was never really
in the game he never got the car started
and i think we're all
you know saying this because of how much
respect we have for dingley wren but if
you showed somebody this notation the
score sheet and remove the player's
names and ratings you would not think
black's a 2800 uh white excuse me uh
dingley wren is a 2800 you would think
that it was maybe a grand master playing
against a low-rated person and just
shows that dingley ran
something about today's game you know
caught him off guard the 96 move perhaps
but
three long games even though there's a
rest day in between the first win and
the second two maybe he's exhausted but
you know we did have an interview with
him dina
bella caught up with him he talked about
his game against fabiano and what he's
looking for in terms of second place so
let's remind everybody of that video
because second place is very important
ding three wins in a row how does it
feel
of course they are very lucky
i was in defensive
defense mode
entire game
but
in time trouble he blunders
the position very badly so today is very
lucky
it all started with a very deep line
analyzed by computers apparently was
knight g7 uh in your preparation
uh yeah i briefly checked this line
knight g7 look f8 knight h knight five
rook eight it's equal but he played
three so i was more or less on my own
and after 96 here i have so many choices
here i believe my position won't be
worse but i don't know where i went
wrong the position seems very unpleasant
for me
he played very well after 96 i think
yeah apparently there was this moment to
play b4 that fabi didn't use and then
bishop g5 in the time travel that was
giving a uh perpetual did you see that
one
when i take home e8 bishop g5 sacrificed
the bishop and
yes you want queen you have fg5 queen
seven king j8 queen g5 and he might
exchange the queens at some point on h3
yeah i was worried about bishop g5 since
i
i didn't find a
clear win but also no clear draw for him
so he didn't go for this
sacrifice after
24 i think my positions
i should be winning
slowly
so was that moment when you sensed the
blood that the wind was coming to you oh
well i think the moment he missed queen
d3
he had to defend after that and also i
have much more time
also more present position so at that
point
yeah
i smelled blood
you are now in a clear fight for the
second place uh maybe even for the first
who knows
we were wondering uh in case there are
several players tied for seconds
what do you think
would be the perfect tiebreaker
if more than one player then might be a
rapid
round-robin
tournament for
if three or four players
well dingly wren said that maybe a rapid
round robin if they're three or so
players
if he does in fact resign this game
hikar nakamura will join him and fabiano
carwana looks to do the same so that's
the big story line magnus carlsen here
in madrid if he doesn't play that world
championship match which looks all but
guaranteed to be against yon napomshi
than one of dingley wren five-minute
karwana or hikara nakamura will have the
right to play against yana palmashi
robert but how long will it take if four
players will die for the second place
and they will agree uh well to play in a
tie break oh you i forgot what team or
job of he's about to if when this game
includes he'll have six points and be a
half point behind the other so how long
will it take i think that the players
they don't mind if it takes a while but
they always want it to be settled over
the chessboard because when you play the
same opponents you're all playing each
other twice with white and black having
a slightly better tiebreaker i don't
think it's just it's really important to
the players right i
feel like they hardly even know what it
means half the time when i played in
chess terms i never looked at the tie
breaks and was like how did they
calculate this i want to learn the math
behind it you're just like all right i
guess i'm a little bit behind right
tie breaks are necessary to a degree you
know when you have a big open tournament
it's impractical to always have a
playoff especially when you're talking
about you know
tied a tie for fifth or sixth place so
they're necessary but i agree that
they're impure and i think the
fundamental assumption you make in the
candidates is that you know
everybody has an equally difficult
tournament that's literally the
definition of a round robin so a tie
breaking around robin just kind of feels
weird and i'm really really happy that
this discussion is happening
but
i'm still processing what's going on in
the tomb raider java game we haven't
talked about rajabov too much in this
tournament the fact that he's on 50
right now and rearing to go and he's
beaten two incredibly strong players
he's had an incredible performance and i
think we can't overlook that yes and
what you were saying is true about in
the round robin or especially double
round robin in particular when you're
playing a swiss tournament you play
different levels of opposition some
people have a harder schedule and they
should be rewarded for that with the tie
breaks but when you play the same exact
cast of characters there is something
that feels wrong about concluding with
some numbers after the score rather than
playing it out of the board
and if we
look at the board can we at least find
uh a possible continuation for white
what happens after knight d4 here he
simply retreats his work or there is a
tactical solution
after this one i think there is a tactic
amir and i were talking about this
during the interview bishop g3 check i
think is still incredibly powerful
forcing
king takes e3 now the bishop steps back
to f4
look at that b-2 bishop i mentioned
earlier the battery the queen is the
hero of this position it's responsible
for both batteries after the king moves
and the bishop captures the rook the
white bishop on b2 is going to be
captured by the black rook with totally
devastating effect oh yep that's the
move drop the rook once short rook takes
b2 on the other hand is a problem the
knight would have to block so the queen
isn't lost but then here there are many
many winning moves you can put the
bishop on f5 you can deliver a check
over here
it's just a hopeless position for white
with the weak king and problems
everywhere
crazy and
we're getting word that the last time
ding has lost a game
and under 30 moves with white was in
2015
that's seven years ago against indian
gmsp set to raman
he has made a move and it's 91
and that probably is the best that he
can do here
but even the simpler rookie eight
it preserves a totally winning advantage
we were looking at some uh
what was the line we were calculating
here after knight d1 oh we look at
knight takes d5 before but knight d1 i
don't think we mentioned it's a sad
retreating move just to get the rook out
of here you can bring your rook right
back and then bring this rook over to c8
bishop coming to c5 all this kind of
stuff
oh gosh dingley wren's pieces are not
coordinated and i wouldn't be surprised
if you could just take on e2 oh the
evaluation part didn't change so that's
good news and if you take with the king
i bring this bishop into the action your
king has to go to a dark square let's
say f2 here comes this bishop your king
has to run over here to g1 and i'm one
move away from checkmate either with the
rook or with the queen coming so
yeah this looks
really really really bad but
this situation is one where you don't
just want to assume that your winning is
black because you give up some material
to get the attack so you would have to
calculate to it
to its conclusion and i think teamwork
with java is very capable of doing just
that
forked sure
you know i think tomorrow we
overestimate but timur is a very dynamic
player
he had to change his opening repertoire
from the king's indian to the queen's
gambit but nevertheless he feels this
position
these types of positions very well
yeah
i think that's a great point i think
talking about tigran petrossian world
champion
a lot of people had this very myopic
view of him as a purely positional
player without realizing that under the
surface of his openings
lay
an incredibly powerful calculator and
tactical player you can't have the kind
of style that rojoba has and survive at
the very top level without also having
the ability to survive and thrive
in these complex tactical positions and
the speed with which he's made some of
these moves
including rook takes e3
is a foolproof indicator of that and his
childhood openings undoubtedly help
where he was
playing every game as if it were his
last super sharp battles trying to win
no matter if he had white black or blue
he was just going for it every single
game and he has to be criticized for his
more frequent uh
chess like the more recent chess i
should say his style has become more
solid he plays very quiet lines even
yesterday against youngstow duda with
the white pieces it seemed like you know
he played for the smallest of advantages
got nothing made a draw but when it
boils down to what he truly loves as a
chess player it's games like this and
not just because he's winning in 20
something moves the black but because
it's really suits him this kind of
free-for-all where he can have his
pieces going everywhere across the board
i was looking for some lines like cookie
bishop
you're still hoping that ding can find
something no i i mean rookie
rookie seven sure i'll put it there you
move your bishop there's always rook to
b1 coming and knight h5 let's not forget
about that idea forgetting about knight
h5 rugby one queen c3 is it com i mean
is it completely lost
knight h5 looks unlike h5 here give me
that square
it's lost on all sides of the board too
center queens had king side white
doesn't have a single move
yeah this is
not what you like to see here if you're
a dingley rent fan and we know he has so
many he is the number two rated player
in the world number one rated player
from china and there have been so many
eyeballs from china watching him play in
this tournament but it's not his day
after three consecutive victories so we
see alireza fruga on screen here we will
bring up his game against yon chistov
duda because jan chistov he did a rook
lift as we see in the bottom left-hand
side of the screen all the raises on the
clock and this is
oh my gosh another game for ali raza
that's out of hand
the last couple moves were knight h5
getting it out of a threat right the
queen was attacking the knight over here
and then rook d but this is just so
superficial by by ali reza i mean he's
making moves that's set one move threats
in that case bishop e3 check
dude is preventing them and then
you know alireza doesn't know what to do
well but he's deviating from our
analysis which was bishop b5 green g2
and look at king hate queen f3 so he uh
probably
understood that this position is
completely lost so he's trying to find
some
practical chances in this game yeah and
he would love to get his knight in but
unfortunately knight g3 it falls victim
to this queen just coming over to g2 you
can't take the rook on f1 because of the
pin and if you get out of the pin i take
your bishop you take my rook and then
your knight is captured with rook takes
you important not to play queen takes g3
because queen takes you three runs into
rook to g8 you lose the game on the spot
so take with the rook on g3 instead and
that way you are up a bishop you have
all the firepower aiming on the g file
and black might as well resign here so
quincy one and bishop f1
yeah
good to finish the variation queen f1
and bishop f1 the point is that this
bishop
returns to safety and now white really
is up a piece without any risk no
tactical ideas for black
oh my gosh rook d3 what a calm move but
with such purpose
but you know professional players
they're defined in many ways by their
response
to adversity and i'm
very curious to see how alireza and
we'll talk more about this toward the
final round of the tournament how will
he respond to this very disappointing
performance how will he approach the
games how will he play in his next
tournament
and um
it's just incredibly hard when your
worst tournament also happens to be the
candidates where all of your opponents
are the strongest players in the world
it's not like an open tournament where
you have a disappointing game and you
drop down and you play someone more
beatable in the next round with every
loss it's like alireza's next opponent
only gets harder
this is devastating to watch what i
wanted to say and we discussed this in
the earlier rounds
could it provoke the same kind of
reaction um as like
after fishers candidates that he took a
retreat from chess like for like i think
it lasted several years he didn't play
any competitive chess
but aleriza hasn't played before this
tournament right yeah so i feel like
what do you think he's going to do
robert do you think a break another
break is called for
what is the proper way to respond to
this after 14 grueling rounds not to
mention all the preparation that goes in
you're exhausted so a break seems
necessary but many of these players will
take part in the olympiad coming up soon
so i don't know if oli reza is playing i
think he is not but
yeah you don't have much of a break
because there's so many events
yeah i mean i think
a break a short break is called for to
all of the players see caro mentioned
that one of the big reasons he's not
playing the olympia is because of the
grueling nature of the candidates
but
it is incredibly hard to analyze the
games objectively because when you look
through the games after the tournament
you relive some of the pain
of the losses so it's very tempting to
just say i'm going to forget these turn
this tournament ever happened i'm gonna
throw away the score sheets
but that's not what a serious
professional has to do a serious
professional has to use these games as
invaluable data points
that allow him to move forward and avoid
these tournaments in the future
and alireza's here just looking for any
move at the moment he's not finding one
and we should go digly wren's game
because he
played that move knight to d1 rook back
to e8 and then knight to e3 and i
wouldn't be surprised if this could just
take this knight considering it took a
pawn here but the simple knight h5
should be good enough
yeah knight h5 threatens bishop g3 so
after knight h5
i suppose knight f1
okay we'll analyze this position as
dangly wren is on the clock knight h5
knight f1
just to cover the square now the amazing
thing is that as i said rajab is winning
on all the flanks so now bishop d7 to b5
striking at the other side and
threatening bishop takes c2 and bishop
g3 check
and at some point ding is just gonna
think he's gonna decide that he's had
enough
you're saying it's bad that this rook is
on h1 and can't participate no it's a
great
yeah ding's position is amazing here
my goodness and her job yeah maybe can
we bring this rook into play like hook
hd1
afternoon after knight h5
and i guess
bishop g3 check here you have to be a
little bit careful
because let's go down that line bishop
g3 check
knight takes g3 force queen takes g3
check
the king is as safe as it's been this is
the entire game on g1 you can almost
pretend that you've castled as for rooks
c3
you need to find a response to rook
takes d5 because amir there's a
oh there's a vicious trap here black
quote-unquote falls into the trap with
knight f4 there's this move queen ca
check all of a sudden looks like you've
blundered checkmate because bishop takes
c8 walks into maid but
there is the cold-blooded bishop e8 or
probably even better is to play rookie 8
and white's counter play has been
exhausted
this looks totally one-sided and totally
winning
i think ding might resign after night h5
uh we
we have no possibility of playing king
of wonder because bishop b5 yes after
knight like rook d1 major three yeah
rook hd1
bishop g3
uh king f1 here yes
yeah there bishop b5 i really like you
don't even have to rush
to take this knight on e3 because that
creates the additional threat of knight
f4
and i guess the one other thing to
mention here
you could try rook e1
in order to be able to defend the knight
on e3 after bishop g3 check but if you
go down this line even with the knight
defended i think knight f4 is totally
devastating so take takes
now king g1
and just look at this position knight
takes h3
brook g6
what isn't a threat here
not much to say
oh it's an absolute triumph of black
pieces
it's just crazy
it's crazy that this is a position that
you have in the candidates
and
honestly
you know i was thinking about this
during the break
bishop takes a6 was the first surprise
but this move b4
would you agree with miami that that's
where all of the trouble seemed to start
because that allowed black to rip open
the queen side with a5 that gave rajabov
a very easy plan
well let's uh let's go back to the
position before
[Music]
b4
here
and what was called for here i mean even
just castling i think after castling we
would have been talking about a very
different game
i i mean rook d1 knight g3 at least
white's not going to get checkmated
yeah it's very true right you can play
against the isolated deep on and i think
b4 allowed black such an easy game
that's what hikara was saying he was
surprised by what happened because as
soon as you push the pawns forward
it's easier to counter
and so when rajab played a5 and a6 and
open the position up bishops thrive in
open space so this could have been more
of a closed position and the knights
would have had a say
absolutely and after before things
continue to go downhill notice how
tomorrow he's taking his time he's not
rushing it i think he sees knight h5
as he's nervously fidgeting with that
pawn he knows how close he is to scoring
one of the biggest wins in this
tournament and paving jan napomnishi's
path to first place but also potentially
his own improbable path to a tie for
second that's the pawn he just stole on
e3 behind me
oh man the irony of that the cruel irony
of that do you think ding realizes that
well you know the pieces have little
magnets underneath them right so i don't
think there's a way for us to verify it
but he did just take that pawn so why
not keep hold of it and he's having a
good time right a lot of players do that
knight h5 and then knight d5 one last
try
amira is still trying to find a
variation that saves dingley running
that's what dingle iron has to do is say
let's find something that maybe at least
makes this complicated and after knight
takes i think we can just play bishop
ge6 and bishop b5 and
oh goodness entire avalanche files up on
that night
oh no
knight f4
queen wherever we got every single piece
is attacking that knight on e2
it's just so hopeless this rook on h1
never got into the game
white's pieces not coordinated as well
as they should be and black with the
only light square bishop on the board is
about to use it's a great effect
so that's when you start negotiating
with some higher powers
right
start praying for a uh over the word
mouse slip of some sort
i don't think there even is a move here
that gives up the entire advantage i
mean it's pretty hard to find one
oh and you can in addition to knight h5
which looks great you can bring this
rook into the attack and put pressure on
this net in e3 if the knight goes
well then that opens the e file for a
future bishop b5 and black's pieces
still come to life and if you try to
defend everything by keeping your pieces
compact and close together
i'll bring my bishop to the party
pinning your knight knight can't move
without losing the rook if you take that
bishop in comes my queen in comes my
knight to e4 this knight on e3 is
already under attack by three of black's
pieces
uh you can't survive this
yeah this game is two or three moves
away from its conclusion
wow what a day i
i
did my predictions at the start of the
show and i said that dingley ren would
get his fourth win in a row and
i just can't believe not the fact that
he
is going to lose the game because timor
java can beat anybody with any color but
the way it's happening you would never
expect this to happen to dingley ren of
all players
no
that's all you can say no
i mean literally everybody voted for
a win and i mean 95 percent voted for
either a winner or a draw and timor
jabba makes his choice and it is indeed
rook b3 and the death knell it is
sounding and it is sounding loudly and
he looks up a dingly run with violence
on his mind and in his eyes and the
knight on e3 is hanging
and the game is over
wow wow wow timor rajabov i mean this
goes to show that no matter what the
expectations were coming into the event
every player will do their part to shake
up the standings and for dingley wren
it's not
the face of somebody who is happy
doesn't look like the face of the player
we saw the last few rounds and he made
his knight move it looks like to g4 so
he is
hoping that trading some pieces will
mean that his king is safer but i don't
believe
after his knight ventures out to g4 that
the attack stops i think it actually
just rages on knight takes g4 check and
then again bishop d7
jumps out to b5
and the combination of the pressure on
e2 with the pressure on g3 is what
destroys white here knight d4 never
works
owing to
bishop g3 check and you don't even need
to rush rookie one check you can play
with be3 if you so desire
or rook takes b2 literally
anything on earth oh what about rook
takes b2 and queen f4
oh my how's that queen d1 queen takes d4
well i'll just show that you can't trade
queens because black will not recapture
and say will deliver check and mate the
bishop takes away the escape squares so
if you don't trade queens and play queen
to d1 okay queen e3 check leads to mate
but queen takes d4 is far nicer because
if you take the queen you have the same
problem with rook e1 mate that's
a beautiful tactic
it is one-sided it is easy
and it is over let's do more grab some
more coffee plenty of time on his clock
shall we have a look at the developments
in
one of the other two games
we haven't looked at five you know car
one is rich report and you usually
expect report to be the one with you
know playing some hectic moves but he
chose a very solid approach for the
second day in a row and uh in the top
left there
the clock is what's catching my eye most
because they play 25 moves they have 27
minutes for report 35 for carwana but
just feels like the struggle
is so tense that
their next bunch of moves just take a
lot of time
oh and just look at richard there was a
moment where he was talking to himself
he was calculating a variation and like
i was trying to figure out
uh what's going on
yeah because he's got to decide whether
he releases the tension
he can release the tension in several
different ways or he can keep the status
quo and keep everything hanging i mean
you could move the bishop away from f4
and the temptation of that move is that
it opens up the contact the x-ray
between the rook and the queen but
going back to what i said earlier i
think there's still a very high
probability that you get some sort of
mass liquidation on the queen side and
if all of the pawns disappear
despite the asymmetry of
the pawn structures on the other side of
the board
it's basically even and there's also a
chance that the knight is traded for the
bishop so richard he's looking for a way
to spice things up but he doesn't have
too much longer look he's got 25 minutes
and i agree i think he needs to factor
in the clock and move pretty fast
because we know what happens even in a
risk-free position when you take too
long just ask fabi what happened to him
yesterday i think the clock played a big
role in that meltdown he had near the
time control on move 60. yeah and
richard continues to spend time here he
probably doesn't want to draw so you're
saying that many of these positions once
trades happen it looks pretty level i'm
sure richard he's looking at this
because his rook on f1
is on an open line his queen and rook on
the h-file is on the line that's about
to open and the rook on d8 isn't quite
as strong that rook is staring into a
brick wall a protected pawn on d3 so
if we go from piece to piece the
rook queen situation seems to be pretty
good for white but this knight on e6 i
mean that's been such a good piece all
game and it remains a good piece so i
feel like
without a clear target it's going to be
hard for him to make any inroads
and he's about to make a move and what
if he plays bishop h6 and g4 where this
doesn't work
there might be f4
f4 that's the flow of this move yeah
that's the the fly in the ointment
because
the threat of g5 forces white to
i guess give up the g pawn otherwise
that would be a really interesting idea
yeah the bishop gets trapped over here
that is unfortunate but your idea is a
good one right you're just trying to
use the pin to your advantage and say
that you can't uh move your pawn f5 or
let's just do this with his hands there
maybe he can play bishop h6
rook f7 then retrieve the bishop and
keep this idea
all right go for g4 next certainly
and
oh my gosh it looks like yanchez of duda
he made a big mistake and we have him
back on screen here and the position
went from
like nearly winning for him to equal
after his last move
rook f2 and it's not that clear-cut sure
the engine says something but his last
move was
rook f1 to f2 and that apparently is a
big error well quincy five was a threat
winning the bishop on c4
mm-hmm
yeah so
there was the move king h1 here
uh with the idea of taking the sting out
of queen c5 knight g3 we already know
the procedure it takes takes queen g2
but dude i wanted to combine two ideas
and he wanted to do it a little bit
differently that rook from f2
is threatening to migrate to g2 with
devastating effect but apparently
his move allows the bishop on f4 to drop
back to e5 and open up the f4 square for
the night and it appears he's allowed
black's minor pieces and queen to
produce a tremendous amount of counter
play here and i i see what the
evaluation bar says i understand that
black gets more play
but once again as we say every single
round this is not how players think
they're not like oh i was plus two and
now i'm plus point two that's not what's
going through mine so i don't think that
due to blunder i think that's a a bad
way of putting it in this particular
position he just wasn't precise and that
gives alareza a much better chance
because he gains access to the f4 square
for his knight as we've been talking
about and this queen can always go to c5
at some moment the dark squares are
blacks for the taking but black's king
does not remain sheltered so with
already on the clock after rook f2 he
has a new lease on life in this position
maybe he will stop the struggles in his
tournament but we will see when we
return here from the 12th round of
defeated candidates live from madrid
spain
this is going to be a real-time
breakdown of danny wrenches games all
time on chess.com uh that's cool
oh in the last month i am playing 83.12.
i'm less accurate than them in every
stage yeah and that that's things you
should okay do the more game review okay
thanks a lot okay so tuesday sucks i
gotta stop playing cats on twitter oh
it's because it's final tuesday
[Laughter]
look how many blunders there were back
in december 2020 and now december 2021
1600 don't look at this number
look at look at this number
best
let's go to
uh tactics
mates
you'll probably need to work on these
ones yep every single rook fork that has
presented itself to me i have found no
one has a higher percentage of rook
forks than i do
that's correct
these are literally the night forks that
you i missed knight d6 it you saw it
just now what is wrong with me
i could have done here and then taken
this pawn and i'm winning because my
pawns get held together that's probably
the coolest part about this feature like
these positions against pets
rook there for rookie two
and he plugged his maiden one
oh my goodness i'm awful
prior to round 11 ali reza faruja
decompressed before his game with the
tournament leader jan napomnishi by
playing hundreds of online hyper bullet
games
many of them against commentator daniel
naredicki who won their match
inevitably questions arose about ali
reza's preparedness for the game he
played the first novelty in a unique
line in the petrov knight to d4
after nepo's natural queen to b6 alireza
struggled to find a way to untangle his
queen side and he struck out first with
the dubious but playable g4 and then
with the extremely aggressive probably
overly aggressive h4
jan calmly sipped his tea
stared ali reza down and began targeting
his pieces towards ali reza's weaknesses
on move 21 nepo rapidly offered a piece
with knight takes f4 check and he
followed up a few moves later with the
beautiful hammer blows 24 bishop takes
g5 and 26 rook takes d4
though alireza defended stoutly after
his knight wandered into b7 nepo's
bishops and rook were able to turn their
attention to a vicious attack on the
king with either checkmate or
catastrophic material losses looming
alireza resigned
with 8 out of 11 which as chatters noted
is a score more typically seen entitled
tuesday than in the candidates nepo has
not yet mathematically clinched first
place but even his competitors are
starting to concede that he has
essentially locked up a victory
[Music]
this club is called amigos del retiro
friends of the retiro the retiro is
the most big and important park in
madrid it's a very important park in the
city because it's right in the center if
you want to play chess you don't know
the place this is a
maybe best one in madrid
punto
[Music]
[Music]
want to play chess online or learn how
to improve join us at the number one
chess destination in the world chess.com
with thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a grandmaster chess.com
makes learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we are back here in the 12th round
of the 2022 feed a candidate this is
chess.com coverage
excuse me i just swallowed and almost
lost my breath that's how great the
games have been but we did have dina
bella kaya catching up with yonda
palmishi talking about the tournament
and this was before dingley wren
struggled against timor java so we're
gonna watch that interview
let you all hear
yan's thoughts
kind of
expected it but still had some hope you
know for
for hikaru going for a fight and uh
yet he chose berlin do you think it was
the right choice uh
well it's hard to say so it's
i mean okay basically the ball was on
his side so
i mean obviously
one can try
few ideas against berlin but i guess
okay a lot of players here i mean
okay for example at least he current
team or they play berlin so
i mean surely
it could be played differently but in
general okay one second tournament
situation
probably screams that uh
so far i shouldn't like burn some
bridges
so i was like preparing for all kind of
i don't know
uh murky lines like i don't know maybe
some beer course some i don't know rare
spanish lines but uh
yeah i felt like okay if berlin then
okay then that's it and in general i
would say he shows like very nice level
of prep here with both colors so it's uh
i mean
i got i can't say that i was really into
you know refuting the berlin today right
and uh in general overlooking at all
your games here in uh the candidates in
madrid what do you think so far has been
the reason of your success
i don't know i'm just trying to keep you
know my head calm and uh not
you know
let you know
any emotions drive me so
trying to do my job more or less and
maybe that's
that could be the this could be the
difference with the players who like
play their first candidates but um
i mean it's
it's hard to judge yeah so once again
it's like we
like as spectators like we can see only
you know very very very few aspects and
a lot of
you know
a lot you know the bigger part of
iceberg is surely hidden here so that's
we don't really know what's happening in
every player's team
now the distress is uh slightly uh going
down any particular plans for tomorrow
rest day apart from lying in the bed
uh lying in the bed yeah so i mean okay
the tournament is uh nothing like over
yes so it's
still i have two games which could be
like extremely tense
and uh
i mean uh
so far once again so far it's good but i
mean it's
it's truly you know to give some
promises
thanks a lot jan thank you
we heard from yacht napashi about his
tournament thus far about his
decision-making and
how he feels going into the final two
rounds he's at eight and a half out of
twelve and if dingley wren goes on to
lose this game that means that yondu
palmishi can do no worse than a tie for
first
two point lead in the candidates that's
absolutely incredible no the eight is
not a typo the guy actually has
eight and a half points out of 12. i
think if we did that interview right now
and you ask him oh how stressed are you
do you know what do you do the rest day
he's gonna be like yeah no i feel really
good i'm up two points i just need one
more draw i'll go to the prado museum
and we see that ding lyren
has resigned he capitulates against team
rajabov the azeri player gets it his
second victory of the tournament and now
he's back up towards the top of
standings he'll be in fourth place at
minimum after this game i think
eventually can believe
that he won with black pieces so easily
against england and he is
back in the race for the second place
he certainly is and
wow what a way to upset dingley wren and
the tournament standings because before
the tournament started nobody predicted
that timor jabba could win the event i
think the most people thought he'd be at
the bottom but dania he has only lost
two games and now he's won two games so
he's right back in the swing of things
there were a lot of negative nancy's
before the tournament
uh you know and debbie downer saying but
timur is just there to make draws and
you know he's
uh he's just gonna slog through the
tournament and try to kill all the games
with white and that could not be further
from the truth yes timur has had some
short draws but even take yesterday's
game against duda he wasn't playing what
he was playing to make a quick draw it's
just that some players managed to
neutralize his openings but i am deeply
impressed with his wins against ikaru
and ding he took out two of the best
form players in this tournament he took
them out in absolute style and his gains
from this tournament should be studied
if you want to know how to be solid and
combative at the same time well he's
been criticized for the lack of
fighting spirit but none other on the
other hand
you cannot play the candidates in the
same way that you've played the other
tournaments so unless you're making the
necessary adjustments to your play
and that's what happened
yeah no he's been very solid and we hear
janna palms you talk about it in the
candidates you shouldn't lose your games
and rajab is very difficult to beat so
even if he doesn't win so many games
like others
he has lost two games this tournament
but he is not the type player who's just
gonna throw away games he doesn't go at
this stage in his career into this risky
territory like we've seen all the rays
of ferrugia do for example
speaking of ali reza purusha i think i
found something crazy in his game okay
we talked about duda making a big
mistake with rook f2 i think this
mistake is based on a crazy
miscalculation and ali reza is going to
have to do some serious tactical work to
go for this line we see bishop e5 on the
board and queen e2 in response you might
look at this move and say wait a second
there's a fork on f4 just due to that
tired no he is not because after knight
f4 he could take on f4 and meet bishop
takes f4 with queen g4 check fork
bishop g5 forced
and now it may appear
that after h4
black loses the piece what else is there
to say
but you can never ever ever stop
calculating if we make the move h4 on
the board black has the incredible
defense king h8 and this i think duda
might have missed you move the king
aside
and the point is that you can no longer
take with the queen due to rook g8 as
you're indicating and if you take with a
pawn
lpdo loose pieces drop off king is weak
the bishop is forked the black king is
safe and now it is white who is losing
the game i have a feeling that duda
might have missed the move king h8 and
if he goes down this line the tables are
going to turn they've already turned
and move order is extremely important
because at this point instead of king h8
i think you're very tempted to play
queen c5 check because you see that the
loose piece does drop off but after king
h1 you can't take this bishop on c4
because you get checkmated immediately
after king h8 queen f6 check only move
is king to g8 and your king is boxed in
by its own rook and that is check and
mate so after queen c5 check the king
slides to h1 and now you think why not
do the same thing donya just taught me
that i can put my king in the corner
because if pawn takes g5 i take this
bishop but there's a huge difference
right here the king is on h1 so queen
takes g5 becomes possible there is no
rook g8 because there is no pin and that
would allow white to win
well should we turn the tables literally
you know and i'll give this position
with white stoiler as a furious and okay
defend this one
man oh man this is a big big moment
it is indeed
and
wow this is quite a turnaround if in
fact alerisa plays knight f4 and knight
f4 just to show again rook takes f4
bishop takes f4 queen g4 check queen g5
would also seem to solve black's
problems but here you can just take on
g5 and after bishop takes now rook g3
there is no counter threat there's no
queen if only there was another queen
right there's no queen coming to c5 to
check the king and attack the bishop so
the rook g3 you'd protect i attack
you can't move it it is pinned to this
king here so this would allow white to
win the game so a huge oversight by yan
chistop duda and for ali reza
does he have any other move candidates
besides knight f4
well he does have knight h5 to f6 and if
he
misses king h8 and if he trusts jkd then
he's going to play knight f6 and we're
going to get back to
uh approximately the same position we've
had where black has clearly insufficient
compensation
and he missed it oh
my gosh
oh my gosh alireza faruja brings his
knife at him back
and he just hasn't been as sharp as
we've seen him when he ascended to 2800
he's visibly very tired because like he
was before he was making his movie so he
was yelling so
uh maybe he
doesn't sleep well during this
tournament
and i think duda might have seen 904
because maybe my eyes are deceiving but
i feel like he just breathed the big
sigh of relief and i actually think
that's why he was walking around he
couldn't bear to look at the position he
knew that he had missed king h8
what a crazy moment this is something
alireza would have seen
while in good form in a blitz game and
i'm not exaggerating that's how good
that kid is at tactics
something is just not screwed on right
for alirez of this tournament oh my gosh
knight f6 that really is surprising to
me because of how
great at tactics alireza is he has not
been in great form during this
tournament but knight f4 it was
available to him and now he's going to
suffer you see that yan chistop slides
his king
over to h1 he wants no part of problems
on the g file and with the king on h1
there's no queen c5 ideas because a
large part of that was that the king is
in check so the move king to h1
just getting the king out of there i
feel like now black has no counter play
whatsoever you know what surprises me
and i hate to be the monday morning
quarterback the guy who just criticizes
it's what i feel like is a lack of
stubbornness on ollie ross's part it's
like he's already resigned himself to
the way this game is going to go because
from his perspective
if knight f4 actually works it solves
all of his problems he knows that so
i feel like you got to spend more time
you've got 21 minutes or 20 minutes
whatever he's got you know that your
position is lost if you don't find
something crazy you know that knight f4
is a very forcing line you've got to
spend longer in that position you got to
be stubborn
and alireza just seems to lot seems to
have lost his heart
wow now he's not totally lost do you
call him the tin man
the tin man
wizard of oz
did i say the word ten you say he lost
his heart
oh the ten man had no heart yeah the
fact that i'd explained that to you
really uh i look i i listen to the
wizard of oz in russian yeah i actually
didn't know what's called the tin man is
that a trove
all right let's see i i did see wizard
of oz so
lay off
we outnumber you that's right i do you
do outnumber me i won't be um be able to
understand what you say in russian but
what i can understand is that yanchez of
duda now has the upper hand here he slid
his king to the corner already the same
one player has two rooks and it is young
chistop duda he has a rook for just a
knight in one pawn now
there's no clear victory at this point
for yon chistop his position is better
he can slide a rook over to g2 he can
bring his queen up in some direction
like this but how is he actually gonna
win this game
well i think he's gonna win it by
gradually accumulating or not so
gradually accumulating his pieces on the
f and g files you can play rook g2 and
in such positions i think it's a good
idea to
formulate an ideal setup a setup that
you are going to aim for
in the absence of specific counter ideas
by your opponent and i think that setup
is rook g2 which i'm expecting within a
couple of minutes and then rook d3 to f3
to f5 to put pressure on the bishop if
the bishop moves then the e pawn
shoves itself forward to e5 that bishop
from c4
it looks good it's putting pressure on
f7 but you actually might want to bring
it back to d3
in preparation for the black bishop
moving away from e5 so something like
this maybe the other rook coming to g5
to push that bishop off of e5 one way or
another i feel like duda is going to
find a way to crash through on the case
yeah i'm just gonna play some of these
moves rook f3 very useful because rook
b1 also looks like it's going to be
checkmate but you can block with the
rook you can also luck with this rook
and
yeah this feels like a position where
black is struggling to come up with any
ideas whatsoever exactly it's like put
yourself in alireza's shoes what is he
going to do to he's going to move his
rook
rookie 8 rook f8
sit and wait yes sit and wait but i like
donald's playing a lot of rook f5
because not only does that pose a
question to this bishop at some point
you can slide towards the g file and
create some problems for this king so
the rook on the third rank has been
pretty good but it can't get to the open
g file so if you're all in for the check
mini attack that rook lift you take the
elevator and you then walk to the side
and go for mate did he in fact play rook
g2
he did in fact play rook g2
yeah yes move
and already feeling the time crunch as
well 20 minutes for 10 moves in a
position like this
not easy at all
man
yeah 10 moves in this position right
even with 15 hours this would be hard
but really true and to remind everybody
the time control the players they start
with two hours they have that amount for
the first 40 moves then they get a full
hour added after
black's 40th move so
we'll see how alireza
deals with the impending time trouble
this position is really difficult to
play for black and i feel like white has
eight different moves at every turn that
seemed to keep him in the driver's seat
let's have a look
it's fabiano's game at fabiano's game we
should definitely do that we will bring
up fabiano's game uh just to show
everybody what's going on there as young
chistop duda
aims for a second victory in three games
he did beat fabiano carwana a couple
games ago
and fabiano he's been struggling he is
trying to find a way to win his game
against richard report but that one is
an ongoing battle but we have alireza
furuja on screen against yon tristop
duda alareza missed a huge chance he's
swinging his rook over to the queen side
like we were predicting so will alireza
find it within himself to continue
fighting or will jan chistov duda just
score his second victory with the white
pieces in two tries the depressing thing
about this is that i don't really see
the long-term counter play white has so
many ways to improve
his position and just looks like things
are going downhill for
alireza but we have a very special guest
in the studio we do indeed and as we
turn away from alireza and jan chistoff
we are happily joined by team over java
timor congrats on a nice game today yeah
thank you very much it was a pretty good
one
um so and you're now back to an even
score how are you feeling about the term
as a whole
well generally just fine but i mean i
was just fighting in most of my games
like i don't know i've spent like few
days probably there on the you know in
the playing area so um yeah i mean i
played seven hours games with the
ferrugi and many others
so yeah that was very hard
and today i just want to place at some
point some king's indian
to try to you know spice it up but i
decided i mean okay i'm not in the you
know i don't have enough energy to
really look at the lines and everything
and still he will go some g3 line and
then
you know you're not getting the real
king's indian so
yeah and then went for my lines but i
was surprised i don't know
i'm bringing ding
traumas like this already the second
time i mean first time was the world cup
where he was close for i think it was
his second final in a row yeah
and then first he lost the final
and uh then he lost to me while going
like plus one after two games yes i
think he won the second game and then
lost dessert in a very
you know closely equal position and this
moment here this was what we're talking
about here in the studio knight a6 your
preparation caught him off guard
yeah i think somehow he was prepared to
start the spawn race thing with f3 g4
queen going to f2 and h4 and so on uh
where black goes c5 c4 and lines like
this because he had to push today for a
win i guess
and um
somehow he found himself in this strange
situation because like the the position
that he had in that position you have to
play position to to try to get an
advantage so you have to play for the
a6a7 pawns you don't
push before i think too early um i think
we looked more at 92 knight coming to d4
then castling short push like putting
the bishop on d2 and then trying to go
around still black is fine dynamically
but so i mean they have to to be precise
but i was very surprised already when he
went for this b4 stuff so i saw that
probably he decided just to i mean to
equalize and make a draw
and uh so i think he was playing between
this
type of position was not giving him a
possibility to push like directly and on
the other hand he was trying to push so
i think that at this point he got
somehow confused because playing this b4
and then going b5 and you know not
playing k4
and just having i think that kind of
equal position i mean can do the same
like in the game but then he can castle
put the knight on before calmly so he
left his kingdom in the center of d1 was
very nervous move i don't know maybe the
pressure was too high he also played a
very hard game yesterday
at which point did you realize that
you were winning is it when he played f3
and you discovered the rook takes c3
idea
uh well
winning yes of course i mean after he
just mistook the x3 before i was not
sure so that maybe he will have some
kind of knight d1 pushing i mean
bringing the bishop to d4 even giving up
the a3 pawn and like putting the knight
on c3 and then some kind of you know uh
yeah some something like this for for
the a3 pawn still probably i mean for
the engine probably it's still good but
i mean practically i think this is kind
of uh
play he should be seeking for but um
maybe already here he has to give it up
like actually yeah actually the engine
is showing it like bishop a1 and castle
playing like this i don't think really
in a practical game white is having too
much risk
because at some point
you know knight before knight f5 is
coming
practically is very okay for white
well at least i mean
that's why i'm saying because he wanted
to keep the pawn as well he wanted to
press and then the position was not
allowing this i think after i played
queen c8 he was very surprised i think
he wanted to castle and already like
give give up the pawn ma3 but quincy
bishop h3 of course is uh is a very nice
thing and after this i think he was
confused about the position then he also
misrooked exe3
and probably could
still you know resist better i guess
because i mean what he was doing is just
the direct loss i don't know but what is
the evaluation here okay it's minus four
yeah yeah yeah it's a bit too much and
it kept growing two more of your two
wins both of them were excellent against
zicaro against ding
which one are you more proud of
um
i think against hikaru is more kind of a
win where you feel that you did
everything to win the game so because
today i think that it was like
very nervous play by dink certainly i
did my best but uh in general i think
missing the cirque de cree and playing
this kind of chess is not key style like
you know i have three king of two not
castling normally
pushing before for for really no reason
i mean even i mean he didn't know the
position here at least had to take some
time we were already at move like i know
12 or something i mean it's a normal
situation don't move five or three
and um
that game i was i'm more proud of of
course but because i mean it was like uh
yeah he did some inaccuracy in the
opening he gave up the pawn
but uh i think technically i found some
decisions in the statement as well and
uh i think pressed hard but in general i
did also feel a few inaccuracies there
that i was upset about and even during
the game i saw that he was having some
knight f4 tricks like uh rg1 g2 was too
much
and so on but still i mean it's it's so
it's about the technical you know stuff
that you are analyzing after seeing the
engine it's another story all over the
world it seemed to me very natural to
play gujarati to stabilize against ikaro
but uh like
in terms of like winning the game okay
today i did did like two three good
moves but again c car was in general a
pretty good game and you said that
today's game wasn't really dingley run
style and a player in this competition
who is young so we don't know exactly
maybe what his style is but other is a
fruit what have you made of his play
because it seems like he's going for a
win no matter the color no matter the
round including against you in the very
first game
yeah but i think there is in general he
will change a lot soon with this kind of
tournament that he will play
uh he will become more kind of stable
player he will have to go for slight
advantages he'll he will have to skip
this tactical style it's not anymore
this type of chess that makes you i mean
on top in general you should go more
magnus way you know to try to to beat
the players because many players are
just playing dry stuff and if you go
like this like i mean for example like
dean did today and stuff like that i
mean yeah you can win like one or two
games sometimes you're in a must-win
situation probably like he was today but
um this doesn't bring too much result on
the high level so as we see also against
jan because some people just uh played
you know
without any reason for a win and in that
situations you know of course he's
punishing them
and gets a lot of points for this but uh
yeah lyrics i think will change but he's
very young so
yeah
timor you're probably the most
experienced player in this entire field
you defeated famously gary kasparov with
the black pieces i believe in 2003. when
you compare your experience playing
people like kasparov in the early 2000s
with your experience playing perugia and
the younger players here at the
candidates do you feel like the styles
of the players have changed and do you
feel like the experience of playing and
preparing for an important tournament
has changed
well i think
honestly everything is changing because
now
let's say in in the times when i played
gary and all these like top players like
romney kanan and everyone from time to
time like there were like two three
tables playing in the super tournament
that were in the state note all the time
and nowadays if you're in satan
everybody says ah he's not in shape so
something is wrong with him we have to
beat him and stuff like that and that's
time pressure by the way yeah like time
pressure time pres i mean okay maybe in
one game and a few games of course in
the candidates but general people are
playing faster much faster than i used
to so having the satan was fine i think
it moved like 10 or 12 in bilbao
tournament it was even
we were having like few minutes it was
sicilian nothing special to be honest
but i don't know how how we got this i
mean he played some line with you know
e4 c5 knight of three e6 like g4c takes
knight the xd4 knight f6 knight c3
knight c6 a3 or something like this and
i was confused because i was not playing
any scavenging systems and stuff like
that so we went there he was also
confused because a3 was without any b5
is kind of strange so yeah we were
thinking and then it was like three
minutes for i don't know 28 moves or
something like this and that was kind of
strange but uh
i'm telling you at the time it was
normal to be in sight not nowadays
usually if you're in statement
especially in a few games already people
consider that you're out of shape so
that changed a lot so opening
preparation of course changed a lot so i
mean before
you could find novelties now you have
the correspondence basis and all that
stuff like all the people are analyzing
like the best moves on the engines
engines are improving every day
um well it's hard to compare compared to
generations because i mean i think
that's
let's be fair i mean kasparov kramnik
and ant if you put them in like 20 years
old or i don't know
25 years old in nowadays situation they
would also be on the very top for sure i
think that they're like
genius is like all these three players
let's say kramnik anand and gary of
course
so uh yeah as well as with all the other
champions so it's hard to compare yeah
probably we're playing better than
capablanca
but uh yeah but in terms of uh in terms
of capablanca studying like we did i
think he would also be on on the very
top yeah i think it's a fair assessment
and a question for you about you know
relative inactivity of course the
pandemic happened but a lot was said
about you hadn't won a game of classical
chess in in three years
playing in the candidates winning a
couple games here what are your
ambitions like
yeah but i don't know they're counting
like three years but it was like 2019
i've played in the world cup yeah
actually i want to get a dink right yeah
so uh then uh i finished the tournament
i was in a very bad like physical
condition and so on after one month
playing the world cup i went to the uh
vita grand prix in hamburg i played like
two games which ended like in 15 moves
in a draw against duboff and then uh
i play just one or two tournaments so
it's a bit not the same like if you are
so active like i don't know carvan and
all the other players and then you're
not winning a single game yeah you will
be already 2500 probably so in my case
yeah and uh
i mean in terms of this it's like a bit
strange comparison in terms of three
years but yes officially it is like two
to something or something like this but
uh yeah i'm feeling pretty well of
course especially beating dean let's be
fair in a good shape
uh in this tournament and uh
i mean the way it happened today uh
certainly was uh his fault in general
but also i had to show some class to to
punish this kind of place it's also a
thing and of course i'm feeling good
about winning two games against uh
the players problem i'm getting more i
mean i'm more motivated to play against
the players that are leading i guess i
don't know why because many players you
know brought traumas in my
situations when i was you know going on
good places like you know catching some
good results and so on and then they
were beating me without any you know
sentiment or something
yeah so uh yeah it's a professional
chance here you have to you have to
score when you have chance
final question for me uh we asked john
what his plans were for the rest day he
expressed the desire to spend a lot of
the day in bed do you find it more
relaxing to stay in your room most of
the time or do you like to explore the
city and
be active during the rest yeah pretty
same because i mean first of all there
is not too much energy to
to do anything except you know being in
the bed or watching some youtube and
watching the streams and so on
and um yeah some walking is good i guess
but so yeah we have to walk anyway i'm
walking from here uh to the you know to
the hotel let's say it's a nice walk in
general in the central part of madrid
and uh
yeah i think it's more or less the same
but
i can't say it's much a different style
than when we're at home like at the
training session for example training
session is also kind of tournament i
would say it's easier it's less
stressful of course also there are some
you know the the coaches the friends and
so on you're talking to everyone here
it's sometimes of course hard because
you're preparing all the time then you
have to play for like i don't know from
time to time to first seven hours or
something
and uh then there is a res day also it
runs super fast it's like there is no
rest day almost you don't feel it so it
goes so fast in the tournaments in a
normal situation you know at home if you
would have just one
like empty day or something that you
have to spend you don't know what you're
doing you're just asking yourself what i
will watch or something like you're
making plans
here it's like i don't know you you ate
the breakfast and then it's like 10
o'clock in the evening you have to go to
bed and also prepare for the next game i
know how it happens but in tournaments
it's like this time time runs much
faster well you said you might watch
streams but you have some uh questions
from the chat if you don't mind
answering them so i'll watch chicago's
three maybe
recap you already watched his recap
we have a question here do you like
reports jacket do you like his sense of
style
uh
yeah
yeah
i like it in general i think that he
gave some interviews about the jacket
yeah oh so you're watching everything
yeah i'm watching it from time i mean
it's always i mean it's on instagram and
somewhere else all the time hikaru i
think he has i think three different
recaps for each day i think he did i
think
he makes them before the match it seems
like for the different results the way
he plays but i mean it's like amazing
what he's doing uh to play the
candidates and make the you know the
streams or i think he was on the stream
as well yeah the title tuesday
yeah he played not only the title
tuesday i think he went for some stream
uh explaining his game
like also it was recap i guess or
something uh with the latest you know
some some kind of free capacity first
round something like this
and um
yeah i don't know how he's doing this
it's just amazing because uh
i don't have uh you know three two some
free 20 minutes to do something well
this next question is just about that
when are you gonna come back to
streaming on youtube
well i don't know i first have to finish
this tournament because i'm telling you
i mean here to stay i mean a few things
to score some points and to stay alive
are two main goals yeah so afterwards
yeah yeah thank you roshan 729 for that
question so the ques the answer is tbd
on that one and i think we have one more
question coming in from the chat
you put up on your sunglasses
yeah i mean uh
i did actually once i think in the world
uh championship at the time it was in
libya yeah yeah and i was playing
dominguez and i lost the first game
and um i had some inflammation in my ear
yeah so
that was not the you know for showing
the class it was just an inflammation in
my ear so i was having the tears and all
that stuff so i had to put the
sunglasses i think it was probably
rare casey for the professional chess it
was
what quarter final of the world
championship at the time
yeah so i was playing in the glasses and
then arbiter
told me that is everything all right why
are you watching i mean why are you
wearing the glasses and uh
i mean i was not really anymore to
explain so i just took them off and he
saw my eyes like full of tears and so on
and he saw that i'm uh you know unhappy
because they will be leaving libya
but actually i won that match and so
yeah and then went to the semi-finals
and uh that's the only time i think when
i played in the sunglasses well they
wanted you to put it on i don't know and
show us that yeah yeah but i mean okay
you don't have to do it on on-demand
showing yeah i i ignore chat all the
time and i will ask you one last
question before we let you go magnus
carlson of course says that you know he
might not play a world champion match
now that you have six out of 12 here's
half a point behind second place are you
thinking about that a lot like with the
next two rounds coming are you going to
be ambitious and
yeah i mean i will
try my best of course in any case i mean
not depending on magnus playing the
match or not
and
i'm sure that he will play the match i
don't know why
everybody is still stressing out about
this i think it's not the first time
that he's saying this um
all the world champions all the world
champions i guess and the the people who
reached the uh peak in their career they
are probably from time to time thinking
that maybe i can do something else and
you know in life or
go to politics i don't know in magnus
case i don't think that he will go there
maybe he will try to beat hikaru in
streams or something
he's playing the world series of poker
so poker i think maybe he will be in i
don't know in soccer team
something like this but already it's i
mean in this age it's not easy yeah so
he's also i mean i'm used to that he's a
youngster and so on because i've played
the first match i think i've mentioned
today i think he was 12 or something i
was playing against him in corsica in
rapid match and uh somehow all the time
even though he became the world champion
and so i have this perception that he's
a youngster somehow but now i saw that
okay i mean if he's going to play
football it's
just a few years left
yeah so i'm not sure that he will not be
playing the world championship
because it should be motivating and um i
don't know for him once again to show
that he's the best in the world
otherwise why to play the normal
tournaments the commercial tournaments
and
we've asked both dingley ren and hikaru
if there is a tie for second we don't
know whether that is important but do
you think that it the tie break should
be played out over the board rather than
by any sort of tie break system
well the tie breaks are good in general
i think it's the right way
and
also for the world championship format
um i think also carlson
uh was proposing this i think the world
cup format is a good thing like all this
you know knockout matches and so on it's
a very good thing i think in my opinion
so you would prefer knockout matches for
the candidates rather than a double
round robin
so uh the knockouts i think are a good
thing also for the people like watching
it's it's fun all the time because i
mean until the very end i mean it goes
like you know uh in the candidates for
example if you started badly and then
you have to play for 14 i mean 14 rounds
and you are like minus four and there's
no chance to win the tournament or
something like this it's like uh
useless tournaments everybody is trying
to beat you and so on so it's a bit uh
tricky thing i think but for the world
championship i think you can i mean can
we use the knockout system in general
it's also a lot of fun and um it's like
it's normalizing i think it's a good
it's a good thing to try at least they
used it for some time but world
champions were not participating that
was the problem yeah the only problem so
i think at some point it was uh topple
of playing and like all the kramnik
kasparov and all these guys they were
not playing the
the tournaments that was the problem if
they would be there of course but uh
world champion in this case of course
should be consulted because i mean he's
the
title holder so yeah well you heard it
from timor java all of his thoughts
about his game about uh second place his
ambition so thank you teamwork so much
for joining me
thank you good luck in the next rounds
thank you
well as we let timor get on out of here
to enjoy his rest day we look at the
standings once more he is right now in
clear fourth place ahead of fabiano
carwana who is still playing his game
and only a half point behind the player
he beat dingley ren and ikaru nakamura
the streamer that he watches so a lot
left at stake for rejavo and he said no
matter if second is important or not
almira he is going to keep fighting
that's true that was actually a very
long and insightful interview
that's what timor gave us
but
i just like i'm walking out of the
studio i'm coming back all i wanted is
to see for
well we can bring up fabiano's game
because that will impact the standings
if he can somehow win he has the black
pieces against the man you see on screen
oh now you no longer see him but oh now
we see him again richard
so
this match-up is still going on and for
five minute carwana it's a position with
queen rook and five pawns per side the
engine slightly prefers a black's
position because presumably the activity
of the rook on f2 versus the rook on h1
and
as we look at this i mean elmira you
first do you think that fabiano has
legitimate winning chances especially
given the clock situation
legitimate winning chances i don't think
so but richard has to find a way to
activate his rook
uh
[Music]
what should be the possibility he can
play rookie one here
you lose sight of that h5 pawn
i
literally don't care
as hicaro would say because i want to
infiltrate the seventh rank
so you want to get your queen and your
rook up there together going for some
kind of aggression aggressive excuse me
intentions
yeah i mean queen g6 here looks like the
natural move to me
but the problem is that black plays
queen f4
and there's two
i mean the first of all the disparity in
the activity of the rooks is very
concerning
it's not that white is in danger of
getting checkmated you always have the
move rook c1 let's not overstate the
case but the problem is that if black's
queen gets to d2 for example and then
forces rook c1 and then black goes rook
h2
now we have a problem because if the
queen let's say moves back to g6 white
can't just stall because already queen
g5 wins the pawn on h5 and if black wins
that pawn the defensive task becomes
you know becomes prohibitively difficult
largely because black's king is
unbelievably safe look at that pawn
cocoon that surrounds black's king that
eliminates any threats of perpetual i
think richard will lose the game if he
loses the h-bond so
these next couple of moves and they're
far from trivial he's got five minutes
on his clock
i think he's let this one slip and
i feel like he needs to be very very
precise not to fall into a lost position
by the time control so uncomfortable
playing a position where your opponent
has so much more activity than you do
where it's even material in the back of
your mind you're like if i look at this
with an engine i know it should be a
draw but every move is challenging to
make but that's exactly the situation
that i wanted to avoid it's very
important to fight to find a way to
activate your rook so we are looking for
an active defense even if we have to
sacrifice the bomb but to activate our
pieces at all costs
and we we know that
he needs to make to move 40 at all costs
he has over five minutes remaining does
richard report oh no he has four minutes
and 24 seconds a little bit of a dgt
issue but you see here on screen that he
has four minutes in 1977 and he
nervously brings that queen to g6 we
were just analyzing that variation so
the queen for black can venture on over
to e3 or f4 e3 seems a little bit more
flexible because you have two different
infiltration squares on the second rank
and if this rook has to go to c1 this is
starting to get mighty unpleasant for
richard report and i think fabiano is
going to play this out
forever and he might just win this pawn
h5
now that i look at this
white might want to get a situation the
lesser evil might be a situation in
which white does give up the pawn in h5
but under the conditions that it leads
to a queen trade and that white's rook
gets behind the pawn on h7 or h8 i feel
like black's damaged queen side pawn
structure
would make it very very difficult for
fabby to actually win that
but richard still needs to figure out a
way to make all of that happen after
something like queen e3 or queen f4
which largely lead to the same position
and they threatened queen d2 as we were
discussing
so how are you going to get your rook
out so
oh and queen to e3 was in fact played so
how are you going to get your rook out
into the open
yeah that's the million-dollar question
i mean first of all find a muffer for
white you know because
the queen on g6 is optimized you're
almost in zouzon
and queen drops back to g1 i think wow
that is not a move that you really want
to play it's very awkward with the
queen and the rook next to each other so
as we get to the live position
i think richard has found a way to get
the semi-optimal position queen d2 queen
c1
okay but now queen e2 yeah and you just
keep the tension i was going to wonder
if i take your queen mm-hmm and you take
up five you don't want to
take with the rook because the work
comes h2 and then i or you don't even
have to move the rook right i make some
kind of move as soon as your rook moves
i go rook h2 and go for the pawn i guess
you can maybe try to make this e1 and
protect this way but once i go rook f5
your rook has to go back and you're in a
passive position once again even the
queens are off it doesn't solve your
problems but we got to go to the game
between yon chistov duda and ali raza
faruja because we see a position where
ali reza can win back his material in
the bottom left
and oh my goodness knight g3 check
because if the king steps up there's all
sorts of threats with rook b2 and this
is a forcing variation we'll bring up
the analysis board here knight g3 king
g2
rook b2 check if you move your king you
lose your bishop and maybe there's some
play left there but if you go rook f2
after the swap of pieces there's bishop
to d4 check and the rook on g1 is lost
for the knight on g3 looks like aliers
is going to save the game after all what
an unbelievable turn of events this is
such a strange round it really is i mean
what
weird stuff
isn't i mean weird stuff is happening in
all the boards and alireza he sees it
and he plays it and he's going to make
time control and the next couple of
moves are completely forced and i'm just
going back to rookie to see what
happened rook b8 bishop a2 looks normal
knight e8 and then somehow that knight
went over to h5 so queen e3 knight d6
and after rook d1 here comes the queen
to f6 so black is stabilizing in this
position not letting and this yeah d1
might have been inaccurate allowed black
to get better positioning that's right
and that's the rook f2
queen g6 rook g1 this looks pretty good
except for the fact that he gave away
the e4 blunder knight g3 he blended
knight g3 completely i mean takes rook
out of g2 and you keep a big advantage
because black can't put push that f bomb
due to the mate on g8 that's right rook
after g2 you see absolute winning three
and you threaten this pawn and if the
rook comes to f8 thinking you cover both
g8 and f7 this bishop in many times can
take on f7 here there is no g3 check but
you have to watch out because there's
not it's not like black can do anything
you're kind of paralyzed here so a big
missed opportunity to continue the
advantage knight g3 king g2 and
well this is looking like it's going to
be a split point here
yeah dude could also play king f3 rook
takes a2 and rookie one oh but the rook
can capture the pawn on a3 and the
simple fact is that white's king has no
safe haven it has to drop back to g2 and
then you get a perpetual check
three time repetition with rook a2 check
don't go king g1 there because of bishop
d4 mate
but uh king f3 forces the draw so this
game
is decided and i think jan kristoff will
probably go r2 here to
to to make sure that you know nothing
crazy happens but just pointing out that
the bishop cannot move because there's a
back ranked check made a ladder mate and
white can throw and move like king to
black to throw in king g8 and then this
rook goes somewhere along the seventh
rank somewhere over here and the bishop
still can't move so black's best bet is
to do as don just suggested rook up and
down check back and forth make a draw
this way but young chistop i mean he had
such a good chance at securing his
second victory with the white pieces in
as many games and ali raza farouja he
provides knight back to f6 but then he
went knight f6 to e8 to d6 all around
the board takes on e4 finally lands on
g3 and i think young child stuff sees
the end and he's going to go rook f2
yeah i don't think there is
much doubt about that orc after rook
takes f2
i can't believe it
yeah he's
i mean he just seems despondent a lot of
the time and i feel like that
you know sometimes that negative
self-talk
it starts getting to you even when you
have a good position
you're
starting to almost expect yourself to
blunder and that becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy if you're
already dejected to begin with as work
up to is on the board
then that greatly increases the chances
of wonder
well they're trading off everything so
after bishop d4 check
scoops up the rook on g1 it's an extra
pawn
for black but that doesn't matter
because of the presence of opposite
colored bishops and it's not like the
game between dingley wren and richard
report where there are pawns all over
the place past pawns that is for one
player here they're just going to make
some kind of repetition pretty soon
because they know that the result is not
in doubt and yanchez k4 the only thing i
would do here is play a4 for white just
to make sure the black doesn't
fix the pawn on a dark square not that
it matters even if black plays a4 and
it's mutual destruction of the apons but
just to make sure
there are no shenanigans
you can't believe it yeah he really is
in shock about how he threw away what
was a very clear advantage
twice
and the first time eli reza didn't
capitalize he got a second chance and he
threw it away again
right and while this game is about to
conclude five out of caruana has in fact
traded queens and he believes in his
endgame because the queens were actually
traded on the d1 square as we see in the
top left the players get more time and
that h5 pawn is falling so fabiano
carwana has winning chances zero risk at
all and now the task is richard reports
to hold on to this game and it will not
be easy
right but what didn't he like in in
in the position after rookie one
uh which move will get you know
the move that i suggested just in case
that was to keep the queens and the
rooks on the board
okay so back after queen g6 before queen
g6 yes and we have a result there the
game is drawn the players discussing
missed opportunities i think other is
yes he's pointed knight h5 and the g3
square earlier
when he went knight f6 right that was
probably what he's asking about but
knight f4 was available there i wonder
if either player really has seen it
because during the game they were
calculating it seems like a mutual miss
yeah seems like a mutual
spot of blindness but as a result the
game has ended in a draw with ali raza
finally
able to stop the bleeding one way or
another
he can't wait for this tournament to be
over but
all's well that ends well for alireza in
this game this could have easily been
another loss
it could have indeed and that leaves us
with just one game remaining in the
tournament hall it's pretty empty there
but there is
one game two players trying to figure it
out
five minute carwanas st louis chess club
jacket they're on full display it is a
very tall chair the jacket is proudly
seated on it and the player is taking a
break as they have reached mu 40. so we
will do the same for now when we return
we'll dive into all things report versus
caruana this is the 12th round of the
2022 feed a candidate the coverage here
by chest.com continues in just a few
[Music]
how many brilliant moves have you played
when do you play your best chess
how many games have you won by castling
in the end game
how many opponents have you played from
new zealand
and most importantly of all how many
botes gambits has alexandra botez played
find the answers to all of these
questions and many many more at
chess.com
insights
our new tool that lets you dive deep
into all of the fun and instructive data
behind your chest try it today
in qualifying for the candidates hikaru
nakamura ratcheted up the level of
interest in what is already considered
the most important tournament in chess
with millions of followers as a popular
content creator hikaru brings along his
sizable community while also attracting
more casual chess fans
although once ranked number two in the
world most believed nakamura's best days
competing in classical chess were behind
him
that changed when this japanese american
grand master leaned on his exceptional
calculating ability to win the fide
grand prix the unexpected victory earned
him a bid into the candidates for the
first time in six years
a five-time u.s champion hikaru has
stayed sharp of late by dominating in
speed chess formats nakamura is
currently ranked by fide in the top two
in both rapid and blitz
a chess giant on twitch and youtube
yukaru brings a special buzz to a
tournament that already holds the keys
to becoming the next world champion
and there are certainly those who have
yet to rule out hikaru from catching
lightning in a bottle here in madrid
chess kid is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational to kids it
feels just like playing but chess is a
great way to learn patience strategy and
critical thinking
chess kid features a comprehensive
training program that guides kids to
level up on their way to mastery this
curriculum is designed to work with
common core standards and global
educational guidelines there are more
than fifty thousand chess puzzles and a
whole library of entertaining videos
that teach strategies tactics openings
and end games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds chess kid helps you organize
your students and monitor their progress
each child receives a weekly report card
that shows how many lessons puzzles and
games were completed you can also
organize kids into clubs and send them
messages
chess kid is the online home of
scholastic chess for thousands of kids
parents schools and coaches signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
want to play chess online or learn how
to improve join us at the number one
chess destination in the world chess.com
with thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a grand master chess.com
makes learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we see the beautiful interior of the
palacio de santonia the artwork on the
walls it's just so bright everyone
enjoys touring this place and all around
here you will find not just beautiful
sculptures and statues and paintings but
happy chess players who are enjoying the
competition even if richard report at
the moment does not seem to be enjoying
his game but while richard report is on
the clock trying to figure out if he can
hold this rook end game we have daniel
niroditsky at the telstra with a fun
game
thank you robert
well richard report and fabiano carona
are very likely to play a long end game
of course timur jabba played a short
game and on the topic of short games
i've got another episode in our opening
traps new series episode number three
i'd like to show something called the
legals mate this is a very very
important opening trap it really
illustrates the power of minor pieces
it's named
not after legal of illegal fame but a
french master 18th century master whose
last name was legal i think that's how
you pronounce it rumor has it that the
original application of this trap was
played in a very famous parisian cafe
called the cafe de la regence where you
had tons of chess masters meeting for
cigars and coffee and of course
brilliant chess games here's how it goes
legal plays e4 and his amateur opponent
plays e5 so far so good
his opponent essays the philidor defense
which was later named for another
illustrious french chess player and that
is d7 d6 in this position a move that is
still considered very solid but now the
trouble begins legal develops as bishop
two c4
and black makes a somewhat ill-advised
move bishop to g4 this is still not that
bad but knights before bishops that's
the way that you're supposed to develop
legal continues to develop his knights
with knight c3 and here his opponent
makes a very unfortunate move he decides
that since the d-pawn blocks the
dark-squared bishop
let me fianchetto the bishop with g6
looks pretty natural looks like nothing
could possibly happen here and yet legal
he takes the cigar out of his mouth he
takes the sip of his coffee and
bang goes the dynamite knight takes e5
his opponent looks at him and says i
think you had something before you had
that coffee thank you very much for your
queen except this is legal's mate why
does only three minor pieces developed
and that's the only minor pieces that
white needs to deliver checkmate in the
center of the board bishop takes f7
check forces the king up to e7 and now
the beautiful final move knight c3 jumps
into d5 and yes ladies and gentlemen
despite the abundance of black pieces
this is checkmate and legal's opponent
shed more than one tier this is legal's
mate
there's instantiations across many
different openings and as i said at the
start it's a great illustration of just
how powerful
peace tandems can be in chess back to
you robert nomira uh that is a very
famous example of activity and delayed
castling king in the center how you get
checkmated very early on but this is
rich report not afraid of checkmate but
afraid perhaps of this rook end game
where he will lose a pawn so as we
remind everybody of what has transpired
in round 12 of 2022 fiat candidates we
have
one decisive result
team over jabba wins the black hikaru
nakamura yonder palmish they drew as
soon as they sat down and then ali
raised a farouza he withstood the
pressure he was in big trouble yon chest
of duda could not score the full point
that game was a draw and as we see the
standings yonder pomshy in first by two
full points he needs one draw and he
will be the winner of the 2022
candidates tournament
i actually think in some ways he would
want a rest day tomorrow he just wants
to get it over with he wants to make
that damn draw and just secure first
place already he's going to spend
some of the day in bed stewing over the
momentousness i don't know if that's a
word the importance let's just say of
the occasion but the good news for yon
he's got the white pieces he's got the
white pieces against richard report
who always promises a interesting
fighting game but if yon plays to even
50 of the form that he has displayed
this tournament we can fully expect that
he's going to wrap this tournament up in
the next round
what does that mean you assumed i spoke
french because i pronounced the goal
correctly
it was marvelous thank you
so before we dive in into
this end game
i know you want to look at that position
with rookie once so we'll bring up the
analysis board we're going to get to it
right now you guys are finishing each
other's senses oh no i know exactly
where almer wanted us to go to so at
this point in time after age six you
were suggesting rook to e1
and i was looking at the move
queen h2 maybe this was the move that
richard didn't like when
he was analyzed in this position
attacking both balance at the same time
but there's rogue one yeah
saying sorry kaidano would say going
back to the square you came from one of
the hardest things to do in chess
yeah and i think that black still has
the upper hand you can move your queen
back to from where it came so
yeah i think rookie one that might be a
really nice move coordinating the pieces
and getting activity because there's no
immediate way for black to win this pawn
over on h5 you can play with like queen
g5 aiming directly for it
but we already get in a position where
white can try to defend actively and if
black is stubborn and says i'm going to
win this pawn i think that this queen
has many options you can go for
something similar to what elmer was
suggesting let's get the queen and rook
active and even threaten the checkmate i
would be tempted to bring my queen to c7
as well and try to get my rook up on the
e file with two different kinds of mates
so it does feel like a position that
with an inaccuracy report went from
potentially active defense maybe giving
up material to a situation where
he is now
going to give up a pawn without the
queens on the board so that means that
there's no active counter play
yeah and i mean this type of end game
where you have
one pawn on one flank an extra pawn
versus three on three or four on four
this type of end game has been very well
studied
what makes this particular end game
interesting is the unusual pawn
structure for both sides on the queen
side so you have a four on four on the
queen side
and richard report is an
incredibly important decision to make
right here and right now he can either
get down to business try to get his rook
behind the pawn rookie one rook f1 rook
g1 all of these moves lead to rome
or you can play d3 d4 and you can try to
effectuate a pawn trade before getting
the rook behind the pawn if black
doesn't play c takes d4 after rook takes
h5
white can either push the pawn at d5 and
then secure it with c4 tempting or take
on c5 and then play rook d7 or h7 so
there's essentially
three different decisions wrapped in one
move for richard report and
changing the pawn structure is always
important in the end game he's got the
extra hour and he's trying to put it to
the best possible use
it feels uncomfortable rook h1 check
king goes here and what if i just start
pushing my pawn like if i just bring
this one to h3 and i think one important
thing that we will show everybody right
now is that you don't actually want to
push your pawn all the way to h2 because
that's how these kind of games
immediately end draw as the players
we saw d4 and actually fight took on d4
immediately and he didn't want to see d5
happen that's why he took on d4 but i'll
quickly show that in this type of
position where if you're just pushing
your pawn don't play king a3 because
rook a1 would be checkmate but if we
just make waiting moves and this pawn
goes up you don't want to play h2
because what you actually want to do
is bring your king
to g3
and then you have the h2 square to hide
on if your king is checked but as soon
as you play h2 and this rook moves i
will allow your king to get all the way
there so we'll just quickly
see the king run and have some fun but
it's not going
anywhere with great effect because once
the king gets all the way
but no i clicked on the wrong thing the
king gets all the way down here as soon
as the king touches the pawn that frees
the rook to move away and the pawn to
promote so you give a check the king has
to step away you can give another check
or just go back and the rook is frozen
the king has to come back i keep giving
the checks and this game's a draw
that's exactly right and
if i'm honest i'm pretty shocked that
fabby took on d4 as quickly as he did
because in the end game you never want
to miss a moment
when
you know you have a certain decision to
make you never want to sleep through
that and i think that's exactly what he
did if we look at the current position
in the game rook takes d4 rook takes h5
very accurate move by richard i think
it's a dead draw because you can get the
position that the problem isn't getting
the pawn to h3 you can do that at
whatever pace you want to do it the
problem comes after you put upon an h3
that black king on a7 it's going
absolutely nowhere because black's pawns
are too vulnerable there's no way to
reposition them in such a way as to
allow black's king the necessary tempi
to make it all the way to the queen side
by the time you do that you know the
earth will have been destroyed by an
asteroid and white will have definitely
taken all of black's queenside pawns and
made his own queen i think this game is
going to end pretty quickly
yeah amira looks like a position where
it's hard at this point to see how
richard goes wrong because
we can always give this check on h1 and
then push the pawn but white has an easy
task you can push your palm to c4
there's no more mate so your king can
also
join the party but it feels like there's
no risk in white's position at all
because the plan is very simple well
black can always try and play b5 but i
will fix your pawns with b4
and
well this is a dead throw i agree with
daniel
asah4
and i think white can continue to defend
actively b3 even
potentially preparing c4 let's say h3
king b2
and the problem is clearly illustrated
after let's say king b8 i like the idea
of going c or rook h7 simply goodbye
let's go let's go to dinner
no way to make progress for sure and if
the king tries to do what it did in the
game between dingley ren and yan chistop
duda where the king ran to chase the
rook you lose this b7 pawn so as soon as
you keep running and i can do nothing
and you go here i can
try to take this pawn on b7 now the
reason why you typically don't want to
take a pawn like this is because it
frees up this rook the rook was tethered
to the pawn on h3 now the rook can slide
to c1 and you may think no big deal i'll
go king b2 to attack your rook and
defend the pawn but as you see in the
evaluation bar it's actually a bad
decision because i'm not going to move
my rook just because it's attacked i
will play h2 i will play h1 my rook
defends here and that means black would
be able to win the end game so what you
really want
from fabion's perspective is to be able
to free that rook up but it's never
going to be easy with the rook staying
behind that past pawn maybe you should
keep your king on b2 and place dany's
move like c4
yeah
that also works for sure c4
no reason that you have to keep going
king a2 king b2 and so on and
if we get a trade
yeah b6 for instance but white can even
play c5 i think
and use the c pawn as
as a decoy there's mutually assured
destruction the black king can never
move outside the radius
of the c pawn black is nothing better
than to just shuffle the king between
the eighth rank or the rogue between h2
and h1
and fabi
you know he's coming to terms with that
there is just isn't much to
to analyze here there are no attempts
right and that's the frustrating thing
for fabiano because it probably felt
like he would have some winning chances
the game would go on forever richard
would get tired he would be left with a
few decisions and make the wrong one as
fabiano did yesterday against dingley
wren but this position is so clear-cut
the plans are quite straightforward you
put your rook behind the past pawn uh
you can pretty much do whatever you want
if you're white with your king and pawns
over there on the queen side but just
leaving the rook on the h file for white
is all it takes but it's also so
uncharacteristic for fabby to make those
moves like ct xd4 very quickly so like
yesterday to make a few inaccuracies
which finally led to a blunder
he's showing also signs of like
impatience
yeah and patience fatigue and you know
even if this game ends as a draw and he
remains behind
hikar nakamura and dingley ren he still
have two rounds to go so he has a chance
to get a win maybe even two and fight
for second place but as we had timor in
the studio and we also have had a car
say this they both believe that magnus
is going to play a world championship
match and that's why fabiano has been
all in for the last several rounds he
wants to get first place or it's bust
and he's been showing that and it hasn't
been working out in the second half of
these candidates it's funny how much i'm
influenced in the moment by you know the
participants opinions it was very
reassuring when timur was claiming that
it's clear that carlson was trolling and
it's obvious that he's going to play i
felt the sense of reassurance yeah of
course he was trolling but then i hear
somebody else say well why would he
bring this up if you were trolling and
then i all of a sudden i think now
there's no way he was trolling so
there is no way to find out and we have
to operate under the assumption that
second place is important the players
certainly have to operate under that
assumption
but can we just really quickly go back
to the moment
after d4 because let's analyze it
you know this game is going to proceed
slowly i think i understand what it is
that fabi overlooked after rook takes h5
d5 king b8 i think fabi fell under the
illusion
that following c4 white gets this
protected passer and how could this
possibly be good for black what i think
fabi might have underestimated is the
power of the undermining technique b6 b5
and the double b bonds are actually good
why are they good you might ask well
because after b takes c4 b takes c4
after a random move like king c2 the
second b pawn is used once again as a
battering ram you would advance it to b5
and white can use his double b pawn to
once again support with b3 but you can
tell the pressure that the c4 pawn is
under rook h4 comes into play this ain't
an easy draw for white at all and fabi
is definitely going to be kicking
himself for
you know for falling for the illusion
and playing instantly and that careless
king c2 move which i know you were just
saying apparently
the problem if you go king up b4 check
separates the king from this b2 pawn and
if you go back to either b1 or c1 i
bring my rook to h4 and now the only way
to keep your pawn chain is make a move
like rook c1 and after b6 you're stuck
here white has to defend black's king
will venture forward and then this rook
and pawn will keep white tied down and
in fact it's already a losing position
despite how similar it looks to the game
white has a passive setup black can put
pressure on white's pawns and the game
continuation on the left hand side of
your screens there is no pressure
against white pawns there is no
undermining going to happen and black
has these double pawns on the b file
which can't spring free any kind of past
pawn
and richard plays once again a very
precise move which is b4 here like
reminds me of the game
[Music]
against hikaru yesterday and the move f5
which was uh very precise and guaranteed
him in draw
yeah and both players the look on their
faces for richard it's like let's get
this over with you know it's a draw for
fabiano it's desperate searching for
winning chances uh but it he knows that
this game is going to fizzle out and it
is a draw there aren't too many things
that he can do here uh
there's not even like a spicy variation
right there's just
nothing to do when but this rook is
going to go right there on h7 and that
means that this king is not getting out
into
the territory needs to be over here on
g3
so
fabiano he's had a tough second half
he has lost three out of four games
that's not a sense you hear very often
when referring to five minute carwana
and he gets black in the next round
against timor java who he has a
monstrous score against five wins no
losses but timor suddenly in good form
and fabi not
timor seems to be bringing brimming with
confidence right now
he's in a great spot on the tournament
and the rest day couldn't come soon
enough for fabi who will need to press
the reset button because he's got two
games that when he's at his best he's
capable of winning he's got as you said
monster scores not only against for java
but also in the final round against
faruga that's a game he will definitely
expect himself to win
and let me tell you fabi will find it a
lot more pleasant to analyze the
disappointing second half of the
tournament if he wins the last two games
or at least gets a point and a half
then if he
continues his tailspin
and doesn't manage 50
and look at that move by report by the
way b3 fabiano attacks the pawn on b4
richard says take it because if you take
the pawn on b4 you lose the pawn on h6
and three on two on the same side of the
board is a theoretical draw even when
the pawns are not doubled but with them
doubled it makes it even easier so this
game comes to conclusion but as we're
talking about elmira what do you think
will favi play some kind of sharp risky
opening against teamwork java or will he
settle down with black and then try to
win that last game with white
it's very difficult to predict what what
will happen but
fabi has accustomed us to
two very risky uh opening choices
especially with black pieces
well
one game comes to mind against yandy
pomnishi and i think actually regrets
the draw that he took in this game
because there was a very powerful uh
exchange sacrifice so
um
they think it's a double-aged decision
but uh
it depends once again on teamwork
reporter
yeah it certainly does and we have
a very random tweet by dan the man crow
saying i bet richard report
you can see that
i could see that too yeah i hope maybe
the banjo though we can ask him though
yeah that would be a good question see
if he plays any instruments
and
well you're right elmira though that the
second round game all the way back then
was an opportunity for fabiano to be a
shark as magnus has called it and
and what if you know what what if the
what if for sure like you know if he
knew that jana palm she was going to win
all his games he would have tried to
beat him in the second round but there
was no guarantee obviously that jan
would have round two of the candidates
well
not round two of this one but a reprisal
of his first candidates tournament where
he he really shined and i think people
were caught off guard by the first
candidates win by john because he hasn't
won major tournaments like he's been
towards the top but it's not like he's
been winning the sink full cup or these
gran chester events he has done well and
maintained his rating but he actually
didn't really have too many big
tournament victories until the
candidates
well that's true but it's also like it's
an incredible breakthrough it's such a
milestone like in his career and
bringing the second candidates back to
back
is absolutely impressive but when i was
looking at the results uh i was asking
myself the question like i have never
seen fabi losing
three games out to four
no
when it's not blitz chess you don't see
that
that's crazy
he did lose
i think a couple the u.s championship
but it was
uh early enough in the tournament where
he came back to such an extent that he
almost won the tournament
here he's doing it in the second half he
just doesn't have he's running out of
real estate he's running out of miles
left in the tank and
at this point you know his tournament is
largely in the tank but that doesn't
mean
that he can't influence the course of
events in the last two rounds that
doesn't mean he doesn't put in full
effort fabby as a consummate
professional and that's why we like
watching him so much we can expect an
incredibly high level of play come hell
or high water and it's a very relevant
question based on what you just said by
jerome moro has fabi played the most
hours total in this tournament most of
his games seem pretty long i'll marry
you've made this point on several
occasions that his style of chess the
way he plays the games is exhausting
because he's giving it his all he's
thinking calculating so much and he
doesn't have these short games that
other players seem to have well actually
you have to take this
element into account because well i know
how
elite players prepare and
well they repair to us so sometimes you
prepare it in a way so you wouldn't
consume that much time and energy in the
opening phase so you will be fresh you
know after the fourth hour so
well i think it suits fabiano but on the
other hand well this is the drawback
for sure and well his second half has
not been one that he would like to
remember and
we have
a zazel tycoon saying how does one offer
a draw over the board okay so it depends
on the situation
in a tournament like this you see the
players repeat moves because that is
their way of offering a draw they know
it's completely even but in
a casual not such a serious term as the
candidates how do you offer draw you say
i offer a draw and then you see if your
opponent wants it but some terms don't
allow draw offers in which case players
can be smart about it and just find a
way to repeat even if the position seems
unclear but usually without any sort of
regulation players just offer a draw you
know after um
they with their move they offer a draw
so they are pushing their pawns they
offer you a draw whatever it may be and
the player can either accept a decline
that's what i'll explain the only thing
yeah like you're saying
it's
ethical to opera draw only on as you're
making your moves that your opponent can
think about on their move offering a
draw
while it's still your turn
um can
i mean i think if that happens you're
allowed to ask your opponent to make a
move
and you're forced to make a move and you
may not retract the dropper as you make
a move
i've i've done that before for sure if
someone offers me a draw on their turn i
just see it as like kind of poor
etiquette unless the position is like
completely drawn right here at that
point you're basically extending your
hands right if it was a rookie three
against it's not much of an offer as a
declaration but there are circumstances
where people have been like they're
thinking and they're like i offer you a
draw i'm like i mean make your move
because i can accept
no matter what so if you blunder on this
turn i'm not accepting it but if you
make the normal move then i might accept
it so in general i mean i've had this
conversation before i think drawfur
should be banned i feel very strongly
about this it deprives fans of
understanding why a game concludes a lot
of draws at the high level come in
situations where there's a lot of life
left in the position and
players they can force draw if they
really need to but draw offers by
themselves where you can't just explain
oh the rules of chess stipulate that
when there's a three-time repetition the
game is over or there are no pieces
remaining on the board but when you have
a messy position and a player just makes
a draw you're left wondering
why or they were scared of something but
play it out like i i don't mind to draw
as a result that's really not the case
it's more so that
when you watch chess
no other sport you can just be like all
right i'm gone in tennis you can retire
if you're injured that's true but if you
watch a game of basketball they don't
just leave and be like i would die at
this and there are no ties in both other
sports so that's part of it but yeah i
really do not like drawfurs i think that
if they banned them from chess players
would adjust and they wouldn't have too
big of a problem with it well that was
robert's manifesto
well i'll go to a much nicer and kinder
person we have dingley wren's interview
ready for you all so let's take a look
at that
doing appreciate you joining uh there
was a bad opening outcome what do you
think went wrong
yeah i i regret the opening choice
especially when i saw he played knight
86 very quickly and
i'm already out of the book so
it's a very difficult to
adjust myself i would like to preach for
win but it's not the way to play four
wins i play very badly
i miss luke history and after this
totally lost
and yesterday i win
lost
lost possession but today
i lost
the game so just
fair cheers affair our commentators
suggested maybe bishop takes a6 was uh
incorrect or was it b4 allowing a5 if i
didn't take on a6 i don't know how to
play
maybe take on c5 and
castle or something else
also yeah before bishop b2
i don't want to castle too quickly
but it turns out that
he can
challenge my queen side very quickly
after h3 i thought he will take on b5
then bishop a6 and it might be a draw
but he played
a very strong
move bishop d7 and
it's clear that he's better
wow and that explanation that we just
heard from dingley run he said i could
have played this but i was worried it
might be a draw so he lost his
objectivity he understood how to
evaluate the position but he felt like
he couldn't make a draw because from the
very beginning the game he was playing
for a win
also at the very beginning of the
interview he well he stated that chess
is fair you know
you win some you lose some
and well
well it's me makes me sad
well you know it's interesting because
he felt he was lost yesterday maybe he
analyzed the game donya but you know he
said i scored a victory i shouldn't have
yesterday and so losing today is fair
but
you know yesterday already happened
that's in the past so you know this
karmic balance that he is
discussing i i think that maybe he's
trying to
remain composed and not you know fret
about the game he still has two left but
that was just a really bad game well
he's obviously going to be
really really upset
and he mentioned that knight a6 took him
out of book that's something that he
will be upset about among other things
you know the fact that he he seemed to
overlook a move that had already been
played it had been played many many
times
and it's a very dangerous idea
and you could tell that he you know from
his comments he was flustered after her
job of flight c5 he wasn't sure what to
do and i think it's very important to
point out that ding felt this massive
additional burden
of having to play for a win and that's
constantly in your head the fact that
you have to get a position that's
combative and so certain options as you
could see were rejected by being on the
basis of the fact that he wouldn't have
chances to play through and even if
those options offered objectively the
best chances to keep the balance and one
of those options involved castling
kingside so even when he was in trouble
i think ding subconsciously was trying
to keep winning chances alive and that
merely exacerbated an already dangerous
situation
and i think what he said with his
actions rather than with his words is
that he was playing for first place that
he could have made a quiet peaceful draw
stayed ahead of hikaru nakamura for
second place hope that magnus carlsen
doesn't play the world championship and
then ding gets to face off against yonda
pamashi but he was going for first so he
went for broke and unfortunately for him
his position fell apart completely he
missed tactics early in the game and
i mean you don't see that very often
from dingley wren and it's great that he
still gave an interview and just shows
the type of person he is that he's
willing to talk to the media and talk to
dina despite a really terrible game that
he undoubtedly is quite upset about
well there is there is
date tomorrow so he will be able to
to analyze
not only this game but his future
openings and maybe repair some of the
lines
and we also just don't think of dingley
ren as somebody who gets caught in the
opening that often it happened against
hikaru nakamura but he was so
fundamentally knowledgeable about the
position that even though he spent a lot
of time he handled it perfectly that was
a great game of chess a great display of
countering preparation with calculation
and uh understanding but in this game
after 96 he just fell apart and it
happens to people so it's not just
dingley wren but the second time in this
tournament where dingley wren with the
white pieces
has faced an opponent that just crushes
him and pretty early in the game so
round one and now round 12
dangler and losing with white is not
something you would have filled out on
your bingo before the tournament
no i mean if i'd
heard that uh that he had lost two games
i would have bet a silver dollar that
both of them were with the black pieces
i mean he's one of the most solid
players in modern history he's got
phenomenal opening preparation
this tournament has been crazy hit a 100
game unbeaten streak
case in point
and speaking of unbeaten
we are still following the last
remaining game of the day which is
richard reports dead drawn end game
against fabiano and
we're waiting for richard to give a
check on h7 that's over on your top left
as we look at the bird's eye view
only one decisive game today but not for
lack of trying well maybe for lack of
trying on yanukomichi's part but the
other games have been very colorful
indeed and we have been informed that
the players cannot
uh make a draw by agreement they can
offer a draw before black's 40th move
and that's good that's a start
but still no draw first well i've played
many tournaments where dwarves
were forbidden so you had to play until
the
well the one like how do you call this
the kings are left on the board
the city of
french national championships were was
played under the same rules i think it
increases um
the number of decisive games naturally
yeah no it's true it does and we have a
good comment a good question here from
lost in the woods
what is the first thing the competitors
will eat when they get home from madrid
so almera
you live closest bye well i'm close by
but also i'm coming back to my
restaurant yeah so like
i will basically eat everything
on what is on the menu
that sounds delicious you you know i
know your restaurant is doing well so
look forward to visiting some time donya
what are you gonna eat when you get home
well two things big old-fashioned juicy
american burger okay fries and all the
fixins
and some thai food because that's like
part of my weekly routine i know there
are some typeways in madrid there's
actually one near our hotel but
i don't know if i'm that exci i'm in
that of an experimental mood and also
spanish food is way too good to
allow yourself anything else while in
madrid has been unbelievable i know i'm
gonna eat some good old new york pizza
so when i get home i'm gonna have a
bagel
and i'm gonna have some near pizza
because i'm a new yorker through and
through i know that's the answer that
everybody wants
including our production team who
spammed new york pizza right on the
teleprompter and they're still doing it
yep but i will in fact very much pizza
when i get home in new york and we're
gonna hear them laughing yeah
[Laughter]
and they're still laughing no i just i
didn't say that it's like uh like french
japanese you know oh yeah so that's
that's dominion
sounds delicious honestly so now i'm
getting hungry
yeah me too and richard
has delivered the check on h7 and a
repetition of moves is inevitable as
fabie offers a draw the handshake
happens and the round is officially over
and there was a smile between the two
and that's because they're friends not
because five minute carwana is the least
bit happy about this result we've heard
from richard report in interviews that
you know he's ready to be done with this
tournament fabiano probably feeling much
of the same but he still has a chance
and you could see smiles conversation
these two players know each other very
very well at this point and they are
good friends get along really well
well actually they were in my restaurant
and then played some bug hoes just
together you played bug house with
richard and fabi
who was the fourth player i know there
was also livo naranjan christian
carrillo yeah okay
yeah don't hold back you just told us
two super gm's but you have the best
chess company in the world so you're
saying i won't be the highest rated
player to visit your restaurant so that
makes me less likely to visit it i'm
just kidding
well i couldn't reveal those stories
well i think richard is being
self-deprecating or questioning his
moves he kind of slapped his head he's
like oh i forgot about that or i missed
this and they're just discussing the
game so there is the rest day tomorrow
it's not like they have to rush on out
of here and be fresh for another day of
chess tomorrow but fabiano
you know he has not been having
a good second half of the tournament but
still in relatively good spirits right
he's
con you're having a good conversation
with his buddies so
i wonder how long they're gonna sit here
and this is the longest post-game
conversation we've had yeah probably
and that's what chess players do right
how many games have you played where you
get like
scolded to leave the tournament hall
because you just want to talk about move
14 and how you thought about sacrificing
a pawn but weren't sure if it's good and
then you just get down all these
variations because with engines
it kind of kills that fun because you
see exactly where you went wrong and it
doesn't leave the wonder of chess and
that's always my favorite part and for
these two who love the game
richard's so creative in his style
fabiano an amazing calculator who works
really hard on his openings trying to
find
inroads against his opponent's lines but
this game the fourth and final one here
at round 12 of the 2022 feed of
candidates has come to its conclusion a
draw between these two players and the
third draw of the round they have a
funny story like a small story about
these postmortem analysis like uh petra
kochnoi always accompanied her husband
and was sitting there throughout the
round and even if it lasted for seven
hours but then victor would always
analyze the game and those tournaments
were played on the stage so petra was
coming there and uh like
well
and took his pants and was like just
come on
time to have a dinner
well speaking of pants frodo the fair
wants to know where they can get rich
reports suit i don't have the answer
that question maybe we'll find out where
he does the shopping but it seems like
he says his wife is the one who uh picks
out many of his clothes so we need to
track down ivana i see we do indeed but
we don't need to track down the results
because they're on screen in front of
you timor jabov the player from
azerbaijan scores a huge victory with
the black pieces puts himself in the
running for that potentially important
second place and yonder palm sheet the
tournament leader he secures no worse
than a tie for first even if he loses
his final two games and it seems that
when everyone slows down there have been
three draws it's worth a more you know
changes the gears
that's true and you know he came in here
talked about it he said that he was
trying to fight he's had some really
long games with both colors from better
positions worse positions so timor he
knows that this tournament is grueling
all 14 games but he seems to be
ambitious
absolutely he seems to be high energy
he's happy with his wins he's fueled by
the fact that he's now on 50 he's within
striking distance of second place
imagine that
and uh you know in the pandas nakamura
that was not a surprise for absolutely
anybody and once again nepo secures the
tournament win with a draw
in the next round
a very high level game in report caruana
and for duda and furuga as they stumble
and bumble their way toward the
tournament's conclusion a topsy-turvy
affair or jkd
once again he's been upset with himself
repeatedly throughout this tournament
and he is going to be upset with himself
again because he missed golden
opportunities to deal yet another blow
to ali raza faruja he did the polish
number one could have played a little
bit more accurately to maintain the
advantage but that's neither here nor
there because jan napomneshi is the talk
of madrid in the chess world he is at
eight and a half points after 12 rounds
they're only 14 rounds everybody at home
hope you can do the math two games
remain he's a two-point lead which means
that even if he's to suffer his first
two losses of this event he will still
be at minimum tide and he can only be
tied by one player because hikaru
nakamura and dingley ren they square off
in the 14th and final round which means
that
even if jan loses tomorrow not tomorrow
he's resting so mean he can lose all he
wants that won't impact his tournament
but if he loses round 13 and those
players draw their games tomorrow or
something like that then or you know
he's got this in the bag so i don't
expect him to lose a game he has been so
solid throughout but i mean look at
these standings here alireza and last
yon running away with the tournament
this is surprising and do you think that
playing a richard report with white is
like uh playing against vasily van chuk
so richard can play any opening so jan
is going to study every possible line or
he's simply
going to rest
i think he's going to rest a large part
of the rest day maybe toward the evening
he'll do some preparation i mean 1 e4 is
to be expected he's hoping for a berlin
he would not mind repeating the same
moves
as today's game but it is a scary
matchup i mean it's not necessarily who
he would want to play with white because
i don't think reports playing the berlin
he's got nothing to lose and he's
putting everything that he has out there
on the board so
you know
and a crazy miracle has to happen for
jan not to win the candidates but he's
not going to relax in the sense of
assuming the tournament is in the bag he
knows better than that
what a tournament this has been and
plenty of reasons to watch the last two
rounds even if nepo secures it as these
players are running out of energy they
will put everything else they have left
in the tank out on the chessboard in the
last two rounds so we can expect some
incredible fighting chess we certainly
can because look at these matchups i
think we have to start at the bottom
there team over jabba he wins a good
game against dingley wren he's the white
pieces in the next round against
five-minute caruana but that lifetime
score is as one-sided as you'll see at
this top level
yeah zero five that's a lot to process
not a single win for timur
and uh the odds are in caruana's favor
but the momentum might be on timur's
favor as he feels confident after a win
and fabby will try to score his first
win
of this forgettable second half of the
tournament and elmira i mean with
fabiano sort of playing for a win every
single game that might open the door for
timor to
go ahead of his even score right now and
finally get into the plus territory
well i think that he will go for
once again for a risk-free opening so he
will expect fabit to take risks
once again and i was also looking at the
next matchup ferociously resign against
dingle iran because i was thinking okay
i think he simply needs to play a good
game of chess i result with white and
[Music]
yesterday he lost almost in the same
manner as
dingley ren lost today against timura
jabez he needs to calm himself down and
just to play chess
i think that's true and dingley wren
he'll be waiting there hoping for
alareza to become overly ambitious
because after today's debacle dingley
run would like to score that victory and
nakamura he gets the white pieces
against yon chistop duda duda he's been
better as of late but hikaru has shown
great preparation he didn't even have a
game today which means that he has even
more time to focus on the polish number
one
yeah like you said easy game today rest
day tomorrow he's got the white pieces
he's feeling good he's got his fan base
behind him i see no reason that hikaru
won't put the heat on jkd and let me put
it this way jan kristoff cannot afford
to miss as many chances and commit as
many errors as he did today against ali
raza because hikaru in his current form
isn't going to let that slide and elmira
hickar was maybe the biggest winner of
the day despite not winning his game
because he moves into a tie with dingley
run for a second of course like i'm a
typical chess player what day are we
today
what day of it of the week it's friday
all right it's right so there are no
titles tuesdays tomorrow so hikari is
going to take his time sleepy saturday
there is the rapid chess championship if
he wants to play in that
the saturday oh no there might not be no
no not next not tomorrow i think yeah
they took time off during the candidates
but when i think of saturday and sunday
i think of the rcc so nakamura
we do have rapid chess championship
tomorrow oh we do wow if i had known
that i would have asked a car about that
for sure oh man i mean he you know he
wins those
saturday swimmers
quick draw on sunday you know maybe
he'll win that too i wouldn't put it
past him wow wow wow so we'll see what
hikaru does on his rest day and of
course we have our fourth and
final game i mean that's an important
one jan napomnishi he gets the white
pieces but against richard report he
could probably just try to make a quick
draw and end his tournament with one
round to spare as the victor of the 2022
candidates
we'll see there's only one way to find
out find out find out it's been a long
day a little long week but janupamishi
he's going to rest up and he will try to
lock it up
on sunday that is correct so we look
forward to the future and as we say
goodbye from the 12th round defeated
candidates almira daniel i'm robert but
we do have a great recap of the last two
rounds of action enjoy we'll see you on
sunday
oh
my goodness did we just see a big move
by fobby apparently gtx f6 might have
been a little bit off the edge
yeah i just played for
complication because the rod didn't make
so much sense so
look at this i mean this is just
gorgeous absolutely amazing how are you
feeling about that
i'm going to use the classic line i mean
i literally don't care he's still much
better he has to keep his composure oh
he looks so upset
he's about to lose several pawns and
with the the game
yeah this was this was a complete
collapse fabby blundered queen g3
he completely missed it oh my gosh i
mean you can see hikar he's
not happy right now
is anything coming out of the thermos
it just happened and has anything come
out in the last like three times that
he's poured it hikaru
akara's face is like what in the world
has happened here yeah you can't believe
that is on the defensive do you ever
pretend to drink tea or do you always
actually have tea in your i'll always
have to tell you dania yeah sure
tabiana looked at the board in complete
disbelief it's like what have i done and
he left the playing hall immediately
[Music]
whoa that is trolling that's a joke
that's gotta be the move b3 was played
uh as the ceremonial first move so that
is amusing stuff
dingley wren just made a wow what a
movie he made that looks
terrible oh my gosh his problems
this game is over and the yondu
palmistry will move to eight and a half
out of twelve
yeah i'm trying to at least wait for the
photographers to leave i don't think
it's happening we're about to see a draw
this would be made without the rook the
queen and the knight that is a gorgeous
checkmate this is why you study your
checkmate patterns yeah i think the
players got together and said let's just
play let's just play some kind of tie
breaker um
i think that that would be a reasonable
way to resolve it he is not the happy
ding we've seen over the last three
rounds and his winning streak is about
to come to an end he just played
terribly i mean he knows it's over ding
never quite felt comfortable
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]